GOOD AFTERNOON. MEMBERS OF THE
SENATE WILL COME TO ORDER.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN ALVARADO, GIL. ARCHULETA.
ASHBY. ATKINS BECKER. BLAKE.
SPEER. BRADFORD CABALLERO.
CORTEZ. DALLY DODD. DURAZO.
EGGMAN GLASER. GONZALEZ. GROVE
HURTADO. JONES. LAIRD LIMON.
MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR MIN. NEWMAN.
NGUYEN NILO. OCHOA. PADILLA
PORTANTINO. ROTH. RUBIO CIERTO.
SKINNER. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS
STERN. UMBERG. WAHAB WIENER.
WILK MEMBERS. A QUORUM IS
PRESENT. COULD I ASK THE MEMBERS
TO RETURN TO THEIR DESKS, PLEASE?
WOULD THE MEMBERS AND OUR GUESTS
BEYOND THE RAIL AND IN THE
GALLERY, PLEASE RISE. WE WILL BE
LED IN PRAYER THIS AFTERNOON BY
OUR CHAPLAIN, SISTER MICHELLE.
AFTER WHICH, PLEASE REMAIN
STANDING FOR THE PLEDGE OF
ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG. SISTER
MICHELLE. THANK YOU. AS WE
GATHER TODAY, WE PRAY IN THE
WORDS OF PSALM 19. THE HEAVENS
ARE TELLING THE GLORY OF GOD AND
THEIR EXPANSE IS DECLARING THE
WORK OF GOD'S HANDS. THERE IS NO
SPEECH, NOR ARE THERE WORDS.
THEIR VOICE IS NOT HEARD. YET
THEIR MUSIC GOES OUT THROUGH ALL
THE EARTH AND THEIR UTTERANCES
TO THE END OF THE WORLD. THE LAW
OF THE LORD IS PERFECT,
RESTORING THE SOUL. THE PRECEPTS
OF THE LORD ARE RIGHT. REJOICING
THE HEART. BUT WHO CAN DISCERN
THEIR OWN WEAKNESSES? ACQUIT US,
OH LORD, FROM OUR HIDDEN FAULTS.
LET OUR FEARS NOT HAVE DOMINION
OVER US. THEN SHALL WE BECOME A
BENEFICIAL PRESENCE FREELY AND
FULLY SURRENDERED TO YOUR LOVE.
LOVING GOD MAY THE WORDS OF OUR
MOUTHS AND THE MEDITATIONS OF
OUR HEARTS BE ACCEPTABLE IN YOUR
SIGHT THIS DAY. AMEN THANK YOU,
SISTER MICHELLE. SENATORS, STAFF
AND GUESTS, PLEASE JOIN ME IN
THE PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE. I
PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG OF
THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA,
AND TO THE REPUBLIC FOR WHICH IT
STANDS. ONE NATION UNDER GOD,
INDIVISIBLE, WITH LIBERTY AND
JUSTICE FOR ALL. THIS WILL. ALL
RIGHT. WELL, LET ME JUST SAY
WELCOME THIS AFTERNOON TO
MEMBERS OF THE SENATE AND OUR
GUESTS. I WANT TO GIVE YOU THE
RUN OF THE SHOW FOR THE DAY
TODAY. IT IS THE EXPECTATION OF
OUR SENATE LEADERS THAT WE WILL
COVER ABOUT 100 BILLS TODAY.
WE'RE GOING TO PUT BILLS ON CALL
WHEN THERE'S MEETINGS OFF THE
FLOOR. WE'RE EXPECTING THAT SOME
OF THOSE TO OCCUR AROUND 3:00.
SO UP UNTIL THAT POINT IN TIME,
WE WILL BE GOING THROUGH THE
ROLL TWICE AND CLOSING THE ROLL.
WE ARE EXPECTED TO HAVE A DINNER
BREAK SOMETIME TODAY, BUT WE'RE
GOING TO ASK MEMBERS TO STAY
HERE IN THE CAPITOL DURING THAT
TIME SO THAT WE CAN COME BACK
PROMPTLY AND COMPLETE OUR WORK.
SO OUR ABILITY TO GET OUT OF
HERE AT A REASONABLE HOUR WILL
DEPEND ON OUR EFFICIENCIES
TODAY, AND I WILL DO MY BEST TO
KEEP US ON TRACK. SO WE WILL
BEGIN WITH PRIVILEGES OF THE
FLOOR. THERE ARE NONE. MESSAGES
FROM THE GOVERNOR WILL BE DEEMED
READ, MESSAGES FROM THE ASSEMBLY
WILL BE DEEMED READ, AND REPORTS
OF COMMITTEE WILL BE DEEMED
READ. WE'RE GOING TO MOVE NEXT
TO MOTIONS, RESOLUTIONS AND
NOTICES. WITHOUT OBJECTION, THE
SENATE JOURNALS FOR AUGUST 19TH,
2024 THROUGH AUGUST 22ND, 2024
WILL BE APPROVED AS CORRECTED BY
THE MINUTE CLERK. PURSUANT TO
SENATE RULE 29 DOT TEN, BE. THE
FOLLOWING BILLS ARE REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON RULES. FILE
ITEM 115 AB 3068. FILE ITEM 120
AB 892. FILE ITEM 125, AB 1878,
AND FILE ITEM 150 AB 2496.
PURSUANT TO SENATE RULE 29.10,
SEE. THE FOLLOWING BILLS ARE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
RULES. FILE ITEM 25 AB 535.
RECOGNIZE SENATOR PADILLA. FOR
WHAT PURPOSE DO YOU RISE? MR.
PRESIDENT, I ASK THAT FILE ITEM
286 AB 1635 BY WARD. BE MOVED TO
THE ENACTED FILE AT THE REQUEST
OF THE AUTHOR. THANK YOU. THE
DESK WILL NOTE. ANYTHING ELSE,
ANYTHING FURTHER ON MOTIONS,
RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES. ALL
RIGHT. WE'RE GOING TO MOVE NEXT
TO CONSIDERATION OF THE DAILY
FILE. SECOND READING FILE. THE
CLERK PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY BILL
2348. 1282 2803 1871 3240 2975
2531 1413 32ND READING FILE WILL
BE DEEMED READ. WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE NEXT TO GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTMENTS. WE HAVE A NUMBER
OF THEM ON OUR SCHEDULE TODAY.
THEY'RE GOING TO BE PRESENTED BY
SENATOR GROVE. FIRST UP IS FILE
ITEM 190. SECRETARY PLEASE READ
NÓ. YOU DON'T. OKAY. ALL RIGHT.
WE'LL HAVE THE PRESENTATION BY
SENATOR GROVE. THE FLOOR IS
YOURS. SENATOR GROVE. THANK YOU,
MR. PRESIDENT. COLLEAGUES FILE
ITEM 140 IS THE CONFIRMATION OF
AMY COSTA FOR THE APPOINTMENT OF
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
BOARD OF GOVERNORS. SHE WAS
FIRST APPOINTED IN 2018 AND
CURRENTLY SERVES AS THE BOARD
PRESIDENT. MISS COSTA IS A
PUBLIC POLICY ADVOCATE AND
CONSULTANT. SHE HAS A LONG, VERY
LONG CAREER IN THE STATE AND
LOCAL GOVERNMENT, INCLUDING
SERVING AS THE CHIEF DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE UNDER THE BROWN
ADMINISTRATION. SHE WAS APPROVED
ON BY THE RULES COMMITTEE ON
AUGUST 7TH ON A50 VOTE.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
ANY DISCUSSION ON THIS
NOMINATION? ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION? SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN. ALVARADO. GILL. AYE.
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY ATKINS.
AYE. BECKER BLAKE. SPEER. AYE.
BRADFORD. AYE. CABALLERO.
CORTEZ. AYE. DALY. AYE. DODD.
AYE. DURAZO. EGGMAN. AYE.
GLAZER. AYE. GONZALEZ. AYE.
GROVE. AYE. HURTADO. AYE. JONES.
AYE. LAIRD LIMÓN. AYE. MCGUIRE
AYE. MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN. AYE.
NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN. AYE. NILO.
OCHOA PADILLA. AYE. PORTANTINO.
AYE. ROTH. RUBIO AYE. SEYARTO
AYE. SKINNER. AYE. SMALLWOOD
CUEVAS. STERN. UMBERG. WAHAB
WIENER. AYE. WILK. SENATOR GROVE
MOVES A CALL. WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE NEXT TO FILE ITEM 193.
NOMINATE A NOMINEE TO THE BOARD
OF FORESTRY. SENATOR GROVE. HI.
THANK YOU, SIR. MADAM. OR EXCUSE
ME, MR. PRESIDENT. FILE ITEM 193
IS THE CONFIRMATION OF KATHRYN
DELBAR FOR REAPPOINTMENT TO THE
BOARD OF FORESTRY AND FIRE
PROTECTION. MISS DELBAR RETIRED
FROM THE U.S. DEPARTMENT OF
AGRICULTURE AFTER 33 YEARS OF
SERVICE. AND SHE IS A PARTNER IN
THE AND RANCHER AT EDDY RANCH
PROPERTIES. SHE FIRST JOINED THE
BOARD IN 2017 AND SERVES THE
RANGE LIVESTOCK INDUSTRY
REPRESENTATIVE, AND SHE WAS
APPROVED BY THE RULES COMMITTEE
ON AUGUST 14TH ON A50 VOTE.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. SENATOR GROVE,
ANY DISCUSSION ON THIS NOMINEE?
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION? SEEING
NONE. SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN ALVARADO. GILL AYE.
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY ATKINS.
AYE. BECKER AYE. BLAKE SPEER.
BRADFORD. AYE. CABALLERO.
CORTEZ. AYE. DALY AYE. DODD.
AYE. DURAZO. EGGMAN. AYE.
GLAZER. AYE. GONZALEZ. AYE.
GROVE. AYE. HURTADO. AYE. JONES.
AYE. LAIRD LIMON. AYE. MCGUIRE
MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN. AYE. NEWMAN.
AYE. NGUYEN. AYE NHIÀU. OCHOA.
BOGH. PADILLA AYE. PORTANTINO.
AYE ROTH. RUBIO. AYE SEYARTO.
AYE. SKINNER. AYE SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. AYE. STERN. UMBERG.
WAHAB. WIENER AYE. WILK SENATOR
GROVE MOVES A CALL. WE'RE GOING
TO MOVE NEXT TO FILE ITEM 194.
SENATOR GROVE. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. COLLEAGUES, FILE ITEM
194 IS THE CONFIRMATION OF THE
FOLLOWING REGIONAL WATER CONTROL
BOARD APPOINTEES. DOCTOR ROBERT
PEARCE, FOR THE LU T BOARD,
MARISSA CHRISTENSEN FOR THE LOS
ANGELES BOARD AND WILLIAM
KISSINGER. MARK RANSOM AND
ALEXIS STROSACKER FOR THE SAN
FRANCISCO BAY REGIONAL BOARD.
THEY WERE APPROVED BY THE RULES
COMMITTEE ON A50 VOTE ON AUGUST
15TH. RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. SENATOR
GROVE, ANY DISCUSSION ON THESE
NOMINEES? ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION? SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN ALVARADO. AYE. ARCHULETA.
AYE. ASHBY ATKINS. AYE. BECKER.
AYE. BLAKE. SPEER. BRADFORD.
AYE. CABALLERO. CORTEZ. AYE.
DALY. AYE. DODD. AYE. DURAZO.
EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER. AYE.
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE. AYE.
HURTADO. AYE. JONES. AYE. LAIRD.
LEHMAN. AYE. MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR
AYE. MIN. AYE. NEWMAN. AYE.
NGUYEN. AYE. NILO OCHOA. PADILLA
PORTANTINO. AYE. ROTH. RUBIO.
AYE. SEYARTO. AYE. SKINNER. AYE.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE. STERN.
UMBERG. WAHAB WIENER. AYE. WILK
SENATOR GROVE MOVES A CALL.
MEMBERS. WE'RE GOING TO GO NEXT
TO ASSEMBLY THIRD READING, AND
I'LL TRY TO GIVE YOU A HEADS UP
OF THE BILLS THAT ARE COMING IN
LINE. SO WE'RE GOING TO BEGIN AT
ITEM 213, FOLLOWED BY FILE ITEM
214, 216 TO 19 AND 225. SO THOSE
ARE THE NEXT FIVE ON THE DOCKET.
WE'LL BEGIN WITH FILE ITEM 213.
THIS IS ASSEMBLY BILL 1946,
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
BILL 1946 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ALANIS. AN ACT RELATING TO HORSE
RACING. WE WILL TURN TO THE
FLOOR. MANAGER, SENATOR DODD.
THE FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK YOU,
MR. PRESIDENT. MEMBERS, TODAY
I'M PRESENTING AB 1946 ON BEHALF
OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER ALANIS. THIS
BILL AIMS TO ALLOW CALIFORNIA
RACING FAIRS AND SATELLITE
FACILITIES TO INCLUDE THIS
PRESTIGIOUS RACE EVENT.
CALIFORNIA'S 50 RACES PER DAY
OFFERINGS, THEREBY SUPPORTING
REVENUE GROWTH, BENEFITING LOCAL
BUSINESS, AND GENERATING MORE
JOB OPPORTUNITIES WITHIN THE
INDUSTRY. THE BILL PASSED WITH
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT OUT OF SENATE
GEO. THANK YOU, AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU. SENATOR DODD. ANY
DISCUSSION ON THIS MEASURE, ANY
DISCUSSION? SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN ALVARADO. GIL. AYE.
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY. ATKINS.
AYE. BECKER. AYE. BLAKE. SPEER.
BRADFORD. AYE. CABALLERO. CORTEZ
AYE. DALY. AYE. DODD AYE.
DURAZO. EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER.
AYE. GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE. AYE.
HURTADO. AYE. JONES. AYE. LAIRD
LIMON. AYE. MCGUIRE MENGIBAR.
AYE. MIN. AYE. NEWMAN. AYE.
NGUYEN. AYE. NILO. OCHOA. AYE.
PADILLA. AYE. PORTANTINO. AYE.
ROTH. RUBIO. AYE. CIERTO AYE.
SKINNER. AYE. SMALLWOOD CUEVAS.
AYE. STERN UMBERG. WAHAB WIENER.
AYE. WILK SENATOR DODD MOVES A
CALL. WE'RE GOING TO MOVE NEXT
TO FILE ITEM 214. ASSEMBLY BILL
2898. SECRETARY, PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL 2898 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WENDY CARRILLO. AN ACT
RELATING TO TENANCIES. SENATOR
WIENER. AYE. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. COLLEAGUES, I RISE TO
PRESENT AB 2898 ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WENDY CARRILLO,
THIS BILL EXEMPTS ANY
RESIDENTIAL UNIT LEASED TO A
TENANT WHO RECEIVES A FEDERAL
HOUSING CHOICE VOUCHER,
INCLUDING A VETERAN AFFAIRS
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING VOUCHER FROM
A PREVIOUS LAW, AB 1373. THE
UNBUNDLED PARKING LAW AB 2898 IS
HAS BEEN REQUESTED BY THE
ADMINISTRATION AS A TECHNICAL
CHANGE TO THE PREVIOUS LAW. THE
ADMINISTRATION HIGHLIGHTED THE
NEED TO EXEMPT VOUCHER HOLDERS
GIVEN FEDERAL REGULATIONS.
PUBLIC HOUSING AUTHORITIES. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
ANY DISCUSSION ON THIS MEASURE,
ANY DISCUSSION. MEMBERS SEEING
NONE. SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN ALVARADO. AYE.
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY ATKINS.
AYE. BECKER. AYE BLAKE. SPEER.
BRADFORD. AYE. CABALLERO CORTEZ.
AYE. DALI. AYE DODD. AYE. DURAZO
EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER. AYE
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE. AYE ORTEZ.
AYE. JONES LAIRD. LIMON. AYE
MAGUIRE. MENGIBAR. AYE MIN. AYE.
NEWMAN. AYE NGUYEN. AYE. NILO.
OCHOA BORG. AYE. PADILLA. AYE
PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH RUBIO. AYE.
CIERTO AYE. SKINNER. AYE.
SMALLWOOD CUEVAS. AYE. STERN
UMBERG. WAHAB. WIENER AYE. AYE.
WILK SEN. WIENER. MOVES A CALL.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE NEXT TO FILE
ITEM 216. ASSEMBLY BILL 1940.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
BILL 1940 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER,
VILLA PADUA. AN ACT RELATING TO
ALCOHOLIC BEVERAGES. SENATOR
DODD. THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT,
AND MEMBERS AB 1940 WOULD ALLOW
DISTRIBUTORS TO EXCHANGE A
DISCONTINUED OR SEASONED BRAND
OF BEER WHEN THE ORIGINAL BEER
MANUFACTURER HAS CEASED DOING
BUSINESS. THIS CHANGE WILL ALLOW
BEER DISTRIBUTORS TO ENSURE THAT
CONSUMERS ARE PROVIDED A BEER
THAT IS FRESH AND NOT OUT OF
CODE. IT HAS RECEIVED STRONG
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT. RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR VOTE. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION ON THIS MEASURE ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION? SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN ALVARADO GILL. AYE.
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY ATKINS.
AYE. BECKER. AYE. BLAKE. SPEER.
BRADFORD. AYE. CABALLERO. CORTEZ
AYE. DALLY. I DODD. AYE. DURAZO.
EGGMAN AYE. GLAZER. AYE. AYE.
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE. AYE.
HURTADO. AYE JONES. AYE. LAIRD.
LIMON AYE. MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR.
AYE MIN. AYE. NEWMAN. AYE
NGUYEN. AYE. NHIÀU. OCHOA.
JONES
Ã LAIRD. LEHMAN I. MCGUIRE
MENGIBAR I. MIN NEUMANN, I.
NGUYEN I. NILO. OCHOA I. PADILLA
I. PORTANTINO I. ROTH RUBIO, I.
SEYARTO I. SKINNER, I.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS, I. STERN.
UMBERG WAHAB. WIENER I. WILK.
SEN. DOLLY. MOVES A CALL.
MEMBERS. WE'RE GOING TO GO NEXT
TO FILE ITEM 225. IT'S GOING TO
BE FOLLOWED BY FILE ITEM 233,
243, 244 AND 250. WE'RE GOING TO
TURN NEXT TO FILE ITEM 225 AB
1890. WE'RE SKIPPING.
ALL RIGHT. WE'RE GOING TO JUMP
AROUND JUST A LITTLE BIT. WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE NEXT TO FILE ITEM
233. THE ASSEMBLY BILL 772.
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL 772 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
JACKSON AND ACT RELATING TO CARE
FACILITIES FOR MANAGERS. SENATOR
LIEBERMAN, SENATOR LIEBERMAN,
THE FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK YOU,
MR. PRESIDENT. AND COLLEAGUES, I
RISE TO PRESENT AB 772, WHICH
SEEKS TO ADD A PHYSICIAN'S
ASSISTANT ASSESSMENT TO THE LIST
OF EXEMPTIONS FOR NON-CONTRACT
CHILD CARE, CHILD DAY CARE
CENTERS. AB 772 CLARIFIES THAT
UPON ADMISSION OF A CHILD INTO A
DROP IN CHILD CARE CENTER, IF A
MEDICAL ASSESSMENT IS NOT
AVAILABLE FOR A CHILD AS
REQUIRED BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
REGULATIONS, THEN THE LICENSEE
SHALL OBTAIN A WRITTEN HEALTH
ASSESSMENT COMPLETED BY THE
CHILD'S AUTHORIZED
REPRESENTATIVE. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. MEMBERS.
DISCUSSION ON THIS MEASURE.
DISCUSSION ON THIS MEASURE. OKAY
SEEING NO FURTHER DISCUSSION.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN ALVARADO. GIL AYE.
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY ATKINS.
AYE. BECKER AYE. BLAKE. SPEER.
AYE. BRADFORD. AYE. CABALLERO.
CORTEZ AYE. DALY DODD. DALY.
AYE. DODD. AYE. DURAZO. EGGMAN
AYE. GLAZER. AYE. GONZALEZ. AYE.
GROVE AYE. HURTADO. AYE. JONES.
AYE. LAIRD LIMON. AYE. MCGUIRE.
AYE. MENGIBAR AYE. MIN. AYE
NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN. AYE. NILO.
OCHOA. BOGH AYE. PADILLA. AYE.
PORTANTINO. AYE. ROTH RUBIO.
AYE. SEYARTO AYE. SKINNER. AYE.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE. STERN.
UMBERG. WAHAB. WIENER AYE. WILK
SENATOR LIMON MOVES A CALL.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE NEXT TO FILE
ITEM 243. THIS IS ASSEMBLY BILL
2300. SECRETARY, PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER, 2300 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WILSON. AN ACT
RELATING TO PRODUCT SAFETY.
SENATOR MIN IS CARRYING THIS
ITEM. SENATOR MIN. THANK YOU,
MR. PRESIDENT. ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLYWOMAN WILSON, I PRESENT
AB 2300 WHICH WOULD PROHIBIT THE
MANUFACTURE, SALE OR
DISTRIBUTION OF INTRAVENOUS
SOLUTION CONTAINERS AND TUBING
MADE WITH INTENTIONALLY ADDED
DYE DEFEATED ON DHP. THIS
CHEMICAL HAS BEEN FOUND TO
MIGRATE FROM IV BAGS AND TUBING
INTO MEDICATIONS AND OTHER
FLUIDS ADMINISTERED TO PATIENTS.
DHP CAN NEGATIVELY AFFECT THE
THYROID AND IMMUNE SYSTEMS.
RESEARCH HAS SUGGESTED IT MAY
CONTRIBUTE TO DRUG RESISTANCE
AND REDUCE THE EFFECTIVENESS OF
BREAST CANCER TREATMENTS, AND IS
ITSELF LINKED TO HIGHER RATES OF
CANCER RECURRENCE AND MORTALITY.
THE POSITIVE NEWS WE HAVE IS
THAT SAFER ALTERNATIVES ARE
AVAILABLE AND ARE ALREADY BEING
UTILIZED IN FDA APPROVED DEHP
FREE IV BAGS. AB 2300 WOULD
ENSURE THAT CALIFORNIA IS AHEAD
OF THE CURVE AND IMMEDIATELY
REDUCING PATIENT CONTACT WITH
DEHP. I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. SENATOR
MIN. SENATOR JONES, THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. THIS
IS A VERY IMPORTANT BILL. I
THINK I'M IN FAVOR OF IT. COULD
WE GET THE QUESTION FOR THE
AUTHOR? I SUPPOSE? COULD HE
RESTATE THE CHEMICAL COMPOUNDS
THAT ARE IN THIS BILL SO THAT I
CAN KNOW WHAT I'M. I WANT TO
MAKE SURE I'M VOTING PROPERLY ON
THIS TODAY. THANK YOU. SENATOR
JONES, SENATOR MIN, WOULD YOU
TAKE A QUESTION? I CAN TRY. IT
IS INTENTIONALLY ADDED
DIETHYLHEXYL PHTHALATE. NOT SURE
IF THAT'S IN ORDER OR OUT OF
ORDER. COULD YOU SAY IT AGAIN?
MR. PRESIDENT? AGAIN. TWICE.
FAST I DON'T THINK I CAN DO
THAT, SIR. ALL RIGHT, SENATOR
JONES, ANY FURTHER COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS? THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. I APPRECIATE THAT. I
THINK THAT ALMOST NEARLY HITS
THE NAIL RIGHT ON THE HEAD AND
ANSWERS MY QUESTION. I WILL BE
SUPPORTIVE OF THE BILL. SENATOR
JONES, WOULD YOU LIKE TO GIVE IT
A TRY? NO, SIR. I THOUGHT SO.
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION ON THIS
MEASURE? SEEING NONE, SENATOR
MIN, YOU MAY CLOSE. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
ALL RIGHT. ALL DEBATE HAVING
CEASED. SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALAN. ALVARADO. GILL.
AYE. ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER AYE. BLAKE.
SPEAR. AYE. BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO. CORTEZ. AYE. DALY.
AYE. DODD. AYE. DURAZO. EGGMAN.
AYE. GLAZER. AYE. GONZALEZ. AYE.
GROVE AYE. HURTADO. AYE. JONES
AYE. LAIRD. LEHMAN AYE. MCGUIRE
MENGIBAR. I'M IN. AYE. NEWMAN.
AYE. NGUYEN. AYE. NHIÀU. OCHOA.
BOGH. AYE. PADILLA. AYE.
PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH. RUBIO AYE.
CIERTO. AYE. SKINNER. AYE.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE. STERN.
UMBERG. WAHAB WIENER. AYE. WILK
SENATOR MIN MOVES THE CALL.
MEMBERS. AS I'M SURE YOU'RE
AWARE, WE DO HAVE A COMMITTEE
HEARING THAT'S CONTINUING TO GO
ON. SO WE HAVE MEMBERS OFF THE
FLOOR. SO WE WILL CONTINUE TO
PUT MEASURES ON CALL. APPRECIATE
YOUR PATIENCE AS WE JUMP AROUND
THE AGENDA FOR THOSE MEMBERS WHO
ARE NOT HERE TO PRESENT THEIR
BILLS YET, WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
NEXT TO FILE ITEM 244. THIS IS
ASSEMBLY BILL 2046. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL 2046
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER BRYANT. AN
ACT RELATING TO EDUCATIONAL
PROGRAMS. SENATOR BRADFORD.
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. AB
2046 AND I'M DOING THIS ON
BEHALF OF ASSEMBLYMAN BRYANT,
WHICH EXTENDS THE SUNSET DATE
FOR THE AUTHORIZATION OF SINGLE
GENDER SCHOOLS AND CLASSES IN
LOS ANGELES IN 2017. AB 23
UNANIMOUSLY PASSED TO ALLOW
LAUSD TO CONTINUE OPERATING
THEIR PILOT PROGRAM TO ADDRESS
SPECIFIC EDUCATIONAL GOALS AND
HAVE A BIANNUAL EVALUATION TO
TRACK THEIR RESULTS. THESE
SCHOOLS WERE ESTABLISHED TO
SUPPORT EDUCATIONAL EQUITY BY
INCREASING THE REPRESENTATION OF
WOMEN AND MINORITIES IN THE STEM
AND LEADERSHIP ROLES. THE
EVALUATION DURING THE PILOT
PERIOD WAS IMPACTED BY COVID 19
PANDEMIC. EXTENDING THE SUNSET
DATES ALLOWS MORE COMPREHENSIVE
AND UNINTERRUPTED EVALUATIONS.
THIS IS RECEIVED BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. SENATOR
BRADFORD, ANY DISCUSSION ON THIS
MEASURE? ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION?
SEEING NONE. SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN ALVARADO.
GIL ARCHULETA. AYE ASHBY.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD. AYE
CABALLERO. CORTEZ. AYE. DALY
AYE. DODD AYE. DALY. I DON'T
KNOW DURAZO. EGGMAN AYE. GLASER.
AYE. AYE. GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE.
NO. HURTADO AYE. JONES. NO.
LAIRD LIMON. AYE. MCGUIRE
MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN. AYE.
NEUMANN. AYE. NGUYEN NO. NIETO.
OCHOA. BORG PADILLA. AYE
PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH RUBIO. AYE
SATO. NO. SKINNER AYE.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE STERN.
UMBERG WAHAB. AYE. WIENER AYE.
WILK SENATOR BRADFORD MOVES A
CALL. WE'RE GOING TO MOVE NEXT
TO FILE ITEM 252. THIS IS
ASSEMBLY BILL 2402. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL 2402
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOWENTHAL. AN
ACT RELATING TO ALCOHOLIC
BEVERAGES. SENATOR LEÓN THANK
YOU COLLEAGUES, I RISE ON BEHALF
OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOWENTHAL TO
PRESENT AB 2402, WHICH REQUIRES
THE DEPARTMENT OF ALCOHOLIC
BEVERAGE CONTROL TO INCLUDE
TRAINING ON ADDRESSING AND
PREVENTING CASES OF DRINK
SPIKING INTO EXISTING
RESPONSIBLE BEVERAGE SERVICES,
TRAINING THAT ARE OFFERED TO
RESTAURANT, BAR AND NIGHTCLUB
STAFF. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. MEMBERS. ANY
DISCUSSION? ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION ON THIS MEASURE? ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION ON THIS
MEASURE? SEEING NONE. SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN.
ALVARADO. GILL. AYE ARCHULETA.
AYE. ASHBY AYE. ATKINS. AYE.
BECKER. AYE. BLAKE. SPEER. AYE.
BRADFORD. AYE. CABALLERO CORTEZ.
AYE. DALLEY AYE. DODD AYE.
DURAZO. EGGMAN. AYE. GLASER.
AYE. GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE. AYE.
HURTADO. AYE. JONES. AYE. LAIRD.
AYE. LIMON. AYE. MCGUIRE
MENGIBAR. I'M IN. AYE. NEWMAN.
AYE. NGUYEN NILO. OCHOA. BOGH.
AYE. PADILLA. AYE. PORTANTINO
AYE. ROTH. RUBIO AYE. SEYARTO.
AYE. SKINNER. AYE. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS AYE. STERN. AYE UMBERG.
WAHAB AYE. WIENER AYE. WILK
WHEN? AYE MILO. AYE.
SECRETARY. CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. ALLEN CABALLERO. AYE.
DURAZO. OKAY MCGUIRE. ROTH
UMBERG. WILK. SENATE-TV. LIMON
MOVES A CALL. ALL RIGHT, WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE NEXT. WE'RE GOING
TO. WE'RE GOING TO MOVE NEXT TO
FILE ITEM 257. ASSEMBLY BILL
2743. SECRETARY PLEASE READ
ASSEMBLY BILL 2743 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER PACHECO. AN ACT RELATING
TO INSURANCE. SENATOR DODD,
PLEASE GIVE SENATOR DODD YOUR
ATTENTION. MEMBERS. THANK YOU,
MISTER PRESIDENT. MEMBERS, ON
BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PACHECO, I'M PLEASED TO PRESENT
ASSEMBLY BILL 2743 AB 2743,
WHICH HAS RECEIVED BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT, ADDRESSES THE
SIGNIFICANT INCREASE IN
FINANCIAL RESPONSIBILITY LIMITS
FOR THE PEER TO PEER CAR
SHARING, WHICH ARE SET TO RISE
ON JANUARY FIRST, 2025, DUE TO
AN UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCE OF
PREVIOUS LEGISLATION. FINANCIAL
LIMITS FOR PEER TO PEER CAR
SHARING PLATFORMS ARE ALREADY
THREE TIMES THOSE OF PERSONAL
VEHICLES. AB 2743 MAINTAINS
INSURANCE AT THAT THREE TIMES
THE STATE MINIMUM, ENSURING THE
PEER TO PEER CAR SHARING REMAINS
VIABLE AND BENEFICIAL FOR BOTH
USERS AND PROVIDERS. WITHOUT
IMPOSING EXCESSIVE FINANCIAL
BURDENS. THIS VERSION OF THE
BILL REFLECTS MONTHS OF WORK
WITH CONSUMER ADVOCATES AND
INSURANCE EXPERTS, AND PEER TO
PEER CAR SHARING PLATFORMS, I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. MEMBERS, ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION ON THIS MEASURE? ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION? IF EVERYONE
PARTICIPATES IN THIS VOTE, WE
COULD CREATE A UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL POTENTIALLY. SO, SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN
ALVARADO GILL. AYE. ARCHULETA.
AYE. ASHBY ATKINS. AYE. BECKER
AYE. BLAKE. SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD
AYE. CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ AYE.
DALY. AYE. DODD AYE. DURAZO. AYE
EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER. AYE. AYE
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE AYE.
HURTADO. AYE. JONES LAIRD. AYE.
LIMON. AYE. MCGUIRE MENGIBAR.
AYE MIN. NEWMAN AYE. NGUYEN.
AYE. NILLO. AYE. OCHOA BORG.
AYE. PADILLA AYE. PORTANTINO.
AYE. ROTH AYE. RUBIO AYE.
SEYARTO AYE. SKINNER. AYE.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS AYE. STERN.
AYE UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB WIENER.
AYE. WILK. AYE. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ASHBY AYE.
MCGUIRE AYE. MIN WAHAB. NOT
VOTING. OKAY. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS ONE LAST TIME.
AND THEN WE'RE GOING TO CLOSE
THE ROLL. MIN. WAHAB ON A VOTE
OF 38 TO 0, THE MEASURE PASSES.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE NEXT TO FILE
ITEM 254. THIS IS ASSEMBLY BILL
2624. SECRETARY, PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL 2624 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WALDRON. AN ACT RELATING
TO PRISONERS. SENATOR DURAZO,
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. ON
BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WALDRON, I PRESENT THIS BILL,
WHICH WILL IMPLEMENT THREE DAYS
OF GRIEF TIME FOR INCARCERATED
INDIVIDUALS IN THE PASSING OF A
CLOSE FAMILY MEMBER. EVERY
INDIVIDUAL DESERVES THE RIGHT TO
GRIEVE A NEED THAT GOES BEYOND
THE WALLS OF INCARCERATION BY
INTRODUCING SECTION 2710 TO THE
PENAL CODE, A CRUCIAL STEP IS
TAKEN TOWARDS SUPPORTING
INDIVIDUALS DEALING WITH
DEVASTATING LOSS. THIS PROVISION
WILL ENSURE INCARCERATED
INDIVIDUALS ARE ABLE TO GRIEVE
FOR THREE DAYS WITH DIGNITY,
UNBURDENED FROM THE WEIGHT OF
THEIR WORK DUTIES, WITHOUT
FINANCIAL CONCERN, BY ALLOWING
THEM TO FOCUS SOLELY ON THE
GRIEVING PROCESS, IT
DEMONSTRATES A COMMITMENT TO
TREAT ALL INDIVIDUALS WITH
EMPATHY, REGARDLESS OF THEIR
CIRCUMSTANCES. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU. SENATOR DURAZO, ANY
DISCUSSION ON THIS MEASURE, ANY
DISCUSSION ON THIS MEASURE?
SEEING NONE. SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN. AYE.
ALVARADO. GILL ARCHULETA. AYE.
ASHBY AYE. ATKINS. AYE. BECKER
AYE. BLAKE. SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD
AYE. CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ. AYE
DALLI. AYE. DODD DURAZO. AYE.
EGGMAN AYE. GLAZER. AYE
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE. AYE.
HURTADO. AYE. JONES AYE. LAIRD.
AYE. LIMON AYE. MCGUIRE.
MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN AYE. NEWMAN.
AYE. NGUYEN AYE. NILO. AYE.
OCHOA. BOG AYE. PADILLA. AYE.
PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH AYE. RUBIO
SEYARTO. AYE. SKINNER. AYE.
SMALLWOOD CUEVAS. AYE. STERN.
AYE UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB AYE.
WIENER. AYE. WILK AYE. BECAUSE
ALL THE SENATORS ARE ON THE
FLOOR, WE'RE GOING TO GO THROUGH
THE ROLL ONE MORE TIME, AND THEN
WE'RE GOING TO CLOSE IT.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ALVARADO, GO.
DODD. AYE MCGUIRE. RUBIO AYE. ON
A VOTE OF 38 TO 0, THE MEASURE
PASSES. WE'RE GOING TO MOVE NEXT
TO FILE ITEM 250. ASSEMBLY BILL
2327. SECRETARY, PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL 2327 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WENDY CARRILLO. AN ACT
RELATING TO HEALING ARTS.
SENATOR ALLEN. THANK YOU, MISTER
PRESIDENT. MEMBERS, I RISE ON
BEHALF OF OUR COLLEAGUE TO
PRESENT AB 2327, WHICH IS A BILL
THAT WILL ENABLE CHARITABLE
ORGANIZATIONS TO CONTINUE TO
OFFER OPTOMETRIC SERVICES FREE
OF CHARGE FOR UNDERPRIVILEGED
YOUNG PEOPLE ACROSS THE STATE.
THIS EXPANDS LEGISLATION FROM
2019 THAT ALLOWED FOR THE
OPERATION OF MOBILE OPTOMETRY
OFFICES BY NONPROFIT CHARITABLE
ENTITIES SUCH AS VISION TO
LEARN, AS LONG AS THESE ENTITIES
PROVIDED SERVICES TO PATIENTS
REGARDLESS OF THEIR ABILITY TO
PAY. VISION TO LEARN IS A GREAT
ORGANIZATION WITH A SIMPLE
MISSION, A SIMPLE MISSION
PROVIDING FREE VISION CARE TO
UNDERPRIVILEGED STUDENTS IN
TITLE ONE SCHOOLS, AND THEY'VE
DELIVERED OVER 200,000 FREE
PAIRS OF GLASSES TO STUDENTS
ACROSS OUR STATE, RELYING
PRIMARILY ON FUNDS RAISED FROM
PRIVATE DONORS. I ASKED FOR AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU, SENATOR
ALLEN. ANY DISCUSSION ON THIS
MEASURE, ANY DISCUSSION? SEEING
NONE. SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN. AYE ALVARADO. AYE.
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER. AYE BLAKE.
SPEAR. AYE. BRADFORD. AYE
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ. AYE.
DALY AYE. DODD. AYE. DURAZZO
AYE. EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER. AYE.
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE. AYE.
HURTADO. AYE. JONES. AYE. LAIRD.
AYE. LIMON. AYE MCGUIRE.
MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN AYE. NEWMAN.
AYE. NGUYEN AYE. NILO. AYE.
OCHOA AYE. PADILLA. AYE.
PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH. I RUBIO.
AYE. SEYARTO. AYE. SKINNER. AYE.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE. STERN
AYE. UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB. AYE.
WIENER. AYE. WILK. AYE.
AYES 39. NOS. ZERO. THE MEASURE
PASSES. SENATOR GROVE, FOR WHAT
PURPOSE DO YOU RISE? JUST A
LITTLE EXERCISE. ALL RIGHT? ALL
RIGHT, MEMBERS, THE INTENTIONS
NOW ARE TO START AT 263,
FOLLOWED BY FILE ITEM 264, TWO
7272 AND 273. SO AUTHORS, FLOOR
MANAGERS, PLEASE BE PREPARED. SO
NEXT UP, FILE ITEM 263 ASSEMBLY
BILL 2484. SECRETARY, PLEASE
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL 2484 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BRYANT. AN ACT
TO COURTS.
ALL RIGHT. WE'RE GOING TO PAUSE.
263 FILE ITEM 263 FOR A MOMENT.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE NEXT TO FILE
ITEM 264. THIS IS ASSEMBLY BILL
3100. SECRETARY, PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL 3100 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LOWE. AN ACT RELATING TO
MORTGAGE LOANS. SENATOR GROVE.
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. I
THOUGHT I WAS CORRECT, BUT I LET
YOU HAVE A LITTLE BIT OF LEEWAY.
GOOD AFTERNOON, PRESIDENT AND
SENATORS. TODAY I'M REPRESENTING
AB 3100, WHICH WOULD ALLEVIATE
THE BURDEN PLACED ON SOME
INDIVIDUALS GOING THROUGH A
DIVORCE BY ALLOWING ONE MEMBER
OF THE COUPLE TO ASSUME THE
MORTGAGE IF THEY MEET THE
NECESSARY QUALIFICATIONS. THIS
IS AN IMPORTANT BILL TO HELP
COMBAT FINANCIAL BURDENS AND
HURDLES THAT ARE OFTEN FACED IN
DIVORCE PROCEEDINGS. WORRYING
ABOUT THE ROOF OVER YOUR HEAD
AND DEALING WITH SUCH A
DIFFICULT TIME IS HARD ENOUGH,
AND THIS WILL HELP ALLEVIATE
SOME OF THOSE CONCERNS. AB 3100
OFFERS PRACTICAL SOLUTIONS TO
EASE THE FINANCIAL CHALLENGES OF
DIVORCE BY ENSURING THAT
ELIGIBLE INDIVIDUALS CAN ASSUME
THEIR MORTGAGE. RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR VOTE ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOWE. SENATOR
GROVE, THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION AND YOUR ATTENTION.
MEMBERS, ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
ON THIS MATTER, ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION? IT IS ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. WITHOUT
OBJECTION. AYES 39. NO ZERO. THE
MEASURE PASSES. WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE NEXT TO FILE ITEM 270. THIS
IS ASSEMBLY BILL 1953. OUR FLOOR
MANAGERS, SENATOR CORTEZ,
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
BILL 1953 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER,
VILLA PADUA, AN ACT TO VEHICLES.
SENATOR CORTESE, THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. I'M PROUD TO PRESENT
AB 1953 TODAY ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER, VILLA PADUA, AB
1953 IS A TECHNICAL CLEANUP OF
THE VEHICLE CODE AND IT
CLARIFIES THAT ZERO AND NEAR
ZERO EMISSION TRUCK AND TRAILER
COMBINATIONS ARE AUTHORIZED TO
OPERATE OPERATE UP TO A MAXIMUM
COMBINED GROSS VEHICLE WEIGHT
RATING OF 82,000 POUNDS. THESE
CHANGES WILL CREATE PARITY WITH
FEDERAL STATUTE. THANK YOU. AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. MEMBERS, ANY DISCUSSION ON
THIS MEASURE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER,
VILLA PADUA. VÆ. VALLAPUDUA. ALL
RIGHT. GOING TO PRACTICE THAT.
ALL RIGHT. THIS IS ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL MEMBERS
WITHOUT OBJECTION. AYES 30 900.
THE MEASURE PASSES. WE'RE GOING
TO MOVE NEXT TO FILE ITEM 272.
ASSEMBLY BILL 262. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY BILL 262 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER HOLDEN. AN ACT
RELATING TO CHILDREN'S CAMPS.
SENATOR HURTADO. THANK YOU.
PLEASE GIVE SENATOR HURTADO YOUR
ATTENTION, PLEASE. SENATOR
HURTADO, THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. I RISE TO PRESENT
MEMBER HOLDEN'S AB 262. THE
RECENT AMENDMENTS COME FROM
COLLABORATION WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION ON THIS IMPORTANT
ISSUE, AND CHILDREN FROM ALL
OVER CALIFORNIA ATTENDED
THOUSANDS OF CAMPS THIS PAST
SUMMER. BUT UNFORTUNATELY,
IMPORTANT SAFEGUARDS ARE STILL
LACKING, AND CENTRALIZED
ENFORCEMENT OF CURRENT CAMP
SAFETY REQUIREMENTS IS VIRTUALLY
NONEXISTENT. AND WE HAVE TOO
MANY EXAMPLES OF INJURY, ABUSE
AND EVEN DEATHS OF CHILDREN
WHILE ATTENDING CAMP TO SETTLE
FOR THE STATUS QUO. AS WE STEP
INTO PROACTIVELY PROTECT
CHILDREN AT CAMP, THERE ARE A
WIDE VARIETY OF FACTORS TO
CONSIDER. AB 262 WILL SET US ON
A PATH TOWARDS SAFER CAMPS FOR
BY DIRECTING THE DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES TO CONVENE
STAKEHOLDERS AND PRACTITIONERS
TO FOCUS ON BETTER PROTECTIONS
FOR CHILDREN AND APPROPRIATE
REGULATIONS FOR THE CHILD
CAMPING INDUSTRY, I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU.
SENATOR HURTADO, ANY DISCUSSION
ON THIS MEASURE, ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION ON THIS MEASURE?
SEEING NONE. SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN. AYE
BROUGH. GILL. AYE. ARCHULETA
ASHBY. AYE. ATKINS. AYE. BECKER
BLAKE. SPEAR. AYE BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE CORTEZ. AYE.
DALY. NO. DODD. AYE. DURAZZO.
AYE. EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER. AYE.
AYE GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE NO.
HURTADO. AYE. JONES. NO. LAIRD
AYE. LEHMAN. AYE. MCGUIRE
MENGIBAR. I'M IN. AYE. NEWMAN.
AYE. NGUYEN NILO. NO OCHOA.
BOGH. AYE. PADILLA. AYE
PORTANTINO. AYE. ROTH. AYE
RUBIO. AYE. SEGATO NO. SKINNER
AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE
STERN. AYE UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB.
AYE WIENER. AYE. WILK. NO. HE'S
CALLED THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ARCHULETA. AYE BECKER. AYE
MCGUIRE. NGUYEN ON A VOTE OF 32
TO 6, THE MEASURE PASSES. WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE TO FILE ITEM 273.
ASSEMBLY BILL 2424. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL 2424
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER. SCHIAVO AN
ACT RELATING TO REAL PROPERTIES.
SENATOR ATKINS. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. COLLEAGUES, I RISE TO
PRESENT AB 2424 ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SCHIAVO,
CALIFORNIA'S FORECLOSURE PROCESS
LEGITIMIZES THE LARGE SCALE
EXTRACTION OF BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS, EXTRACTS BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS OF WEALTH FROM LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES. WHEN A
MORTGAGOR CAN'T PAY BACK THEIR
MORTGAGE LOAN, THE LENDER CAN
SELL THE PROPERTY AT AN AUCTION,
RESULTING IN THE HOMEOWNER
LOSING HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
DOLLARS OF ACCRUED HOME EQUITY.
FORECLOSED HOMEOWNERS ARE OFTEN
LOW INCOME, ELDERLY, IMMIGRANT
OR DISABLED, AND THE EQUITY IS
THEIR LIFE SAVINGS. AB 2424 WILL
REQUIRE FORECLOSING LENDERS TO
POSTPONE A FORECLOSURE SALE IF
THE HOMEOWNER PROVIDES THE
LENDER WITH A LISTING AGREEMENT
FOR THE SALE OF THE PROPERTY. IT
WOULD ALSO SET A MINIMUM BID
REQUIREMENT ON THE FIRST
ATTEMPT. ATTEMPTED FORECLOSURE
AUCTION, SO THAT THE SECURED
PROPERTY COULD NOT BE SOLD BELOW
A CERTAIN THRESHOLD CALCULATED
AT 67% OF THE PROPERTY'S MARKET
VALUE. THIS WOULD ALLOW THE
HOMEOWNER THE CHANCE TO RECOVER
MORE OF THEIR EQUITY THROUGH THE
FORECLOSURE SALE PROCESS, WHILE
ENSURING THE BANK GETS A FAIR
SHARE OF THEIR INTEREST IN THE
VALUE OF THE HOME. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU. SENATOR ATKINS. DOES
THE SENATOR WANT TO BE HEARD ON
THIS MEASURE? ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION? THIS IS ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. WITHOUT
OBJECTION. AYES 30 900. THE
MEASURE PASSES. MEMBERS, WE'RE
GOING TO GO TO FILE ITEM 276,
FOLLOWED BY THREE MEASURES BY
SENATOR UMBERG. IF HE IS
RETURNED TO THE FLOOR. THOSE ARE
ON FILE ITEM 227, 230 AND 241.
SO WE'LL BEGIN WITH FILE ITEM
276. ASSEMBLY BILL 2477.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL 2477 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ZUBER. AN ACT RELATING TO FOSTER
CARE. SENATOR PADILLA. THANK
YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. I RISE TO
PRESENT AB TWO 477 ON BEHALF OF
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER. THIS BILL
CLARIFIES AMBIGUITY AMBIGUITIES
BY ALIGNING STATE LAW WITH
RECENT DEPARTMENTAL GUIDANCE,
REMOVING ANY SUGGESTION THAT
YOUTH CANNOT ACCUMULATE CASH
ASSETS WHILE IN FOSTER CARE. IN
A NUTSHELL, THIS BILL IS ABOUT
INCREASING FINANCIAL SECURITY
AND EQUITY FOR ALL OF OUR YOUTH.
IN FOSTER CARE, AND ABOUT THE
LEGISLATURE'S DUTY TO SUPPORT
MARGINALIZED POPULATIONS UNDER
THE STATE'S CARE. THIS BILL IS
RECEIVED STRONG BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT, HAS NO OPPOSITION. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. SENATOR PADILLA,
ANY DISCUSSION ON THIS MEASURE?
ANY DISCUSSION? MEMBERS SEEING
NONE. SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN AYE. ALVARADO AYE.
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY. AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER. BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ. AYE.
DALLY. AYE. DODD. AYE. DURAZZO
AYE. EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER. AYE.
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE AYE.
HURTADO AYE. JONES. AYE. LAIRD.
AYE. LIMÓN AYE. MCGUIRE.
MENGIBAR. MEN AYE. NEWMAN. AYE.
NGUYEN. AYE. HELLO. AYE. OCHOA.
BOGH. AYE. PADILLA. AYE.
PORTANTINO. AYE. ROTH AYE.
RUBIO. AYE. SEYARTO. AYE.
SKINNER AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS.
AYE. STERN. AYE. UMBERG. AYE.
WAHAB. AYE. WIENER AYE. WILK
AYE. PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. BECKER. MCGUIRE.
MENGIBAR. SENATOR PADILLA MOVES
A CALL. WE'RE GOING TO HEAR
THREE MEASURES BY THE FLOOR
MANAGER. SENATOR UMBERG WILL
BEGIN WITH ITEM TWO. TWO SEVEN.
ASSEMBLY BILL 1785. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL 1785
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER PACHECO. AN
ACT RELATING TO PUBLIC RECORDS.
SENATOR UMBERG. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. COLLEAGUES AB 1785
CLOSE. THE LOOPHOLE ALLOWS
INDIVIDUALS TO ANONYMOUSLY
LOCATE THE HOME ADDRESSES OF
ELECTED AND APPOINTED OFFICIALS
ONLINE. URGE AND I VOTE AYE.
MEMBERS. ANY DISCUSSION ON THIS
MEASURE? ANY DISCUSSION ON THIS
MEASURE? THIS IS ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. NO. ALL
RIGHT. WE HAVE MEMBERS OFF THE
FLOOR. SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALLEN ALVARADO. GILL.
AYE. ARCHULETA AYE. ASHBY. AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER. BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD. CABALLERO.
AYE. CORTEZ AYE. DALY AYE. DODD.
AYE. DURAZO AYE. EGGMAN GLAZER.
AYE. AYE. GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE
AYE. HURTADO. AYE JONES. AYE.
LAIRD. AYE. LEHMAN. AYE. MCGUIRE
MENGIBAR. MIN. AYE. NEWMAN. AYE.
NGUYEN AYE. NILO AYE. OCHOA.
AYE. PADILLA. AYE. PORTANTINO.
AYE. ROTH. AYE. RUBIO. CIERTO.
AYE. SKINNER AYE. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. AYE. STERN. AYE. UMBERG.
AYE. WAHAB. AYE. WIENER. WILK
AYE. WIENER. AYE SEN. UMBERG
MOVES A CALL. NEXT UP. FILED
ITEM 230. ASSEMBLY BILL 2284.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL 2284 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GRAYSON. AN ACT RELATING TO
RETIREMENT. SENATOR UMBERG.
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
COLLEAGUES. ASSEMBLY BILL 2284
AUTHORIZES THE COUNTY EMPLOYMENT
RETIREMENT LAW OF 1937
RETIREMENT SYSTEMS TO DEFINE A
GRADE AS A GROUP OF EMPLOYEES
BASED ON SHARED SIMILARITIES IN
THEIR JOB DUTIES ARE, AMONG
OTHER LOGICAL WORK RELATED
GROUPINGS FOR PURPOSES OF THE
CALCULATION OF THE COMPENSABLE
COMPENSATION, THEIR PENSIONABLE
COMPENSATION URGENT I VOTE. DOES
A MEMBER WANT TO BE HEARD ON
THIS MEASURE? ANY DISCUSSION ON
THIS MEASURE? SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN ALVARADO. GILL. AYE.
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY. AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER. BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ AYE.
DALY. AYE. DODD. AYE. DURAZZO.
AYE. EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER. AYE.
AYE. GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE. AYE.
HURTADO AYE. JONES. AYE. LAIRD.
AYE. LIMÓN. AYE MCGUIRE.
MENGIBAR MIN. AYE. NEWMAN AYE.
NGUYEN. NILO AYE. OCHOA. AYE.
PADILLA. AYE. PORTANTINO. AYE.
ROTH. AYE. RUBIO. SEYARTO. AYE.
SKINNER AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS.
AYE. STERN. AYE. UMBERG. AYE.
WAHAB. AYE. WIENER. AYE. WILK.
AYE WHEN? AYE. SENATOR UMBERG
MOVES A CALL. WE'LL MOVE NEXT TO
FILE ITEM 241. ASSEMBLY BILL
2741. SECRETARY, PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL 2741 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER HAYNIE. AN ACT RELATING
TO RENTAL PASSENGER VEHICLES.
SENATOR UMBERG. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. MEMBERS, SOME OF THE
BILL 2741 DEALS WITH THE
INCREASE IN RENTAL CAR THEFTS
OCCURRING IN CALIFORNIA. RENTAL
CARS ARE BEING STOLEN AT
ALARMING RATES, WITH RENTAL CAR
COMPANIES REPORTING THAT THEY'VE
HAD A 266% INCREASE IN VEHICLE
THEFTS OVER THE PAST THREE
YEARS. RIGHT NOW, UNDER CURRENT
LAW, WHEN A CAR IS MISSING OR
STOLEN, TRACKING SYSTEMS CANNOT
BE LEGALLY ACTIVATED UNTIL THE
CAR HAS BEEN MISSING FOR 72
HOURS PAST ITS RETURN TIME. THIS
BILL SIMPLY ALLOWS RENTAL CAR
COMPANIES TO INITIATE VEHICLE
RECOVERY 24 HOURS AFTER AN
INDIVIDUAL FAILS TO RETURN A
VEHICLE. I URGE, AND I VOTE.
MEMBERS. ANY DISCUSSION ON THIS
MEASURE? ANY DISCUSSION ON THIS
MEASURE? SEEING NONE. SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN.
ALVARADO. GILL. AYE. ARCHULETA.
AYE. ASHBY. AYE. ATKINS. AYE.
BECKER. BLAKE. SPEER. AYE.
BRADFORD. AYE. CABALLERO. AYE.
CORTEZ. AYE. DALY. AYE. DODD.
AYE. DURAZO. AYE. EGGMAN. AYE.
GLAZER. AYE. GONZALEZ. AYE.
GROVE. AYE. HURTADO JONES. AYE.
LAIRD. AYE. LIMÓN. AYE. MCGUIRE.
MENGIBAR. MIN. AYE. NEWMAN. AYE.
WHEN I. NILO. AYE. OCHOA AYE.
PADILLA. AYE. PORTANTINO. AYE.
ROTH. AYE. RUBIO. CIERTO. AYE.
SKINNER. AZEMAR. CUEVAS. AYE.
STERN. AYE. UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB.
AYE. WIENER. AYE. WILK. AYE.
SENATOR UMBER MOVES A CALL.
MEMBERS. WE'RE GOING TO PROCEED
WITH THE FOLLOWING THREE ITEMS
IN ORDER. 277, FILE ITEM 279 AND
FILE ITEM 281. WE'LL BEGIN NOW
WITH FILE ITEM 277. ASSEMBLY
BILL 852. SECRETARY. PLEASE
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL 852 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER JONES-SAWYER AN
ACT TO PEACE OFFICERS AND
DECLARING THE URGENCY THEREOF TO
TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY.
SENATOR. CIERTO. THE FLOOR IS
YOURS. THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
MEMBERS, TODAY I RISE TO PRESENT
AB 852 ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER JONES-SAWYER. IN 2021,
THE LEGISLATURE PASSED AB 89 THE
PEACE OFFICERS, EDUCATION AND
AGE CONDITIONS FOR EMPLOYMENT
ACT OR PEACE ACT, WHICH
INCREASED THE MINIMUM WAGE,
MINIMUM AGE, AND EDUCATION LEVEL
FOR PEACE OFFICERS IN
CALIFORNIA. THIS YEAR, THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
SYSTEM HAS CRAFTED A MODEL
CURRICULUM FOR A MODERN POLICING
DEGREE, WHICH WILL SERVE AS THE
MINIMUM EDUCATION REQUIREMENTS
LEVELS FOR PEACE OFFICERS. AB
852 MAKES THE NECESSARY TIMELINE
CHANGES TO ALLOW COMMUNITY
COLLEGES TO BEGIN PROVIDING THE
NEW DEGREE AND PROSPECTIVE PEACE
OFFICERS TO ATTAIN IT. THIS BILL
HAS ENJOYED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT,
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR
CIERTO. ANY DISCUSSION ON THIS
MEASURE? ANY DISCUSSION. SEEING
NONE. THIS HAS AN URGENCY
REQUIRES 27 VOTES. SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLAN
ALVARADO. GILL. AYE. ARCHULETA
AYE. ASHBY. AYE. ATKINS AYE.
BECKER. BLAKE. SPEER. AYE.
BRADFORD. AYE. CABALLERO. AYE.
CORTEZ. AYE. DALY AYE. DODD
DURAZZO. AYE. ECKMAN. AYE.
GLAZER. AYE. AYE. GONZALEZ. AYE.
GROVE. AYE. HURTADO. JONES AYE.
LAIRD. AYE. LIMON. AYE. MCGUIRE
MENGIBAR. MIN AYE. NEWMAN. AYE.
NGUYEN AYE. NILO AYE. OKUBO.
AYE. PADILLA. AYE. PORTANTINO
AYE. ROTH. AYE. RUBIO SEYARTO.
AYE. SKINNER AYE. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. AYE. STERN. AYE. UMBERG.
AYE. WAHAB. AYE. WIENER. AYE
WILK. AYE. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ALLEN. BECKER
DODD. AYE. HURTADO. MCGUIRE
MENGIBAR. RUBIO. SENATOR.
CIERTO. MOVES A CALL. WE'LL MOVE
NEXT TO FILE ITEM 279. THIS IS
ASSEMBLY BILL 2871. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL 2871
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER MAIENSCHEIN.
AN ACT RELATING TO PUBLIC
HEALTH. SENATOR PADILLA THANK
YOU. MR. MR. PRESIDENT I RISE TO
PRESENT AB TWO 871 ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MAIENSCHEIN.
CALIFORNIA IS FACING A
STAGGERING NUMBER OF OVERDOSE
DEATHS. THE IMPACT OF FENTANYL
ALONE HAS BEEN FELT IN EVERY ONE
OF OUR DISTRICTS. THIS BILL
CREATES A NEW TOOL TO HELP
COMBAT THIS CRISIS AND PREVENT
FUTURE DEATHS. IT ALLOWS
COUNTIES TO CREATE OVERDOSE
FATALITY REVIEW TEAMS COMPOSED
OF PUBLIC HEALTH PROFESSIONALS,
LAW ENFORCEMENT, DRUG TREATMENT
PROVIDERS, AND LOCAL NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS. THE REVIEW TEAMS
WILL EXAMINE THE CIRCUMSTANCES
SURROUNDING INDIVIDUAL OVERDOSE
DEATHS TO IDENTIFY COMMONALITIES
OR OTHER ACTIONABLE ITEMS THAT
CAN LEAD TO INFORMED EFFORTS TO
PREVENT FUTURE OVERDOSES. THIS
BILL IS MODELED OFF EXISTING
REVIEW TEAMS SUCH AS CHILD DEATH
REVIEW TEAMS, DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
DEATH REVIEW TEAMS, AND ELDER
AND DEPENDENT ABUSE DEATH REVIEW
TEAMS. THIS BILL HAS BROAD
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT, HAS HAD ZERO
NO VOTES, AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU.
SENATOR PADILLA, ANY DISCUSSION
ON THIS MEASURE? ANY DISCUSSION?
SEEING NONE. SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALAN ALVARADO
GILL. AYE. ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER. BLAKE
SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO AYE. CORTEZ. AYE. DALI
AYE. DODD. AYE. DURAZZO AYE.
EGGMAN. AYE. GLASER. AYE.
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE. AYE
HURTADO. JONES. AYE. LAIRD. AYE.
LEHMAN AYE. MCGUIRE MENGIBAR.
MIN AYE. NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN
NILO. AYE. OCHOA. AYE. PADILLA.
AYE. PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH. AYE.
RUBIO. SEYARTO. AYE. SKINNER.
AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS AYE.
STERN UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB. AYE.
WIENER AYE. WILK. AYE. SEN.
PADILLA MOVES A CALL. WHEN? AYE.
SEN. PADILLA MOVES A CALL. WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE NEXT TO FILE ITEM
281. THIS IS ASSEMBLY BILL 805.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL 805 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ARAMBULA. AN ACT RELATING TO
WATER QUALITY, MAKING AN
APPROPRIATION, THEREFORE, AND
DECLARING THE URGENCY THEREOF TO
TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY. SEN.
LAIRD. THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
AVIATOR FIVE PROTECTS
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES FROM
FAILING AND POORLY MANAGED
INFRASTRUCTURE BY AUTHORIZING
THE WATER RESOURCE CONTROL BOARD
TO APPOINT AN INTERIM
ADMINISTRATOR FOR A STRUGGLING
WASTEWATER SYSTEM SERVING A
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITY. THEIR
SUPPORT ON BOTH SIDES. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
MEMBERS, ANY DISCUSSION ON THIS
MEASURE? ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
ON THIS MEASURE? SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN. ALVARADO. GILL. AYE.
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY. AYE.
ATKINS AYE. BECKER. BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ AYE.
DALY. AYE. DODD AYE. DURAZZO.
AYE. EGGMAN AYE. GLAZER. AYE.
GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE. AYE.
HURTADO. JONES. AYE. LAIRD. AYE.
LEHMAN MAGUIRE AND JABBAR. MIN.
AYE. NEWMAN AYE. NGUYEN. AYE.
NEILA. AYE. OKUBO. AYE. PADILLA.
AYE. PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH. AYE.
RUBIO SEYARTO. AYE. SKINNER AYE.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE. STERN.
AYE. UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB. AYE.
WIENER. AYE WILK. AYE. SEN.
LAIRD MOVES A CALL. MEMBERS.
WE'RE GOING TO TAKE UP THE NEXT
FOUR ITEMS. 283 FILE TWO 9293
AND 294. THOSE ARE FLOOR
MANAGERS SKINNER, OCHOA, BOGH,
WIENER AND ARCHULETA. WE'LL
BEGIN WITH ITEM 283. ASSEMBLY
BILL 1186. SECRETARY, PLEASE
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL 1186 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BONTA ENACT
RELATING TO RESTITUTION. SENATOR
SKINNER. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS. PLEASED
TO PRESENT AB 1186 ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BONTA. AB 1186
IS THE REPAIR ACT WHICH HELPS
MAKES OUR YOUTH RESTITUTION
SYSTEM WORK MORE EQUITABLY. IT
ELIMINATES YOUTH RESTITUTION,
FINES IT VACATES OLD AND LARGELY
UNCOLLECTABLE RESTITUTION, FINE
DEBT. IT ENDS WAGE AND TRUST
ACCOUNT GARNISHMENT FOR YOUTH
RESTITUTION. IT CLARIFIES LOSS
CALCULATIONS FOR PROPERTY REPAIR
OR REPLACEMENT FOR YOUTH
RESTITUTION ORDERS, AND ENDS THE
JOINT AND SEVERAL LIABILITY FOR
YOUTH CO-DEFENDANTS. SO, IN
SHORT, IT MAKES THE RESTITUTION
SYSTEM WORKS MUCH BETTER FOR OUR
YOUTH AND THEIR FAMILIES. AND
WITH THAT, I ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. MEMBERS. ANY DISCUSSION ON
THIS MEASURE? ANY DISCUSSION?
SEEING NONE. SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN ALVARADO.
GIL NØ. ARCHULETA. AYE ASHBY.
AYE. ATKINS. AYE. BECKER BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ AYE.
DALY. NO. DODD. AYE. DURAZO.
AYE. EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER. AYE.
AYE. GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE NO.
HURTADO. JONES. NO. LAIRD. AYE.
LIMON. AYE. MCGUIRE MENGIBAR.
MIN AYE. NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN NO.
NILO. NÓ. OKUBO NO. PADILLA.
AYE. PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH. AYE.
RUBIO SUGIARTO. NO. SKINNER.
AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE
STERN. AYE. UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB
AYE. WIENER. AYE WILK. SEN.
SKINNER. MOVES A CALL. NEXT UP
IS FILE ITEM 290. ASSEMBLY BILL
1891. SECRETARY, PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL 1891 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WEBER. AN ACT RELATING TO
COMMUNITY COLLEGES. SENATOR
OCHOA BOGUE. MR. PRESIDENT AND
MEMBERS, I RISE TO PRESENT AB
1891, WHICH WILL PROVIDE
CALIFORNIA'S COMMUNITY COLLEGES
WITH MORE FLEXIBILITY WHEN
ADMITTING STUDENTS INTO THEIR
ALLIED HEALTH PROGRAMS. THESE
PROGRAMS TRAIN STUDENTS IN
CAREERS THAT SUPPORT MAJOR
SECTORS OF HEALTH CARE, SUCH AS
DENTAL ASSISTANTS, PARAMEDICS,
AND LAB TECHS. EXPANDING
ADMISSION OPTIONS TO INCLUDE
MULTI-CRITERIA SCREENING ALLOWS
COLLEGES TO MANAGE CAPACITY
LIMITATIONS WHILE INCREASING THE
NUMBER OF ALLIED HEALTH
GRADUATES WHICH ARE SO VITAL TO
CALIFORNIA'S HEALTH CARE
WORKFORCE. COMMUNITY COLLEGES
HAVE BEEN RISING, HAVE BEEN
USING THIS TYPE OF SCREENING IN
THEIR NURSING PROGRAMS FOR
ALMOST TWO DECADES, WITH MUCH
SUCCESS. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. MEMBERS ANY
DISCUSSION ON THIS MEASURE? ANY
DISCUSSION? SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN ALVARADO. GILL AYE.
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER. BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ AYE.
DALY. AYE. DODD AYE. DURAZO AYE.
EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER. AYE. AYE.
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE. HURTADO
JONES. AYE. LAIRD AYE. LIMÓN.
AYE. MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR MIN. AYE.
NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN AYE. NILO.
AYE OCHOA. BOGH. AYE. PADILLA
AYE. PORTANTINO. AYE. ROTH AYE.
RUBIO. SEYARTO AYE. SKINNER.
AYE. SMALLWOOD CUEVAS. AYE.
STERN. AYE UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB.
AYE WIENER AYE. WILK AYE.
SENATOR OCHOA. BOGH MOVES THE
CALL. NEXT UP, FILE ITEM 293.
ASSEMBLY BILL, 1979. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL 1979
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER WARD. AN ACT
RELATING TO CIVIL LAW. SENATOR
WIENER. TO PASS ON FILE. NO. NO
I'M JUST KIDDING, SENATOR
WIENER. THANK YOU, MISTER
PRESIDENT. I LIKE HOW YOU RUN A
TIGHT SHIP, COLLEAGUES, I RISE
TO PRESENT AB 1979. THE DOXXING
VICTIMS RECOURSE ACT ON BEHALF
OF ASSEMBLYMEMBER'S WARD AND
AGUIAR-CURRY. THE BILL PROVIDES
RELIEF AND SUPPORT FOR VICTIMS
WHO HAVE BEEN HARMED AS A RESULT
OF BEING DOXXED BY ALLOWING THEM
TO PURSUE CIVIL RESTITUTION FOR
THE HARMS THEY ENDURED. DOXING
IS A DOXING IS A HARASSMENT
TACTIC THAT OCCURS WHEN A PERSON
RELEASES ANOTHER INDIVIDUAL'S
PRIVATE PERSONALLY IDENTIFYING
INFORMATION WITHOUT THEIR
CONSENT, WITH THE INTENT TO
CAUSE THAT PERSON HARM. WHILE
DOXING IS ALREADY A CRIME,
PROTECTIONS AND RECOURSE ARE
ABSENT IN THE CIVIL CODE. THIS
BILL WILL CORRECT THIS ABSENCE,
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. SENATOR
WIENER, ANY DISCUSSION ON THIS
MEASURE? SEEING NONE. SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN
ALVARADO. GILL AYE. ARCHULETA.
AYE. ASHBY AYE. ATKINS. AYE.
BECKER BLAKE. SPEER. AYE.
BRADFORD. AYE. CABALLERO. AYE.
CORTEZ AYE. DALY. NO. DODD AYE.
DURAZZO. AYE. EGGMAN. AYE.
GLASER. AYE. AYE. GONZALEZ. AYE.
GROVE HURTADO. JONES NO. LAIRD.
AYE. LEHMAN MAGUIRE. MENGIBAR
MIN. AYE. NEUMANN AYE. NGUYEN.
NEILA OCHOA. PADILLA AYE.
PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH. AYE. RUBIO
SEYARTO NO. SKINNER AYE.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE. STERN.
AYE. UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB. AYE.
WIENER AYE. WILK. AYE. SENATOR.
WIENER MOVES A CALL. ALL RIGHT,
MEMBERS, WE'RE GOING TO GO TO
FILE ITEM 294, FOLLOWED BY FILE
ITEM 297 294 IS ASSEMBLY BILL
1994. SECRETARY, PLEASE READ
ASSEMBLY BILL 1994 BY THE
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON MILITARY
AND VETERANS AFFAIRS. AN ACT
RELATING TO VETERANS. SENATOR
ARCHULETA, THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. I RISE
TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL, 1994,
A COMMITTEE BILL OF THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON MILITARY AND
VETERANS AFFAIRS, AB 1994
ESTABLISHES THAT WITHIN THE
CORVETTE THERE IS A DEPUTY
SECRETARY OF MINORITY AND
UNDERREPRESENTED VETERANS
AFFAIRS WHO SHALL HAVE
RESPONSIBILITY OVER THE
ADMINISTRATION OF MINORITY AND
UNREPRESENTED VETERANS AFFAIRS.
THIS BILL HAS RECEIVED UNANIMOUS
APPROVAL AND BIPARTISAN SUPPORT.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
VOTE. THANK YOU, SENATOR
ARCHULETA. ANY DISCUSSION ON
THIS COMMITTEE MEASURE ANY
DISCUSSION. SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN ALVARADO GILL. AYE.
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY ATKINS.
AYE. BECKER BLAKE. SPEER. AYE.
BRADFORD. AYE. CABALLERO. AYE.
CORTEZ. AYE. DALY DODD. AYE.
DURAZO EGGMAN. AYE. GLASER. AYE.
AYE. GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE AYE.
HURTADO JONES. LAIRD AYE.
LEHMAN. AYE. MCGUIRE MENGIBAR.
MIN. AYE. NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN
NILO. OCHOA. BOGH NILO AYE.
OCHOA. BORG. AYE. PADILLA AYE.
PORTANTINO. AYE. ROTH. AYE.
RUBIO. SUGIARTO SKINNER. AYE.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS AYE. STERN.
AYE UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB. AYE
WIENER. WILK AYE. SENATOR
ARCHULETA MOVES A CALL. WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE NEXT TO FILE ITEM
297. THIS IS ASSEMBLY BILL 2063.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ. GENERAL
ASSEMBLY BILL 2063 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MAIENSCHEIN. AN ACT
RELATING TO HEALTH CARE
COVERAGE. SENATOR BLAKE SPEER
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. AND
COLLEAGUES, I RISE TODAY TO
PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL 2063 ON
BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MAIENSCHEIN. AB 2063 SEEKS TO
EXTEND THE SUNSET DATE OF A
PILOT PROGRAM THAT HAS FACED
SIGNIFICANT DELAYS DUE TO THE
UNPRECEDENTED CHALLENGES OF THE
COVID 19 PANDEMIC. THIS PILOT
PROGRAM IS DESIGNED TO INTEGRATE
RISK BEARING PROVIDERS WITH
SELF-FUNDED EMPLOYER PLANS
UTILIZING CAPITALIZED PAYMENT
MECHANISMS INSTEAD OF
TRADITIONAL FEE FOR SERVICE
COMPENSATION. THE GOAL IS CLEAR,
WHICH IS TO REDUCE HEALTH CARE
COSTS WHILE MAINTAINING OR
IMPROVING THE QUALITY OF CARE.
THE ADDITIONAL TWO YEARS WILL
ALLOW US TO PROPERLY ASSESS THE
PROGRAM'S IMPACT ON SERVICE
SPEED, HEALTH CARE COSTS, AND
PATIENT OUTCOMES. CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT AREAS AS WE STRIVE TO
IMPROVE HEALTH CARE COVERAGE FOR
ALL, I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
I VOTE. THANK YOU. SENATOR BLAKE
SPEER, ANY DISCUSSION ON THIS
MEASURE? ANY DISCUSSION? SEEING
NONE. SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN ALVARADO. GILL. AYE.
ARCHULETA AYE. ASHBY. AYE.
ATKINS AYE. BECKER. BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ. AYE.
DALY AYE. DODD. AYE. DURAZZO.
AYE. EGGMAN. AYE. GLASER. AYE.
AYE. GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE.
HURTADO JONES. AYE. LAIRD AYE.
LIMÓN. AYE. MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR.
MINH AYE. NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN
AYE. NHIÀU. AYE. OCHOA. AYE.
PADILLA PORTANTINO. AYE. ROTH.
AYE RUBIO. SEYARTO AYE. SKINNER
AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE.
STERN. AYE. UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB.
AYE. WIENER WILK. NO. SEN.
BLAKE. SPEER MOVES A CALL.
MEMBERS. THE NEXT FOUR ITEMS.
WE'RE GOING TO TAKE UP THIS
AFTERNOON ARE FILE ITEMS 304,
307, 308 AND 310. FLOOR MANAGERS
CORTESE, GROVE, ROTH AND DODD.
WE'LL BEGIN WITH FILE ITEM 304.
ASSEMBLY BILL 2385. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL 2335
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCHENRY. AN
ACT RELATING TO PEOPLE, PUBLIC
EMPLOYMENT. SENATOR CORTESE
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
SENATORS, I RISE TO PRESENT AB
2335 WHICH IS SPONSORED BY THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
PROFESSIONAL SCIENTISTS AND THE
UNITED AUTO WORKERS. THE BILL
MANDATES THE STATE TO UPHOLD OR
REINSTATE THE HISTORICAL SALARY
PARITY AMONG STATE CIVIL SERVICE
CLASSIFICATIONS AND BARGAINING
UNITS, ENSURING THAT COMPARABLE
COMPENSATION IS PROVIDED FOR
ROLES THAT ARE FUNDAMENTALLY
ALIKE. MOREOVER, IT NECESSITATES
THE STATE TO RECTIFY ANY GENDER
BASED WAGE DISPARITIES THAT MAY
PERSIST BETWEEN CIVIL SERVICE
POSITIONS AND CLASSIFICATIONS
THAT PERFORM SIMILAR DUTIES.
STATE SCIENTISTS SALARIES LAG
THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT AND FEDERAL
COUNTERPARTS, AND OTHER STATE
EMPLOYEES THAT DO SUBSTANTIALLY
SIMILAR WORK BY UPWARDS OF 40%.
THIS THIS IS INCONSISTENT WITH
THE ADMINISTRATION'S DECLARED
PRIORITY OF ESTABLISHING EQUITY
AS THE STATE'S LARGEST EMPLOYER
IS CRITICAL FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA TO LEAD BY EXAMPLE
AND WORK TO CREATE A CALIFORNIA
WHERE ALL EMPLOYEES ARE VALUED,
RESPECTED, AND PAID EQUITABLY,
PROVIDE EQUITABLE PAY IS
ESSENTIAL FOR PROMOTING GENDER
EQUALITY AND ATTRACTING AND
RETAINING STATE EMPLOYEES. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I
VOTE. THANK YOU. SENATOR
CORTESE, ANY DISCUSSION ON THIS
MEASURE? ANY DISCUSSION ON THIS
MEASURE? SEEING NONE. SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN
ALVARADO. GILL. NO ARCHULETA.
AYE. ASHBY AYE. ATKINS. AYE.
BECKER BLAKE. SPEER. AYE.
BRADFORD AYE. CABALLERO. AYE.
CORTEZ AYE. DALY. NÓ. DODD AYE.
DURAZZO. AYE. EGGMAN AYE.
GLAZER. AYE. GONZALEZ AYE.
GROVE. NO. HURTADO JONES. NO.
LAIRD AYE. LEHMAN AYE. MAGUIRE.
MENGIBAR MIN. AYE. NEWMAN AYE.
NGUYEN. NO. NILO NO. OCHOA.
PADILLA AYE. PORTANTINO. AYE
ROTH. AYE. RUBIO. SEGATO NO.
SKINNER. AYE SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS.
AYE STERNE. AYE. UMBERG. AYE
WAHAB. AYE. WIENER WILK. SENATOR
CORTEZ MOVES A CALL. NEXT UP,
FILE 307. ASSEMBLY BILL 2423.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ ROLL ON
THIS. ACTUALLY, I WAS ASSEMBLY
BILL 2423 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MATHEWS. AN ACT RELATING TO
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES. SENATOR
GROVE. THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
COLLEAGUES, TODAY I RISE TO
REPRESENT AB 2423 ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER DEVIN MATHIS, AB
2423 CORRECTS AN INJUSTICE BY
REQUIRING THE DEPARTMENT OF
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES TO REVIEW
AND UPDATE THE CURRENTLY
OUTDATED RATE MODELS THAT ARE
PROVIDED TO OUR REGIONAL CENTERS
IN THE IDD COMMUNITY. FOR FAR
TOO LONG, THE REGIONAL CENTERS
THAT SERVE THE NEEDS OF THE ID
COMMUNITY HAVE SERIOUSLY BEEN
UNDERFUNDED, WHICH HAS LIMITED
THE ABILITY OF OUR REGIONAL
CENTERS TO PROVIDE THE SUPPORT
THAT THIS COMMUNITY NEEDS,
ENSURING OUR COMMUNITY GETS THE
SUPPORT IT'S NEEDED IS NOT A
PARTIZAN ISSUE, AND WE HAVE
RECEIVED A SUPPORT FROM A
DIVERSE GROUP OF POPULATIONS AND
COALITION GROUPS. THE BILL IS
SPONSORED BY THE CALIFORNIA
DISABILITY SERVICES ASSOCIATION.
IT'S RECEIVED NO NO VOTES.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE
ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLYMEMBER
MATHIS. THANK YOU. SENATOR GROVE,
ANY DISCUSSION ON THIS MEASURE?
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION? SEEING
NONE. SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN ALVARADO GILL. AYE.
ARCHULETA. ALLEN ALVARADO. GILL.
AYE ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY. AYE
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER. BLAKE.
SPEER AYE. BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO AYE. CORTEZ. AYE. DALY
AYE. DODD. AYE. DURAZZO AYE.
EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER. AYE. AYE.
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE AYE.
HURTADO. JONES AYE. LAIRD. AYE.
LEHMAN AYE. MAGUIRE. MENGIBAR
MIN. AYE. NEWMAN AYE. NGUYEN.
AYE NILO. AYE. OCHOA. BORG. AYE
PADILLA AYE. PORTANTINO AYE.
ROTH AYE. RUBIO SEYARTO AYE.
SKINNER AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS
AYE. STERN. AYE UMBERG AYE.
WAHAB. AYE WIENER. WILK. AYE
SENATOR GROVE MOVES TO CALL.
NEXT UP, FILE 308. ASSEMBLY BILL
2448. SECRETARY, PLEASE READ
ASSEMBLY BILL 2448 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER JACKSON. AN ACT RELATING
TO ELECTRIC BIKE VEHICLES.
SENATOR ROTH THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. THIS BILL CREATES AN
ELECTRIC VEHICLE ECONOMIC
OPPORTUNITY ZONE IN RIVERSIDE
COUNTY. IN BRIEF, THE BILL WOULD
DIRECT CALIFORNIA'S LABOR AND
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT AGENCY TO
WORK WITH THE COUNTY OF
RIVERSIDE TO MAKE ELECTRIC
VEHICLE MANUFACTURING JOBS AND
EDUCATION MORE ACCESSIBLE IN ONE
OF THE FASTEST GROWING REGIONS
IN THE STATE. THE BILL WILL
ENABLE RIVERSIDE COUNTY TO HELP
PROPEL CALIFORNIA TOWARD ITS
CLEAN ENERGY GOALS AND SERVE AS
A MODEL FOR HOW SIMILAR ZONES
COULD BE DEVELOPED ACROSS THE
STATE. BILL HAS NO OPPOSITION,
RECEIVED STRONG BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT. RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. SENATOR
ROTH. ANY DISCUSSION ON THIS
MEASURE? SENATOR GROVE? THANK
YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. COLLEAGUES,
I RESPECTFULLY RISE IN
OPPOSITION TO AB 2448. THIS BILL
IS MEANT TO ENCOURAGE ELECTRIC
VEHICLE MANUFACTURERS TO LOCATE
IN LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES IN
RIVERSIDE COUNTY AND WILL
PRIORITIZE RECRUITMENT AND
ENROLLMENT OF THE WORKERS AND
STUDENTS OF UNDERPRIVILEGED
ECONOMIC STATUS. I KNOW THE
GOVERNOR AND MANY MEMBERS OF
THIS FLOOR THINK THAT ELECTRIC
VEHICLES ARE THE GREEN SOLUTION,
AND THAT THOSE THOSE
SPECIFICALLY CALLED GAS GUZZLING
VEHICLES SHOULD BE REPLACED. BUT
WE NEED TO START LOOKING
SERIOUSLY AT THE POTENTIAL
HAZARDS CAUSED BY LITHIUM
BATTERIES IN THESE VEHICLES.
THERE HAVE BEEN MULTIPLE
EXAMPLES OF LITHIUM ION
BATTERIES CREATING EXTENSIVE
ENVIRONMENTAL DAMAGE AND PUTTING
MANY PEOPLE'S LIVES AT RISK FOR
EXAMPLE, WHEN THE FACILITY
STORING LITHIUM ION BATTERIES IN
OTAY MESA CAUGHT ON FIRE BECAUSE
OF A MALFUNCTION WITH ONE OF THE
BATTERIES, THE FACILITY BURNED
FOR 17 DAYS AND SPEWED OVER 7000
PARTS PER MILLION OF A POISON
INTO THE AIR. FIRES CAUSED BY
LITHIUM ION BATTERIES ARE
INCREDIBLY DIFFICULT TO PUT OUT.
THEY ALSO PRODUCE TOXIC HYDROGEN
FUMES, TOXIC HYDROGEN SELENIDE
FUMES THAT CAN BE EXTREMELY
HARMFUL, AND EVEN FATAL. EVEN
WHEN THE STORAGE FACILITY IN
OTAY MESA CAUGHT ON FIRE, CAL
FIRE WAS ONLY ABLE TO LIFT THE
EVACUATION ORDERS AFTER 13 DAYS.
THAT MEANS 8 MILLION GALLONS OF
WATER WAS USED TO PUT THIS FIRE
OUT. PEOPLE HAD TO PUT THEIR
ENTIRE LIVES ON HOLD FOR TWO
WEEKS, SO THEY WEREN'T EXPOSED
TO THESE DANGEROUS FUMES. LAST
MONTH, THE TRUCK CARRYING
LITHIUM ION BATTERIES CAUGHT ON
FIRE ON THE 15 FREEWAY, AND THAT
SHUT DOWN BOTH SIDES OF THIS
CRITICAL TRANSPORTATION ROUTE.
DRIVERS WERE TRAPPED IN 100
DEGREE WEATHER, AND IT TOOK DAYS
FOR THE CLEANUP OF THE TOXIC
MESS. JUST LAST WEEK, AN
ELECTRIC SEMI TRUCK CAUGHT FIRE
ON THE INTERSTATE 80, WHICH
CREATED A TOXIC PLUME OF SMOKE
AND SHUT DOWN BOTH DIRECTIONS OF
THE FREEWAY FOR 12 HOURS. ONE
WOMAN NEAR THE PROPOSED STORAGE
SITE WAS QUOTED THAT THIS
PARTICULAR SITE WILL AFFECT
BLACK AND BROWN COMMUNITIES IN A
NEGATIVE WAY, AND SHE STATED,
IT'S NEW TECHNOLOGY AND I FEEL
LIKE WE'RE BEING THE GUINEA PIGS
ALL OVER AGAIN IN THIS
NEIGHBORHOOD. THE OTHER
COMMUNITIES AND OTHER
COMMUNITIES WHERE THEY ARE
PROPOSING LITHIUM BATTERY
STORAGE FACILITIES, PEOPLE HAVE
BEGUN ADVOCATING AGAINST THEM
BECAUSE THEY DON'T WANT THESE
DANGEROUS FACILITIES NEAR THEIR
FAMILIES, THEIR CHILDREN OR
THEIR COMMUNITY. THIS BILL
ENCOURAGES THE PLACEMENT OF
THESE FACILITIES IN LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES, WHICH WOULD BEAR
THE BRUNT OF THESE RISKS,
PARTICULARLY BLACK AND BROWN
COMMUNITIES. IT IS THE LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES THAT ARE AT
RISK OF BEING EXPOSED TO
DANGEROUS TOXIC FUMES THAT WILL
FACE THE RISK OF EVACUATING
WEEKS AT A TIME IF THERE'S A
POTENTIAL EXPOSURE, WHICH IS
LIKELY TO HAPPEN, AND EVACUATING
THEM WHERE I THINK THIS BILL
MEANS A WELL TO ENCOURAGE
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT IN LOW
SOCIOECONOMIC DISADVANTAGED
NEIGHBORHOODS. BUT WHERE WE PUT
THESE FACILITIES NEEDS TO BE
SAFE AND MAKE SURE THAT OUR
COMMUNITIES ARE PROTECTED FROM
THESE HORRIFIC, CATASTROPHIC
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACTS THAT
CREATE HAZARDS ON ALL THE
COMMUNITIES THAT THEY ARE
SURROUNDED BY. RESPECTFULLY
ASKED FOR A NO VOTE. THANK YOU,
MEMBERS, ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
ON THIS MEASURE? SENATOR EGGMAN,
I THANK YOU VERY MUCH, MR.
PRESIDENT. JUST RISING IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL AS WE
CONTINUE OUR TRANSITION AWAY
FROM GAS. WE KNOW WE'VE HAD MORE
HEAT RELATED DEATHS IN THE LAST
COUPLE OF YEARS. AND WE'VE EVER
HAD THE MOST DEATHS THAT WE HAVE
RELATED TO ANY KIND OF WEATHER
OCCURRENCE IS HEAT, AND WE KNOW
HEAT COMES DIRECTLY FROM ISSUES
AROUND CLIMATE CHANGE AND OIL
AND THE WAYS WE USE THINGS LIKE
THAT. AND ALSO JUST IN MY
DISTRICT, AND I KNOW IN MY IN MY
COLLEAGUE'S DISTRICT FROM KERN
COUNTY, THE HIGHEST RATES OF
ASTHMA AFFECTING YOUNG CHILDREN
ARE FOUND IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY,
WHERE WE HAVE MORE TRUCKS AND
TRACTORS GOING UP AND DOWN THAT
FREEWAY EVERY DAY. SO I AM IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL AS IT
BEGINS TO MOVE US OFF IN A
SENSIBLE WAY, OFF OIL AND GAS
AND MOVING TOWARDS A MORE GREEN
ECONOMY WHERE EVERYBODY CAN
BENEFIT AND WE CAN BREATHE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH, MR.
PRESIDENT. THANK YOU, SENATOR
EGGMAN. ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE? MEMBERS SEEING NONE.
SENATOR ROTH, YOU MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. I'M. I
HAPPEN TO LIVE IN RIVERSIDE
COUNTY, AND I'M FAIRLY CERTAIN
THAT THE AUTHOR OF THIS MEASURE
DIDN'T INTEND TO PROMPT A
DISCUSSION OF FOSSIL FUEL VERSUS
ALTERNATIVE FUEL SOURCES. THE
PROS AND CONS, AND ALL OF THE
REST OF THAT, RATHER, I AM
FAIRLY CONFIDENT THAT THE
AUTHOR'S INTENT WAS TO ATTEMPT
TO PROVIDE A PATHWAY FOR
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES FOR
THE FOR THE UNDERPRIVILEGED, FOR
THOSE WHO ARE NOT LIKE US, WHO
LIVE IN SOME PARTS OF RIVERSIDE
COUNTY, WHO RIGHT NOW ARE
DEALING WITH WAREHOUSES, THE
PROS AND CONS OF WAREHOUSES,
BECAUSE WE ARE THE PIPELINE FROM
THE PORTS TO ALL OF THE REST OF
YOU, FRANKLY, IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA, THE MIDWEST AND THE
EAST COAST. SO THIS BILL WOULD
HOPEFULLY MOVE THOSE IN
RIVERSIDE COUNTY IF THE
OPPORTUNITY ZONE WORKS TOWARD A
HIGH TECH, HIGH PAY, HIGH
QUALITY JOBS, WHICH IS SOMETHING
WE CERTAINLY LACK IN SOME
PORTIONS OF THE COUNTY TODAY. SO
I WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANKS ALL DEBATE
HAVING CEASED, SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALAN ALVARADO.
GILL. AYE. ARCHULETA AYE. ASHBY.
AYE. ATKINS. AYE. BECKER. BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE CORTEZ. AYE. DALY
DODD. AYE. DURAZZO AYE. EGGMAN.
AYE. GLASER. AYE. AYE. GONZALEZ.
AYE. GROVE. NO HURTADO. JONES.
NO. LAIRD AYE. LEHMAN. AYE.
MCGUIRE MENGIBAR. MIN AYE.
NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN NHIÀU.
OCHOA. BOGH PADILLA. AYE.
PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH. AYE. RUBIO
SEYARTO AYE. SKINNER. AYE.
SMALLWOOD CUEVAS. AYE. STERN
AYE. UMBERG. AYE WAHAB. AYE.
WIENER WILK. NO. ALVARADO. GILL.
I DON'T KNOW, SENATOR ROTH MOVES
A CALL. MEMBERS, WE'RE NEXT
GOING TO BEGIN WITH A FILE ITEM
310, FOLLOWED BY FILE ITEM 317
319, THREE, 23, 21, 322 AND 329.
WE'LL BEGIN NEXT WITH FILE ITEM
310. THIS IS ASSEMBLY BILL 2669.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL 2669 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
TING. AN ACT RELATING TO
TRANSPORTATION. SENATOR DODD.
MR. PRESIDENT AND COLLEAGUES,
TODAY I'M PRESENTING AB 2669 ON
BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER TING
WHICH WOULD PROTECT FREE
SIDEWALK ACCESS FOR PEDESTRIANS
AND BICYCLISTS BY PROHIBITING
THE USE OF SIDEWALK TOLLS ON ALL
STATE RUN BRIDGES CONSTRUCTED
BEFORE JANUARY 2025, A
PEDESTRIAN TOLL ON THESE BRIDGES
WOULD UNFAIRLY BURDEN
PEDESTRIANS AND BIKERS. THEY DO
NOT PUT THE SAME WEAR AND TEAR
ON THE BRIDGES AS CARS OR
TRUCKS. SB EXCUSE ME, AB 2669
SIMPLY PRESERVES AN INCENTIVE
FOR PEOPLE TO PURSUE EMISSION
FREE METHODS OF ACTIVE
TRANSPORTATION. RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU.
SENATOR DODD. ANY DISCUSSION ON
THIS MEASURE? SEEING NO
MICROPHONES UP, SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN
ALVARADO, GIL ARCHULETA. AYE.
ASHBY AYE. ATKINS. AYE. BECKER
BLAKE. SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ AYE.
DALY. NÓ DODD. AYE. DURAZZO. AYE
EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER. AYE. AYE.
GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE. NO HURTADO.
JONES. NO LAIRD. AYE. LEHMAN.
AYE MAGUIRE. MENGIBAR. MIN AYE.
NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN NILO. NO.
OCHOA NO. PADILLA. AYE
PORTANTINO. AYE. ROTH AYE.
RUBIO. SEYARTO NO. SKINNER AYE.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE STERN.
AYE. UMBERG AYE. WAHAB. AYE.
WIENER WILK. AYE WHEN? NO
SENATOR DODD MOVES A CALL. ALL
RIGHT. SENATORS BE AWARE THAT
THE NEXT THE FLOOR MANAGERS FOR
THE FOLLOWING ITEMS ARE GOING TO
GO IN ORDER. LIMÓN DURAZZO,
LAIRD, DURAZZO, CORTESE AND
ARCHULETA. NEXT UP, ITEM 317.
ASSEMBLY BILL 2734. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY BILL 2734
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER CONNOLLY. AN
ACT RELATING TO AGRICULTURE.
SENATOR LEHMAN, THE FLOOR IS
YOURS. THANK YOU, PRESIDENT AND
MEMBERS. AB 2734 PROPOSES
SEVERAL CHANGES TO THE HEALTH
HEALTHY SOILS PROGRAM TO ENSURE
ALL FARMERS CAN ACCESS IT,
PROMOTING CLIMATE SMART
PRACTICES ACROSS CALIFORNIA. THE
BILL DIRECTS THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF FOOD AND
AGRICULTURE TO OFFER GRANTS FOR
ON-FARM DEMONSTRATION PROJECTS.
AB 2735 ENJOYS BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT, AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. MEMBERS, ANY
DISCUSSION ON THIS MEASURE? ANY
DISCUSSION? SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN ALVARADO. GILL. AYE.
ARCHULETA Ã. ASHBY. AYE. ATKINS
AYE. BECKER. BLAKE. SPEER. AYE
BRADFORD. AYE. CABALLERO AYE.
CORTEZ AYE. DALY DODD. DURAZZO
AYE. EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER AYE.
AYE. GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE
HURTADO. JONES. AYE. LAIRD AYE.
LEHMAN. AYE. MAGUIRE MENGIBAR.
MIN. AYE NEWMAN. AYE. WHEN I
NHIÀU. AYE. OKUBO AYE. PADILLA.
AYE. PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH. AYE
RUBIO. SEYARTO AYE. SKINNER AYE.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE STERNE
AYE. UMBERG AYE. WAHAB. AYE
WIENER. WILK AYE. SENATOR LEMON
MOVES A CALL. WE'LL MOVE NEXT TO
FILE ITEM 319. THIS IS ASSEMBLY
BILL 2780. SECRETARY, PLEASE
READ ASSEMBLY BILL 2780 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MACKINNON AND
AQUILANTE. CARRIERS OF
PASSENGERS. SENATOR DURAZZO.
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. AB
2780 WOULD REQUIRE CHARTERED BUS
CARRIERS TO NOTIFY LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AT LEAST 24 HOURS
BEFORE TRANSPORTING VULNERABLE
PASSENGERS FROM OUT OF STATE TO
A CALIFORNIA CITY, COUNTY OR
OTHER LOCAL JURISDICTION. THIS
COUNTRY HAS A PROUD HISTORY OF
COMPASSIONATELY WELCOMING, LEGAL
ASYLUM SEEKERS FROM AROUND THE
WORLD. CITIES, COUNTIES, AND
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS HAVE
ORGANIZED AS BEST THEY CAN IN
THE PAST SEVERAL YEARS TO TRIAGE
THESE LEGAL ASYLUM SEEKERS AND
PROVIDE THEM WITH TEMPORARY,
HUMANE CARE, INCLUDING FOOD,
CLOTHING AND SHELTER. WHAT IS
MISSING IS KNOWING WHEN THESE
LEGAL ASYLUM SEEKERS WILL ARRIVE
IN A CALIFORNIA CITY, SO THAT
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS CAN HELP PREVENT
POTENTIAL HUMAN LABOR OR SEX
TRAFFICKING. OF THESE
INDIVIDUALS, AND TO BETTER
COORDINATE HUMANITARIAN AID,
REQUIRES THE CHARTER BUS
CARRIERS TO PROVIDE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS WITH A 24 HOUR
NOTICE. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU. SENATOR
DURAZZO, ANY DISCUSSION ON THIS
MEASURE? ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION?
SEEING NONE. SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN ALVARADO.
GILL. ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD. AYE
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ. AYE
DALY. DODD DURAZZO. AYE. EGGMAN
AYE. GLAZER. AYE. GONZALEZ AYE.
GROVE. HURTADO JONES. NO. LAIRD
AYE. LIMÓN. AYE MAGUIRE.
MENGIBAR. MIN AYE. NEWMAN. AYE.
NGUYEN NILO. AYE OCHOA. PADILLA.
AYE PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH AYE.
RUBIO. SEYARTO NO. SKINNER. AYE.
SMALLWOOD CUEVAS AYE. STERN AYE.
WAHAB AYE. EXCUSE ME. UMBERG
AYE. WAHAB. AYE. WIENER WILK.
WEN. NO SENATOR DURAZO MOVES A
CALL. WE'LL MOVE NEXT TO FILE
ITEM 320. THIS IS ASSEMBLY BILL
2872. SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. EXCUSE ME. PLEASE READ THE
ITEM. GETTING A LITTLE AHEAD OF
MYSELF. THERE ASSEMBLY BILL 2872
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER CALDERON. AN
ACT RELATING TO INSURANCE.
SENATOR LAIRD WILL ACTUALLY
HEAR. HEAR YOUR BILL FIRST
BEFORE WE CALL. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT, BUT I APPRECIATED THE
INFERRED POWERFUL PRESENTATION.
THIS BILL IS SPONSORED BY
INSURANCE COMMISSIONER RICARDO
LARA AND WOULD HELP PROVIDE A
NEEDED PAY INCREASE FOR
INVESTIGATORS AT THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE. THE PAY
INEQUITY BETWEEN THE DEPARTMENT
OF INSURANCE AND OTHER DIVISIONS
IS A MAJOR FACTOR IN RETAINING
SWORN OFFICERS. THE INSURANCE
OFFICERS ARE CURRENTLY BEING
PAID ALMOST 21% LESS FOR
PERFORMING SIMILAR WORK FROM
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE OF SIMILAR
WORKERS. WOMEN REPRESENT 40% OF
LEADERSHIP POSITIONS AND 35% OF
THE RANK AND FILE POSITIONS AT
THE DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE.
THIS IS THE HIGHEST PERCENTAGE
OF WOMEN IN LAW ENFORCEMENT
ACROSS THE STATE AND ACROSS THE
NATION. BECAUSE OF THE WAY THESE
POSITIONS ARE FUNDED, AB 2872
DOES NOT DIRECTLY IMPACT THE
STATE. GENERAL FUND. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. SENATOR LAIRD,
ANY DISCUSSION ON THIS MEASURE?
ANY DISCUSSION? SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN ALVARADO NØ. ARCHULETA
AYE. ASHBY. ATKINS AYE. BECKER.
BLAKE. SPEER BRADFORD. AYE
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ AYE.
DALY. NÓ. DODD AYE. DURAZZO.
AYE. EGGMAN AYE. GLAZER. AYE.
GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE HURTADO.
JONES NO. LAIRD. AYE. LEHMAN
AYE. MAGUIRE. MENGIBAR AYE. BIN.
AYE NEUMANN. AYE. NGUYEN. NO
NILO. NO. OCHOA PADILLA. AYE
PORTANTINO. AYE. ROTH AYE.
RUBIO. SUGIARTO NO. SKINNER AYE.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE STERN.
UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB AYE. WIENER
WILK. AYE SEN. LAIRD MOVES A
CALL. RUBIO. AYE.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE NEXT TO FILE
ITEM 321. THIS IS ASSEMBLY BILL
2873. SECRETARY, PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL 2873 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GARCIA. AN ACT RELATING
TO WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT.
SENATOR DURAZO. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. THIS BILL, AUTHORED
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER GARCIA, MAKES
SMALL BUT IMPACTFUL CHANGES TO
THE BREAKING BARRIERS TO
EMPLOYMENT INITIATIVE, MAKING
THE PROGRAM MORE EQUITABLE,
FLEXIBLE AND ACCESSIBLE WHILE
MAINTAINING THE PROGRAM'S GOALS.
THE BILL HAS RECEIVED NO NO
VOTES AND IS SUPPORTED BY A
LARGE COALITION OF COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS AND LOCAL
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT BOARDS. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU. SENATOR DURAZO. ANY
DISCUSSION ON THIS MEASURE?
SEEING NONE, SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN. AYE.
ALVARADO. GILL. AYE. ARCHULETA
AYE. ASHBY. ATKINS AYE. BECKER
AYE. BLAKE. SPEER BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO. CORTEZ AYE. DALY.
DODD AYE. DURAZO. AYE EGGMAN.
AYE. GLAZER. AYE GONZALEZ. AYE.
GROVE AYE. HURTADO. JONES AYE.
LAIRD. AYE. LIMON AYE. MCGUIRE
MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN AYE. NEWMAN
WHEN. NILO AYE. OCHOA. BOGH
PADILLA. AYE. PORTANTINO AYE.
ROTH. AYE. RUBIO SUGIARTO.
SKINNER. AYE SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS
AYE. STERN UMBERG AYE. WAHAB.
WIENER. WAHAB AYE. WIENER. WILK
AYE. SENATOR DURAZO MOVES THE
CALL. NEXT UP. ITEM 322.
ASSEMBLY BILL 2971. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ. THE. ASSEMBLY BILL
2971 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER MANCINI.
AN ACT TO CLASSIFIED EMPLOYEES.
SENATOR CORTESE, THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. COLLEAGUES CLASSIFIED
SCHOOL EMPLOYEES ARE THE PEOPLE
WHO KEEP OUR SCHOOLS RUNNING
SMOOTHLY FROM SERVING MEALS TO
CLEANING CLASSROOMS. I THINK
MOST OF US ARE AWARE OF THAT.
UNFORTUNATELY, MANY SCHOOLS ARE
FACING STAFFING SHORTAGES, WHICH
MAKES IT HARDER TO SUPPORT
STUDENTS AND MAINTAIN A HEALTHY
ENVIRONMENT. CURRENTLY, THERE
ARE NO CLEAR GUIDELINES ON HOW
MANY STAFF MEMBERS SCHOOLS
ACTUALLY NEED. THE PANDEMIC MADE
THOSE ISSUES EVEN MORE ACUTE. AB
2971 SIMPLY ADDS COMMUNITY
COLLEGES TO AN EXISTING
CLASSIFIED EMPLOYEE STAFFING
RATIO WORKGROUP. THIS BILL WILL
HELP US HAVE BETTER
CONVERSATIONS IN THE WORKGROUP
ABOUT HOW MANY STAFF MEMBERS
SCHOOLS NEED TO KEEP STUDENTS
SAFE AND SUPPORTED. IT'S AN
IMPORTANT STEP TOWARDS CREATING
A STRONGER AND MORE RESILIENT
EDUCATIONAL SYSTEM. THANK YOU
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
I VOTE. THANK YOU. SENATOR
CORTESE, ANY DISCUSSION ON THIS
MEASURE? ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION?
SEEING NONE. SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. EXCUSE ME. YEAH.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN.
AYE. ALVARADO. GILL NO.
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY ATKINS.
AYE. BECKER AYE. BLAKE. SPEAR.
BRADFORD CABALLERO. CORTEZ AYE.
DALY. NØ. DODD AYE. DURAZZO. AYE
EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER. AYE
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE HURTADO.
GROVE. NO. HURTADO JONES. NO.
LAIRD AYE. LEMON. AYE MCGUIRE.
MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN AYE. NEWMAN.
WHEN NO. NILO. NO. OKUBO NO.
PADILLA. PORTANTINO. AYE. ROTH
AYE. RUBIO. SEYARTO NO. SKINNER.
AYE SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE.
STERN WAHAB. I MEAN UMBERG. AYE.
WAHAB AYE. WIENER WILK. NO SEN.
CORTEZ MOVES A CALL. NEXT UP,
FILE ITEM 329. THIS IS ASSEMBLY
BILL 1122. SECRETARY, PLEASE
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL 1122 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BARNES AND
AQUILINA TO VESSELS. SENATOR
ARCHULETA. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. I RISE TO PRESENT AB
1122 BY DOCTOR BAINS, AND THIS
BILL WILL ENSURE THAT WE ACHIEVE
AIR QUALITY IMPROVEMENTS AT OUR
PORTS AND HARBORS, WHILE AT THE
SAME TIME PROTECTING THE LIVES
AND THE LIVELIHOOD OF OUR
MARINERS. US COAST GUARD HAS
RAISED SAFETY CONCERNS ABOUT THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE COMMERCIAL
HARBOR CRAFT RULE, WHICH WILL
REQUIRE SHIPS AND BOATS TO
UPGRADE TO NEWER AND CLEANER
PROPULSION SYSTEMS. AB 1122
MAINTAINS THAT THE REQUIREMENT
OF THESE CLEAN AIR RULES, WHILE
ADDRESSING THE COAST GUARD
CONCERNS BY REQUIRING THE
INCLUSION OF A BYPASS SYSTEM
THAT A VESSEL CAPTAIN MAY
ACTIVATE IN AN EMERGENCY, AN
EMERGENCY SITUATION. IN ADDITION,
UNIONS HAVE RAISED CONCERNS THAT
THEIR CREWS COULD LOSE B 25
BETWEEN 25 AND 30% OF THEIR
INCOMES WHILE VESSELS GO INTO
DRY DOCK FOR THE ENGINE
UPGRADES. THE BILL MINIMIZES
THEIR LOST INCOME FOR WORKERS BY
ALLOWING VESSELS TO ALIGN THEIR
COAST GUARD INSPECTION SCHEDULE
WITH THE REQUIREMENTS TO INSTALL
NEW ENGINES. SINCE THE CREWS
ALREADY OPERATE AROUND COAST
GUARD INSPECTIONS. ALIGNMENT
WILL SIGNIFICANTLY REDUCE THE
IMPACT ON WORKERS INCOMES. AB
1122 WAS DRAFTED WITH THE INTENT
TO BE NARROW AND TAILORED IN
ADDRESSING THE LEGITIMATE SAFETY
AND ECONOMIC CONCERNS THAT HAVE
BEEN RAISED. THE BILL IS
SPONSORED BY STAKEHOLDERS FROM
ACROSS THE INDUSTRY, INCLUDING
THE CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION,
INLAND BOATMEN'S UNION, AND THE
INTERNATIONAL ORGANIZATION OF
MASTERS, MATES AND PILOTS. FOR
THESE REASONS, I ASK FOR YOUR
VOTE. THANK YOU. SENATOR
ARCHULETA, ANY DISCUSSION ON
THIS MEASURE, ANY DISCUSSION ON
THIS MEASURE? SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN ALVARADO. GILL. AYE.
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY. AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER. AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER BRADFORD. AYE. CABALLERO
AYE. CORTEZ. AYE. DALY AYE. DODD
AYE. DURAZZO. AYE. EGGMAN. AYE.
GLASER. AYE. AYE. GONZALEZ GROVE.
AYE. HURTADO JONES. AYE. LAIRD
AYE. LEHMAN AYE. MCGUIRE
MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN AYE. NEWMAN
WHEN? AYE. NILO AYE. OCHOA. BORG
AYE. PADILLA AYE. PORTANTINO.
AYE. ROTH AYE. RUBIO SEYARTO
AYE. SKINNER AYE. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. AYE. STERN. UMBERG. AYE.
WAHAB. AYE. WIENER WILK. AYE
SENATOR ARCHULETA MOVES A CALL.
MEMBERS HERE ARE THE SENATORS
THAT ARE NEXT ON DECK. HERE WE
HAVE BECKER, LAIRD. SKINNER.
UMBERG. LAIRD, WE'RE GOING TO
BEGIN WITH FILE ITEM 342.
ASSEMBLY BILL, 1937. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL, 1937
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERMAN. AN
ACT RELATING TO STATE PROPERTY.
SENATOR BECKER, THANK YOU. THIS
BILL WILL FACILITATE THE
TRANSFER OF EXCESS CALTRANS
PROPERTY NEAR PACIFICA STATE
BEACH TO THE DEPARTMENT OF PARKS
AND RECREATION FOR STATE PARK
PURPOSES. IT WILL ENSURE
ULTIMATELY, MORE CALIFORNIANS
CAN ACCESS PACIFICA'S BEAUTIFUL
BEACHES. AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU.
SENATOR BECKER, ANY DISCUSSION
ON THIS MEASURE? ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION ON THE MEASURE?
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL. PLEASE
CALL THE VOTE. ALLEN AYE.
ALVARADO. GILL AYE. ARCHULETA.
AYE. ASHBY AYE. ATKINS. AYE.
BECKER AYE. BLAKE. SPEER.
BRADFORD AYE. CABALLERO AYE.
CORTEZ. AYE DALY. AYE. DODD AYE.
DURAZO. AYE. EGGMAN. AYE.
GLAZER. AYE. AYE. GONZALEZ. AYE.
GROVE AYE. HURTADO JONES. NO.
LAIRD AYE. LIMÓN AYE. MCGUIRE
MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN AYE. NEWMAN.
NGUYEN NILO. NO OCHOA. PADILLA
AYE. BROUGH. AYE. PORTANTINO
AYE. ROTH AYE. RUBIO. SUGIARTO
RUBIO. AYE. SKINNER. AYE.
SMALLWOOD CUEVAS. AYE. STERN
UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB AYE. WIENER
AYE. WILK. AYE. SEN. BECKER.
WHEN? AYE REMIND MEMBERS WE'RE
GOING TO ONLY GO THROUGH THE
RULE ONCE BECAUSE WE HAVE FOLKS
OFF THE FLOOR. SO WE'LL PUT
THINGS ON CALL. ALL RIGHT. WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE NEXT TO FILE ITEM
346. THIS IS ASSEMBLY BILL 2103.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL 2103 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PELLERIN. AN ACT RELATING TO
STATE PARKS. SENATOR LAIRD.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH, MR.
PRESIDENT, FOLLOWING THE
DEVASTATING CCU LIGHTNING WIRED
FIRE, WHICH BURNED ACROSS THE
ENTIRETY OF BIG BASIN STATE
PARK, WHICH IS IN THE AUTHOR'S
DISTRICT AND MY DISTRICT, THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF PARKS
AND RECREATION, INITIATED A
PLANNING PROCESS TO REIMAGINE
AND REBUILD BIG BASIN REDWOODS.
HOWEVER, THE CURRENT PROCESS OF
STATE LAND ACQUISITIONS REQUIRED
APPROVALS BY THE PUBLIC WORKS
BOARD AND THE DEPARTMENT OF
GENERAL SERVICES IS OFTEN
DELAYED AND MAKES CONSERVATION
ORGANIZATION WAIT MANY MONTHS TO
TRANSFER PROPERTY. WITH THIS
URGENCY, THIS WILL HELP BRING
CERTAINTY TO THE ACQUISITION
PARTNERS BY ADDING PROPERTY
ACQUIRED BY BIG BASIN REDWOODS.
UN NUEVO BUTANO STATE PARK TO
THE LIST OF EXEMPTIONS FROM THE
PUBLIC WORKS BOARD. THERE'S NO
REGISTERED OPPOSITION. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A NO VOTE.
THANK YOU. SENATOR LAIRD, ANY
DISCUSSION ON THIS MEASURE?
SEEING NO. MICROPHONE'S UP.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN. AYE. ALVARADO. GO
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER. BRADFORD. AYE. CABALLERO
AYE. CORTEZ AYE. DALLY. DODD
DURAZO. AYE. EGGMAN. AYE. GLASER
AYE. AYE. GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE
HURTADO. AYE. JONES NO. LAIRD.
AYE. LIMON AYE. MCGUIRE
MANJESHWAR. AYE. MIN AYE.
NEWMAN. NGUYEN NILO. OKUBO
PADILLA. PORTANTINO. AYE ROTH.
AYE. RUBIO AYE. CIERTO SKINNER.
AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS AYE.
STERN. UMBERG AYE. WAHAB. AYE.
WIENER WILK. SEN. LAIRD MOVES A
CALL. NEXT UP. FILE ITEM 349.
ASSEMBLY BILL 2178. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY BILL 2178
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER TING. AN ACT
RELATING TO PRISONS. SENATOR
SKINNER. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. MEMBERS, PLEASE
PRESENT THE BILL AB 2178 ON
BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER TING.
THIS BILL FOLLOWS A
RECOMMENDATION BY OUR
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE TO
SET AN EMPTY BED THRESHOLD PER
FISCAL YEAR ON CALIFORNIA'S
PRISON POPULATION HAS BEEN
STEADILY DECLINING AND ACCORDING
TO THE LA. S FEBRUARY 2024
REPORT BY 2028, CALIFORNIA COULD
HAVE NEARLY 19,000 EMPTY PRISON
BEDS. THE PROJECTION FOR CAPITAL
OUTLAY IS ANTICIPATED TO BE 2
BILLION OVER THE NEXT TEN YEARS,
WITH WHEN WE'RE FACING DEFICITS,
WE COULD SAVE SOME OF THAT
CAPITAL OUTLAY BY NOT REPAIRING
ASPECTS OF FACILITIES THAT WE
MAY NOT NEED OR USE. SO BY
FOLLOWING THE LAO'S
RECOMMENDATION TO SET AN EMPTY
BED THRESHOLD PER FISCAL YEAR,
THE STATE COULD AVOID SPENDING
SOME OF THOSE FUNDS AND WITHOUT.
WITH THAT, I ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. MEMBERS. IS THERE A
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
MEASURE? DISCUSSION OR DEBATE?
SEEING NONE. SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN AYE.
ALVARADO. GILL. AYE. ARCHULETA.
AYE. ASHBY ALVARADO. GILL. I
DON'T KNOW, ASHBY. ATKINS AYE.
BECKER. AYE. BLAKE. SPEER.
BRADFORD. AYE. CABALLERO AYE.
CORTEZ AYE. DALLY. NØ. DODD NO.
DURAZO AYE. EGGMAN GLASER.
EGGMAN. AYE. GLASER. GONZALEZ
AYE. GROVE. NO. HURTADO JONES.
NO. LAIRD. AYE. LEHMAN AYE.
MCGUIRE MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN
NEWMAN. NGUYEN. NO. NILO NO.
OCHOA. NO. PADILLA. AYE.
PORTANTINO. AYE. ROTH RUBIO.
SEYARTO. NO SKINNER. AYE.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE. STERN.
UMBERG. WAHAB. AYE. WIENER.
WILK. NØ SENATOR. SKINNER MOVES
A CALL. MEMBERS. THE NEXT FIVE
BILLS. WE'RE GOING TO TAKE UP AT
LEAST PLAN TO TAKE UP IN ORDER
AS FOLLOWS. FILE ITEM THREE
5351, 352, 357 AND 363 AS HER
FLOOR MANAGER'S UMBERG LAIRD,
ROTH, PADILLA AND CORTESE. NEXT
UP IS FILE ITEM 350. ASSEMBLY
BILL 2193 BY SENATOR BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER, HOLDEN SECRETARY. PLEASE
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL 2193 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER HOLDEN. AN ACT
RELATING TO HAZING. SENATOR
UMBERG, THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT AND
COLLEAGUES. AB 2193 ALLOWS FOR A
CIVIL ACTION TO BE BROUGHT
AGAINST AN INSTITUTION OF HIGHER
LEARNING FOR INSTANCES OF HAZING
INVOLVING ONE OR MORE STUDENTS.
IF THE INSTITUTION HAD DIRECT
INVOLVEMENT, KNEW OR SHOULD HAVE
KNOWN OF THE DANGEROUS HAZING,
HAZING PRACTICES AND FAILED TO
INTERVENE. THIS IS A FOLLOW ON
TO BILLS THAT PROVIDED FOR
RESPONSIBILITY FOR MERE
NEGLIGENCE. THIS REQUIRES THAT
THE INSTITUTION EITHER HAVE BEEN
DIRECTLY INVOLVED, OR KNEW, OR
SHOULD HAVE KNOWN OF THE HAZING
PRACTICES. I URGE AND I VOTE.
MEMBERS. ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS MEASURE.
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEEING
NONE. SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN AYE. ALVARADO. GILL
NO. ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY.
ATKINS AYE. BECKER. BLAKE. SPEER
BRADFORD. AYE. CABALLERO CORTEZ.
AYE. DAWLEY. NO. DODD. AYE.
DURAZO. AYE. EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE. NO.
HURTADO. AYE. JONES. NO. LAIRD.
AYE. LEHMAN. AYE. MCGUIRE.
MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN NEWMAN.
NGUYEN. NO. NILO. NO. OCHOA
PADILLA. AYE. PORTANTINO AYE.
ROTH AYE. RUBIO CIERTO. NO
SKINNER. AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS.
AYE. STERN. UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB.
AYE. WIENER. WILK. AYE SENATOR
UMBERG MOVES A CALL. NEXT UP,
FILE ITEM 351. ASSEMBLY BILL
2202. SECRETARY, PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL 2202 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RENDON. AN ACT RELATING
TO SHORT TERM RENTALS. SENATOR
LAIRD. THANK YOU VERY MUCH, MR.
PRESIDENT. AB 2202 REQUIRES THAT
CALIFORNIA SHORT TERM VACATION
RENTALS INFORM CUSTOMERS WHAT
CLEANING CHORES THEY WILL BE
ASKED TO COMPLETE AT THE HOME
BEFORE THE CUSTOMER BOOKS THE
RENTAL. WE'LL ALSO REQUIRE THAT
ANY PENALTIES RENTERS MIGHT
INCUR IF THEY FAIL TO COMPLETE
THESE TASKS BE OUTLINED PRIOR TO
BOOKING. AMENDMENTS TAKEN IN
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS NARROW THE
SCOPE OF THE BILL AND CLARIFY
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS, AMONG
OTHER TECHNICAL CHANGES. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. MEMBERS, ANY DISCUSSION ON
THIS MEASURE? SEEING NO
MICROPHONES UP, SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN.
AYE. ALVARADO. GILL. AYE.
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY. ATKINS.
AYE. BECKER. AYE. BLAKE SPEER.
BRADFORD. AYE. CABALLERO. AYE.
CORTEZ. AYE. DALY. DODD DURAZZO.
EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER. AYE. AYE.
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE. AYE.
HURTADO. AYE. JONES. LAIRD. AYE
LEHMAN. AYE. MCGUIRE MENGIBAR.
I'M IN. AYE. NEWMAN. WHEN NILO.
OCHOA PADILLA. AYE. PORTANTINO.
AYE. ROTH AYE. RUBIO AYE. NILO.
AYE OCHOA. AYE. SATO NO. SKINNER
AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS AYE.
STERN. HAMBURG AYE. WAHAB. AYE.
WIENER AYE. WILK. AYE. SENATOR
LAIRD MOVES A CALL. NEXT UP,
FILE ITEM 352. ASSEMBLY BILL
2231. SECRETARY, PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL 2231 BY SENATE
MEMBER GIBSON. AN ACT RELATING
TO PAWNBROKERS. SENATOR ROTH.
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. THIS
BILL SEEKS TO PROPOSE MANDATORY
CONTINUING EDUCATION FOR
PAWNBROKERS IN CALIFORNIA.
BEFORE RECEIVING LICENSURE, ALL
PAWNBROKERS WOULD BE MANDATED TO
TAKE EIGHT HOURS OF TRAINING.
THE BILL HAS RECEIVED BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT AND HAS NO OPPOSITION.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. MEMBERS ANY DISCUSSION ON
THIS MEASURE? ANY DEBATE ON THIS
MEASURE? SEEING NONE. SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN AYE.
ALVARADO. GILL. AYE. ARCHULETA.
AYE. ASHBY AYE. ATKINS AYE.
BECKER. AYE. BLAKE. SPEER.
BRADFORD. AYE. CABALLERO. AYE.
CORTEZ AYE. DALLY. DODD AYE.
DURAZZO. AYE. EGGMAN AYE.
GLAZER. AYE. AYE. GONZALEZ GROVE.
AYE. HURTADO AYE. JONES NO.
LAIRD. AYE. LEHMAN. AYE.
MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN AYE.
NEWMAN. WHEN NILO. OKUBO.
PADILLA AYE. PORTANTINO. AYE.
ROTH. AYE. RUBIO. AYE SATO. NO.
SKINNER SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS AYE.
STERN. UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB. AYE.
WIENER. WILK. AYE SENATOR ROSS.
SEYARTO. NO. TO. AYE MEMBERS A
REMINDER YOU'LL GET ANOTHER
CHANCE WHEN WE PUT BILLS ON
CALL. SO. SEN. ROTH MOVES A
CALL. WE'RE GOING TO MOVE NEXT
TO FILE ITEM 357. THIS IS
ASSEMBLY BILL 2440. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL 2440
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER REYES AN ACT
RELATING TO ENVIRONMENTAL
PROTECTION. SENATOR PADILLA IS
PRESENTING. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. I PRESENT AB 2440 ON
BEHALF OF ASSEMBLYMEMBER REYES,
WHICH WILL INCORPORATE THE STATE
PARKS DEPARTMENT AND OTHER
AGENCIES MANAGING STATE OWNED
LANDS INTO THE STATE'S GOALS OF
CONSERVE 30% OF LANDS AND
COASTAL WATERS BY 2030. THE BILL
WOULD ENSURE EQUITABLE ACCESS TO
THE OUTDOORS FOR ALL AND SPECIFY
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS AROUND
THE GOAL. CALIFORNIA STATE PARKS
ARE AN INVALUABLE ASSET TO
CONSERVATION AND PROVIDING
PUBLIC ACCESS TO OUR INCREDIBLE
LANDSCAPES. THEY SHOULD BE
INCLUDED IN THE SUPPORT,
ACQUISITION AND STEWARDSHIP OF
STATE LANDS. THIS BILL IS
RECEIVED NO NØ VOTES. I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. SENATOR
PADILLA. ANY DISCUSSION ON THIS
MEASURE? ANY DISCUSSION? SEEING.
NONE. SECRETARY, PLEASE HOLD ON.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN AYE. ALVARADO. AYE.
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY ATKINS.
AYE. BECKER. BLAKE. SPEER. AYE
BECKER. AYE. BLAKE. SPEER
BRADFORD. AYE. CABALLERO AYE.
CORTEZ. AYE. DALY NÓ. DODD. AYE.
DURAZO. AYE. EGGMAN AYE. GLAZER.
AYE. GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE NO.
HURTADO AYE. JONES JONES. AYE.
LAIRD. AYE. LEHMAN. AYE.
MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR. I'M IN. AYE.
NEWMAN. NGUYEN. NILO. AYE. OCHOA
PADILLA. AYE. PORTANTINO AYE.
ROTH AYE. RUBIO. AYE. CIERTO
SKINNER. AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS.
AYE. STERN. UMBERG AYE. WAHAB
AYE. WIENER AYE. WILK. AYE.
SENATOR PADILLA MOVES A CALL.
OKAY, MEMBERS. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PATIENCE. WE'RE GOING TO
CONTINUE ON WITH THE FILE IN THE
FOLLOWING ORDER. FILE ITEM 363
367, THREE 7413 AND 419. OKAY,
WE'RE GOING TO TURN NEXT TO FILE
ITEM 363. THIS IS ASSEMBLY BILL
2738. SECRETARY, PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL 2738 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER THREE OF US. AN ACT TO
DEPLOYMENT. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. SENATOR CORTESE, THE
FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. AB 2738 SEEKS TO STRENGTHEN
THE ENFORCEMENT TO PROTECT STAGE
PRODUCTION WORKERS BY HOLDING
PUBLIC VENUES ACCOUNTABLE AND
INCREASING CONTRACT
TRANSPARENCY. TO VERIFY THAT
PRODUCTION COMPANIES HIRE
TRAINED WORKERS. ADDITIONALLY
EXPANDS THE EXISTING AUTHORITY
OF LOCAL PUBLIC AGENCIES TO
ENFORCE THE LIVE EVENT SAFETY
LAW AND OTHER LABOR LAWS TO
REDUCE THE BACKLOG AT STATE
AGENCIES. AND THEN LASTLY, IT
MAKES A SMALL CHANGE TO AB 594
FROM LAST YEAR, WHICH REQUIRES
RATHER THAN ALLOWS A COURT TO
AWARD REASONABLE ATTORNEY'S FEES
TO THE PUBLIC PROSECUTOR. IF
THEY WIN THE CASE, SO THAT LOCAL
PUBLIC AGENCIES ARE ADEQUATELY
FUNDED FOR ENFORCEMENT. THE
AUTHOR TOOK AMENDMENTS AND
SENATOR PROPES FROM THE LABOR
AGENCY TO HAVE THE PENALTIES GO
TO THE VICTIMS FIRST. THE
REMAINING PENALTIES WILL GO TO
THE GENERAL FUND BEFORE
REIMBURSING LOCAL PROSECUTORS.
WE NEED TO ALLOW LOCAL
PROSECUTORS TO RECOVER FEES
BECAUSE THERE'S AN UNLEVEL
PLAYING FIELD FOR A LARGE
DEFENDANT AGAINST SMALLER
ENTITIES THAT ARE NOT FROM OUR
LARGE CITIES TO GO AFTER LABOR
VIOLATIONS. THE PUBLIC COUNSEL,
THEY WILL BE AT A SEVERE
DISADVANTAGE. THEY'RE TAKING A
GAMBLE THAT THEY'RE GOING TO
SUCCEED AND RETURN AND RECOVER.
ATTORNEY FEES. THIS IS SIMPLY
TRYING TO EMPOWER PUBLIC SECTOR
PROSECUTORS TO ENFORCE LABOR
VIOLATIONS, TO REDUCE THE BURDEN
ON THE STATE. AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU. SENATOR CORTESE, ANY
DISCUSSION ON THIS MEASURE? ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION ON THIS
MEASURE? SEEING NONE. SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLAN
ALVARADO, GIL NÓ. ARCHULETA.
AYE. ASHBY ATKINS. AYE. BECKER
AYE. BLAKE. SPEER BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO AYE. CORTEZ. AYE. DALI
NØ. DODD. DURAZZO AYE. EGGMAN.
AYE. GLAZER AYE. GONZALEZ. AYE
GROVE. NO. HURTADO. AYE JONES.
NO. LAIRD AYE. LEHMAN AYE.
MAGUIRE. MENGIBAR MIN. AYE.
NEWMAN NGUYEN. NO. NILO NO.
OCHOA. NO. PADILLA AYE.
PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH AYE. RUBIO
AYE. SEYARTO. NO SKINNER. AYE.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS AYE. STERN
UMBERG. AYE WAHAB. AYE. WIENER
AYE. WILK NO. SENATOR CORTEZ
MOVES A CALL. OUR NEXT FILE
ITEM, THE AUTHOR IS OFF THE
FLOOR. THE FLOOR MANAGER IS OFF
THE FLOOR. SO WE'RE GOING TO
SKIP THAT AND MOVE TO FILE ITEM
370. THIS IS ASSEMBLY BILL 3031.
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL 3031 BY SENATE MEMBER LEE.
AN ACT RELATING TO STATE
GOVERNMENT. SENATOR LAIRD, THE
FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. THIS BILL WOULD
CREATE THE LGBTQ PLUS COMMISSION
AT THE STATE LEVEL TO SERVE AS A
FOCAL POINT FOR THE WIDE RANGE
OF ISSUES FACING THE COMMUNITY.
THIS COMMISSION WOULD BE A
VALUABLE VOICE FOR THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR, AS
WE CONSIDER POLICIES THAT IMPACT
OUR STATE. IT'S MODELED AFTER
THE HIGHLY RESPECTED COMMISSION
ON THE STATUS OF WOMEN AND
GIRLS. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. MEMBERS, ANY
DISCUSSION ON THIS MEASURE? ANY
DISCUSSION? SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN AYE. ALVARADO. GILL AYE.
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY ATKINS.
AYE. BECKER. BLAKE. SPEAR
BECKER. AYE. BLAKE. SPEAR
BRADFORD. AYE. CABALLERO CORTEZ.
AYE. DALLY. DODD AYE. DURAZO.
AYE. ECKMAN. AYE. GLAZER. AYE.
AYE. GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE
HURTADO. AYE. JONES. LAIRD. AYE.
LEHMAN. AYE. MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR
MIN. AYE. NEWMAN NGUYEN. NILO
OCHOA. PADILLA AYE. PORTANTINO
AYE. ROTH. AYE. RUBIO. AYE.
SEYARTO SKINNER. SMALLWOOD
CUEVAS. AYE. STERN UMBERG. AYE.
WAHAB. AYE. WIENER AYE. WILK.
SEN. LAIRD MOVES A CALL. NEXT UP
IS FILE ITEM 413. THIS IS
ASSEMBLY BILL 3042. SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. FOR FLOOR MANAGER.
SENATOR GROVE, ASSEMBLY MEMBER
30.
ASSEMBLY BILL 3042 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER STEPHANIE NGUYEN. AN ACT
RELATING TO COUNTY PENALTIES.
SENATOR. GROVE. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. COLLEAGUES, I RISE
TODAY TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL
3042 AUTHORED BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
STEPHANIE NGUYEN. THIS BILL IS
EXTENDS A SUNSET DATE FOR FOUR
YEARS ON PROPOSITION 69. THE DNA
FINGERPRINT, UNSOLVED CRIME AND
INNOCENCE PROTECTION ACT. FOR
TWO DECADES, PROPOSITION 69 IS
DIRECTED CRIMINAL FUNDS TOWARDS
DNA SAMPLE COLLECTION AND
TESTING EFFORTS, WHICH IS
ESSENTIAL FOR SOLVING CRIMES AND
EXONERATING THE INNOCENT. THE
PROGRAM RECOVERED OVER 106,000
DNA HITS ON UNSOLVED CRIMES IN
MAY, WHICH AND MANY OF WHICH
COULD HAVE BEEN SEXUAL ASSAULTS.
THIS BILL RECEIVED NO NO VOTES
AND HAS GONE THROUGH THE PROCESS.
WE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER NGUYEN. THANK YOU.
SENATOR GROVE, ANY DISCUSSION ON
THIS MEASURE? SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN AYE. ALVARADO. GILL. AYE.
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY. AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER. BLAKE
SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ AYE.
DALY. DODD AYE. DURAZZO. AYE.
EGGMAN AYE. GLAZER. AYE.
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE. AYE.
HURTADO. AYE. JONES. LAIRD. AYE.
LIMÓN. AYE. MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR.
MEN. AYE. NEWMAN. NGUYEN. AYE.
NILO. OCHOA. BOGH. PADILLA.
OCHOA. BORG. AYE PADILLA. AYE.
PORTANTINO AYE. NILO. AYE. ROTH.
AYE. RUBIO. AYE. SEYARTO. AYE.
SKINNER SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE.
STERN. AYE. UMBERG AYE. WAHAB
AYE. WIENER. AYE WILK. AYE.
SENATOR GROVE MOVES A CALL. NEXT
UP IS FILE ITEM 419. THIS IS
ASSEMBLY BILL 2427. FLOOR
MANAGER, SENATOR BECKER.
SECRETARY. PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL 2427 BY SENATE MEMBER
MCCARTY. AN ACT RELATING TO LAND
USE. SENATOR BECKER. THANK YOU.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN OF THE
SENATE. PLEASED TO PRESENT AB
2427 THE EQUITABLE EV CHARGING
ACT. THIS WILL MAKE CHARGING
MORE AVAILABLE TO MULTIFAMILY
HOUSING RESIDENTS, HELP THE
STATE'S EV GOALS, AND ALSO
RESOLVE RACIAL DISPARITIES BY
INCREASING ACCESS AND EQUITY. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
MEMBERS, ANY DISCUSSION ON THIS
MEASURE? ANY DISCUSSION? SEEING
NONE. SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN. AYE. ALVARADO.
GILL. ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY.
AYE. ATKINS. AYE. BECKER. AYE.
BLAKE. SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD.
AYE. CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ.
AYE. DALLY DODD. AYE. DURAZO.
AYE. EGGMAN. GLAZER. AYE.
GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE AYE.
HURTADO. AYE. JONES. LAIRD. AYE.
LEHMAN. AYE. MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR.
MIN NEWMAN. NGUYEN NHIÀU. OCHOA
PADILLA. AYE. PORTANTINO AYE.
ROTH. AYE. RUBIO. AYE. CIERTO
SKINNER. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE.
STERN. AYE. UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB
AYE. WIENER. AYE WILK. SEN.
BECKER MOVES A CALL. WE'RE GOING
TO MOVE BACK TO FILE ITEM 367.
THIS IS ASSEMBLY BILL 2917.
FLOOR MANAGER IS SENATOR BLAKE
SPEER. SECRETARY, PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL 2917 BY SENATE
MEMBER ZUBER. AN ACT RELATING TO
FIREARMS. SENATOR BLAKE SPEER.
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. AND
MEMBERS, I RISE TO PRESENT AB
2917 ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ZABIR. THIS BILL IS
SPONSORED BY EVERYTOWN FOR GUN
SAFETY AND THE SAN FRANCISCO
CITY ATTORNEY. IN THE LAST
DECADE, GUN VIOLENCE,
RESTRAINING ORDERS OR GROWS HAVE
BECOME ONE OF THE MOST EFFECTIVE
TOOLS AVAILABLE FOR PREVENTING
CERTAIN TYPES OF GUN VIOLENCE
BEFORE THEY OCCUR. AB 2917
UPDATES AND REFINES CALIFORNIA'S
NATION, LEADING GROW LAW TO DRAW
THE CIVIL COURT'S ATTENTION TO A
BROADER SET OF RISK FACTORS. IN
A COURT'S ANALYSIS OF WHETHER
TEMPORARY ACCESS TO A FIREARM
SHOULD BE RESTRICTED ACCORDING
TO THE CALIFORNIA ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S MOST RECENT REPORT ON
HATE CRIMES. HATE CRIMES
INVOLVING RACIAL BIAS. RELIGIOUS
BIAS, SEXUAL ORIENTATION BIAS,
AND GENDER BIAS ALL INCREASED
BETWEEN 2021 AND 2022. THIS BILL
GUIDES THE COURT TO CONSIDER
THREATS OF VIOLENCE MADE AGAINST
GROUPS PROTECTED BY HATE CRIMES
LAW AND THREATS OF VIOLENCE TO
ADVANCE POLITICAL OBJECTIVES. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. SENATOR BLAKE
SPEER, ANY DISCUSSION ON THIS
MEASURE? SEEING NO. MICROPHONE'S
UP. SECRETARY. PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN AYE. GILL. NO
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY ATKINS.
AYE. BECKER BLAKE. SPEER. AYE.
BRADFORD AYE. CABALLERO. AYE.
CORTEZ. AYE. DALY. DODD AYE.
DURAZO I. EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER.
AYE. GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE NO.
HURTADO AYE. JONES. NO. LAIRD.
AYE. LEHMAN. AYE. MCGUIRE.
MENGIBAR. I'M IN. AYE. NEWMAN.
WHEN NILO. NO. OCHOA PADILLA.
AYE. PORTANTINO. AYE. ROTH AYE.
RUBIO. AYE. CIERTO. NO. SKINNER.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE. STERN
UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB AYE. WIENER.
AYE. WILK. AYE SEN. BLAKE MOVES
A CALL. FOR MEMBERS. HERE'S THE
NEXT FIVE BILLS ON THE DOCKET
FOR 22, FOLLOWED BY 421, 423,
426, AND 428.
SO WE'RE GOING TO GO NOW TO A
FILE ITEM. 422 ASSEMBLY BILL
2533. SECRETARY, PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL 2533 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER JUAN CARRILLO. AN ACT
RELATING TO LAND USE. SENATOR
BLAKE SPEER. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT AND COLLEAGUES. I RISE
TODAY TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL
2533 ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER JUAN CARRILLO AB 2533
SEEKS TO FORMALLY GET EXISTING
UNPERMITTED ACCESSORY DWELLING
UNITS AND JUNIOR ACCESSORY
DWELLING UNITS ONLINE BY
UPDATING ADU AMNESTY LAWS. THIS
CHANGE WILL EMPOWER HOMEOWNERS
TO SEEK ADVICE FROM LICENSED
CONTRACTORS TO ADDRESS ANY
HEALTH AND SAFETY CONCERNS, AND
PROVIDE A PATHWAY FOR HOMEOWNERS
LOOKING TO LEGALIZE THEIR UNITS,
ADUS, OR INFILL. THEY ARE
AFFORDABLE, AND THEY ARE OFTEN A
CRITICAL STEPPING STONE FOR
MIDDLE CLASS FAMILIES TO BUILD
GENERATIONAL WEALTH, WHETHER BY
PROVIDING AN AFFORDABLE OPTION
TO FAMILY MEMBERS AND LOVED ONES,
OR AS RENTAL INCOME BUILDING AND
OWNING AN ADU CAN BE A LIFE
CHANGING ASSET. THIS BILL HAS
ENJOYED UNANIMOUS SUPPORT
THROUGHOUT THE PROCESS, AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. SENATOR BLAKE
SPEER, ANY DISCUSSION, MEMBERS,
ANY DISCUSSION ON THIS BILL?
SEEING NONE. SECRETARY. IS THAT
SENATOR UMBERG? IS YOUR
MICROPHONE UP FOR THIS BILL? NO
IS THERE A POINT OF ORDER? NO,
SIR. ALL RIGHT. SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN AYE.
ALVARADO. GILL. AYE. ARCHULETA.
AYE. ASHBY ATKINS. AYE. BECKER.
AYE. BLAKE. SPEER. AYE.
BRADFORD. AYE. CABALLERO. AYE.
CORTEZ AYE. DALY. AYE. DODD.
AYE. DURAZO. AYE. EGGMAN. AYE.
GLAZER. AYE GONZALEZ. AYE.
GROVE. AYE. HURTADO. AYE. JONES.
AYE. LAIRD. AYE. LEHMAN. AYE.
MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN.
AYE. NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN. NILO
AYE. OCHOA BORG. AYE. PADILLA.
AYE. PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH. AYE.
RUBIO. AYE. CIERTO. AYE.
SKINNER. SMALLWOOD CUEVAS. AYE.
STERN. UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB AYE.
WIENER. AYE WILK. AYE. SEN.
BLAKE. SPEAR MOVES A CALL. ALL
RIGHT. WE'RE GOING TO HEAR THREE
BILLS BY FLOOR MANAGER. SENATOR
MENJIVAR, WE'RE GOING TO BEGIN
WITH FILE ITEM 421. ASSEMBLY
BILL 2343. SECRETARY, PLEASE
READ ASSEMBLY BILL 2343 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CIOBO. AN ACT
RELATING TO PUBLIC, SOCIAL
SERVICES. SENATOR MENGIBAR.
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. AB
2343 WILL BRIDGE A GAP IN
SERVICES FOR FAMILIES SUFFERING
HOMELESSNESS AND DOMESTIC ABUSE
BY CODIFYING LANGUAGE ALLOWING
ALTERNATIVE PAYMENT PROGRAM
ADMINISTRATORS TO USE EXISTING
FUNDS TO MAKE REFERRALS FOR
THESE FAMILIES SEEKING CHILD
CARE TO OTHER SUPPORTIVE
SERVICES. RESPECTFULLY ASKING
FOR AN AYE VOTE. MEMBERS, ANY
DISCUSSION ON THIS MEASURE? ANY
DISCUSSION. SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN AYE. ALVARADO. GILL AYE.
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY ATKINS.
AYE. BECKER. AYE. BLAKE. SPEER.
AYE. BRADFORD. AYE CABALLERO.
AYE. CORTEZ. AYE. DALY. AYE.
DODD. AYE. DURAZO. AYE. EGGMAN.
AYE. GLAZER. AYE. AYE. GONZALEZ.
AYE. GROVE. AYE. HURTADO. AYE.
JONES AYE. LAIRD. AYE. LEHMAN.
AYE. MCGUIRE MENGIBAR. I'M IN.
AYE. NEWMAN AYE. NGUYEN. AYE
NEILA. AYE. OCHOA. BOGH. AYE.
PADILLA. AYE. PORTANTINO. AYE.
ROTH. AYE. RUBIO. AYE. SEGATO
AYE. SKINNER. SMALLWOOD CUEVAS.
AYE. STERN. UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB
AYE. WIENER AYE. WILK AYE.
SENATOR. MENGIBAR MOVES A CALL.
WE'RE GOING TO NOW TAKE UP TWO
ADDITIONAL BILLS BY OUR ACTIVITY
CHAIR. EXCUSE ME, SENATOR
MENGIBAR. WE WILL BEGIN WITH
FILE ITEM 295, FOLLOWED BY FILE
ITEM 316. SO 295 IS ASSEMBLY
BILL 2005. SECRETARY, PLEASE
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL 2005 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER, WARD. AN ACT TO
HOUSING. SENATOR MENGIBAR. ONCE
AGAIN, THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
AB 2005 WILL ALLOW CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITIES TO UTILIZE
THE LOW INCOME HOUSING TAX
CREDIT TO CREATE MORE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING FOR OUR AMAZING CSU
STAFF AND FACULTY. LACK OF
ACCESS TO AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN
CALIFORNIA HAS INCREASED
DIFFICULTY FOR CSUS TO RECRUIT
AND RETAIN DIVERSE, QUALITY
STAFF. PRIOR LEGISLATION HAS
PROVIDED ACCESS TO THE LOW
INCOME HOUSING TAX CREDIT TO OUR
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES,
AS WELL AS TO OUR K THROUGH 12
FACULTY, MAKING AB 2005 AN EASY
NEXT STEP TO PROVIDE HOUSING FOR
THESE REASONS, RESPECTFULLY
ASKING FOR NO VOTE. MEMBERS. ANY
DISCUSSION ON THIS MEASURE? ANY
DISCUSSION. SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE VOTE.
ALLEN AYE. ALVARADO. GILL. NO.
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY. AYE.
ATKINS AYE. BECKER. AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ. AYE.
DALLY. NÓ. DODD. AYE. DURAZO.
AYE. EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE. NO.
HURTADO AYE. JONES. NO. LAIRD.
AYE. LIMÓN. AYE. MCGUIRE.
MENGIBAR. I'M IN. AYE. NEWMAN.
AYE. NGUYEN. NHIÀU WATROBA. AYE.
PADILLA. AYE. PORTANTINO. AYE.
ROTH AYE. RUBIO. AYE. SEYARTO.
NØ. SKINNER AYE. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. AYE. STERN. UMBERG. AYE.
AYE. WAHAB AYE. WIENER AYE.
WILK. NO MEMBERS. WE HAVE A FULL
HOUSE NOW, SO WE'RE GOING TO GO
THROUGH THE ROLL ONE MORE TIME.
ONE FINAL TIME. SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
GLAZER. AYE. AYE. MCGUIRE.
NGUYEN NO. NILO NO. STERN.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. STERN. AYE
MEMBERS. ON A VOTE OF 31 TO 8,
THE MEASURE PASSES. WE'RE GOING
TO MOVE NEXT TO FILE ITEM 316.
THIS IS ASSEMBLY BILL 2704.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ. THE
ASSEMBLY BILL 2704. BOSTON.
MEMBER. ZUBIATE. AN ACT RELATING
TO IN-HOME SUPPORTIVE SERVICES.
SENATOR MENGIBAR. THANK YOU ONCE
AGAIN, MR. PRESIDENT. THIS BILL
WILL HELP STREAMLINE ENTRY INTO
THE IN-HOME SUPPORTIVE SERVICES
WORKFORCE. IT ALLEVIATES A
FINANCIAL BURDEN ON PROSPECTIVE
IHSS PROVIDERS BY SHIFTING THE
RESPONSIBILITY OF COVERING THE
DOJ COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH
CRIMINAL BACKGROUND CHECKS FROM
THE PROSPECTIVE PROVIDERS TO
DOJ, REMOVING BARRIERS TO ENTRY
INTO THIS WORKFORCE SHOULD BE A
PRIORITY FOR OUR STATE, AND THIS
BILL FURTHERS THAT GOAL BY
STREAMLINING THE PROCESS TO
RECRUIT IHSS PROVIDERS, ASKING
RESPECTFULLY FOR AN I VOTE. AND
IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS MEASURE?
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE? SEEING
NONE. SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN. AYE. ALVARADO. GILL.
AYE. ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY. AYE.
ATKINS. AYE BECKER. AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ. AYE.
DALY DODD. AYE. DURAZZO. AYE.
EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER. AYE. AYE.
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE. NO.
HURTADO AYE. JONES. NO. LAIRD
AYE. LEHMAN. AYE. MCGUIRE
MENGIBAR. I'M IN. AYE. NEWMAN.
AYE. NGUYEN NILO. NO. OCHOA
PADILLA. AYE. PORTANTINO. AYE.
ROTH. AYE. RUBIO. AYE CIERTO.
NO. SKINNER. AYE. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. AYE. STERN. AYE. UMBERG.
AYE. WAHAB. AYE. WIENER. AYE.
WILK. OCHOA. AYE PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. DALY. NO.
MCGUIRE. NGUYEN ON A VOTE OF 33
TO 5, THE MEASURE PASSES.
ALL RIGHT. NEXT UP, MEMBERS FILE
ITEMS 423, 426 AND 428. WE'LL
BEGIN WITH 423. THIS IS ASSEMBLY
BILL 1168. SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL 1168 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BENNETT. AN ACT
RELATING TO EMERGENCY MEDICAL
SERVICES. SENATOR LIMÓN IS FOR
MANAGING. PLEASE PROCEED. THANK
YOU. MEMBERS, I RISE TO PRESENT
AB 1168 ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BENNETT. THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT ISSUE IN OUR DISTRICT.
THE BILL WILL MAKE NARROW
CHANGES TO ALLOW THE CITY OF
OXNARD THE OPTION OF PROVIDING
AMBULANCE AND EMS SERVICES. AB
1168 CLARIFIES THAT WHEN A
JURISDICTION OR FIRE DISTRICT
ENTERS INTO A JOINT POWERS
AUTHORITY, IT DOES NOT
AUTOMATICALLY LOSE ITS ABILITY
TO CONTROL EMERGENCY SERVICES.
THE RECENT FULLER AMENDMENTS
EXPLICITLY STATE THAT NOTHING IN
THIS BILL ALTERS, MODIFIES,
DIMINISHES, OR ENLARGES ANY
RIGHTS OR OBLIGATIONS REGARDING
201 RIGHTS AND ENTERING A JPA.
THIS BILL HAS RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT, AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. SENATOR LIMÓN,
ANY DISCUSSION ON THIS MEASURE?
MEMBERS, ANY DISCUSSION? SEEING
NONE. SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. CALL THE VOTE. ALLEN
ALVARADO. GILL. AYE. ARCHULETA
ASHBY. AYE. ATKINS AYE. BECKER.
BLAKE. SPEER AYE. BRADFORD
CABALLERO. CORTEZ AYE. DALY
DODD. DURAZO AYE. EGGMAN. AYE.
GLASER. AYE. GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE
HURTADO. JONES AYE. LAIRD AYE.
LIMÓN AYE. MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR
AYE. MIN AYE. NEWMAN NGUYEN.
NILO OCHOA. PADILLA AYE.
PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH. AYE. RUBIO
AYE. CIERTO AYE. SKINNER AYE.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS AYE. STERN.
AYE. UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB AYE.
WIENER. AYE WILK. AYE. JUST A
MOMENT, PLEASE. MEMBERS. WE DO
HAVE A FULL HOUSE. WE'RE GOING
TO GO THROUGH THE ROLL. ONE MORE
TIME. SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ALLEN ARCHULETA.
AYE. BECKER BRADFORD. CABALLERO
AYE. DALI NÓ. DODD GROVE.
HURTADO AYE. MCGUIRE NEWMAN. AYE
WHEN? AYE. NILO. NØ. OKUBO AYE.
ON A VOTE OF 32 TO 2, THE
MEASURE PASSES. WE'RE GOING TO
DO TWO MORE ASSEMBLY. THIRD
READING ITEMS, MEMBERS. AND THEN
WE'RE GOING TO GO TO BILLS ON
CALL. SO BE PREPARED FOR THAT.
NEXT UP IS FILE ITEM FOR 26.
THIS IS ASSEMBLY BILL 2318.
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL 2318 BY SENATE MEMBER
PEPIN. AN ACT RELATING TO WATER.
SENATOR. SENATOR ALLEN IS
PREPARED. SENATOR TO GIVE YOU AN
ANSWER. YES. THANK YOU SO MUCH,
MR. PRESIDENT. YOU'RE DOING A
GREAT JOB. I RISE TODAY TO
PRESENT AB 2318 ON BEHALF OF
SENATE MEMBER PAPIN. IT WOULD
REQUIRE THE STATE WATER BOARD TO
PUBLISH AN ANNUAL REPORT
DETAILING THE RECEIPTS AND
EXPENDITURES OF THE CLEANUP AND
ABATEMENT ACCOUNT. AS FOLKS MAY
KNOW, WHEN A VIOLATION OF WATER
QUALITY STANDARDS OCCURS, THE
VIOLATOR HAS TWO OPTIONS THEY
CAN EITHER CONDUCT A
SUPPLEMENTAL ENVIRONMENTAL
PROJECT TO RESTORE THE WATERWAY,
OR THEY CAN PAY INTO THE STATE
WATER BOARD'S CLEANUP AND
ABATEMENT ACCOUNT. NOW, MOST
VIOLATORS OPT TO PAY PENALTIES
INTO THE CLEANUP AND ABATEMENT
ACCOUNT RATHER THAN CONDUCTING
THE WORK OF THE CLEANUP WORK
DIRECTLY, AND THE ACCOUNT WAS
DESIGNED WITH THE INTENTION THAT
FUNDS FROM THE PENALTIES WOULD
BE ALLOCATED BACK TO THE
AFFECTED COMMUNITIES TO REDRESS
AND REMEDIATE POLLUTION. BUT
THERE'S BEEN A LACK OF
COMPREHENSIVE REPORTING ON HOW
THESE FUNDS ARE USED, WHICH HAS
RAISED CONCERNS AND UNCERTAINTY
ABOUT THEIR ALLOCATION. THIS
MEASURE WOULD REQUIRE OUR WATER
BOARD TO DISCLOSE WHICH REGIONS
HAVE RECEIVED FUNDING FROM THE
ACCOUNT. IT'S A VERY MODEST
TRANSPARENCY MEASURE THAT WOULD
PROVIDE ASSURANCE TO COMMUNITIES
THAT THE FINES PAID BY POLLUTERS
ARE BEING USED EFFECTIVELY TO
ADDRESS LOCAL POLLUTION. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY VOTE.
MEMBERS, ANY DISCUSSION ON THIS
MEASURE? ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION?
THIS IS ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL. WITHOUT OBJECTION.
AYES 30 900. THE MEASURE PASSES
ALL RIGHT. THAT'S THE SPIRIT.
NEXT UP, ITEM 428. THIS IS
ASSEMBLY BILL 3281. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL 3281
BY THE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON
JUDICIARY. AN ACT RELATING TO
STATE GOVERNMENT. SENATOR
UMBERG. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. MEMBERS. THIS BILL
CONTAINS NUMEROUS MINOR UPDATES
TO THE VARIOUS CODE SECTIONS
WITHIN THE JURISDICTION OF THE
COMMITTEE. URGE AND I VOTE.
REALLY GOOD. MEMBERS, ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION ON THIS
MEASURE? DESPITE THAT THOROUGH
PRESENTATION, IT IS NOT ELIGIBLE
FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN AYE. ALVARADO. GILL. NO.
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY. AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ. AYE.
DALLEY. NO. DODD. AYE. DURAZO
AYE. EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER. AYE.
AYE. GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE NO.
HURTADO. AYE. JONES NO. LAIRD
AYE. LEHMAN. AYE. MCGUIRE.
MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN NEUMANN. AYE.
NGUYEN. NO. NILO. NO. OCHOA NO.
PADILLA. AYE. PORTANTINO AYE.
ROTH. AYE. RUBIO SEYARTO.
SKINNER AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS
AYE. STERN. AYE. UMBERG. AYE.
WAHAB AYE. WIENER AYE. WILK. AYE
ALL RIGHT. WE'RE GOING TO GO
THROUGH THE ROLL ONE LAST TIME.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. MCGUIRE. MIN.
AYE. RUBIO. AYE. SEYARTO. ON A
VOTE OF 31 TO 7, THE MEASURE
PASSES. OKAY, MEMBERS, WE ARE
GOING TO LET ME TELL YOU THE
SCHEDULE FOR. AND PRIOR TO
DINNER, WE'RE GOING TO GO
THROUGH BILLS ON CALL. SO WE'RE
GOING TO NEED ALL THE MEMBERS AT
THEIR DESKS. SO YOU WILL HAVE
YOUR LAST CHANCE TO PARTICIPATE
IN THOSE VOTES. WE'RE THEN GOING
TO GO BACK TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS. IF FOLKS WANT TO
RISE TO MAKE SOME REQUESTS. AND
THEN WE'RE GOING TO TAKE A
DINNER BREAK OF ABOUT 30 MINUTES
IN LENGTH, ASKING MEMBERS TO
STAY HERE IN THE BUILDING. AND
THAT IS THE SCHEDULE FOR THE
NEXT FEW MINUTES. SO WE'D ASK
YOU TO COME BACK TO YOUR DESK SO
YOU CAN BE ATTENTIVE TO A LOT OF
BILLS ON CALL, AND MAKE SURE
YOUR VOTE CAN BE COUNTED AND
WE'LL TAKE JUST A MOMENT TO GET
ORGANIZED HERE AT THE DESK.
OKAY, MEMBERS, I'M SURE YOU
FOUND THAT LITTLE BUTTON ON YOUR
COMPUTER THAT TELLS YOU WHICH OF
THE VOTES THAT YOU ARE NOT ON,
RIGHT? EVERYBODY'S FOUND THAT
BUTTON. SO WE'RE GOING TO ASK
FOR A LOT OF ATTENTION ON THIS
BECAUSE IT'S EASY TO MISS. WE
HAVE MORE THAN 50 BILLS ON CALL.
I'M GOING TO CALL THEM AND WE'LL
HOPEFULLY PEOPLE ARE PAYING
ATTENTION SO WE DON'T HAVE TO GO
BACK AND DO IT AGAIN. SO WE'RE
GOING TO BEGIN WITH GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTMENTS. THIS IS FILED ITEM
190. SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS ALLEN Ã ASHBY.
AYE. BECKER. AYE. CABALLERO.
AYE. DURAZZO. AYE. LAIRD. AYE.
NILO. AYE. OKUBO AYE. ROTH. AYE
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS AYE. STERN.
AYE. UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB AYE.
WILK. AYE. ON A VOTE OF 40 TO 0,
THE NOMINEE IS CONFIRMED. MOVING
NEXT TO FILE ITEM 193.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ALLEN. AYE.
ASHBY AYE. BLAKE. SPEER. AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE. DURAZO. AYE.
LAIRD AYE. MCGUIRE NILO. AYE.
OCHOA. BOGH. AYE. ROTH AYE.
STERN. AYE. UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB.
AYE. WILK. AYE WHAT IS MISSING?
ON A VOTE OF 39 TO 0. THE
NOMINEE IS CONFIRMED. MOVING
NEXT TO FILE ITEM 194.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ALLEN AYE. ASHBY
AYE. BLAKE. SPEER. AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE. DURAZO. AYE.
LAIRD AYE. MCGUIRE. NILO OCHOA.
AYE. PADILLA AYE. ROTH AYE.
STERN. AYE. UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB.
AYE. WILK. AYE. NILO. AYE ON A
VOTE OF 39 TO 0, THE NOMINEES
ARE CONFIRMED. WE'RE GOING TO
NEXT MOVE TO ASSEMBLY. THIRD
READING. BILLS ON CALL WILL
BEGIN WITH FILE ITEM 213.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ALLEN. AYE.
ASHBY AYE. BLAKE. SPEER AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE. DURAZO. AYE.
LAIRD AYE. MCGUIRE. NILO AYE.
ROTH AYE. STERN AYE. AMBER. AYE.
WAHAB AYE. WILK AYE. ON A VOTE
OF 39 TO 0, THE MEASURE PASSES.
NEXT UP, FILE ITEM TWO 214.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
OPPOSITE MEMBERS. ALLEN. AYE.
ASHBY. AYE. BLAKE. SPEER AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE. DURAZO. AYE.
JONES AYE. LAIRD. AYE. MCGUIRE.
NILO AYE. ROTH AYE. STERN. AYE.
UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB. AYE. WILK
AYE. ON A VOTE OF 39 TO 0, THE
MEASURE PASSES. NEXT UP, ITEM
216. SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
OPPOSITE MEMBERS. ALLEN AYE.
ASHBY AYE. BLAKE. SPEER. AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE. DURAZZO. AYE.
LAIRD. AYE. MCGUIRE. NILO AYE.
ROTH AYE. STERN. AYE. UMBERG.
AYE. WAHAB AYE. WILK AYE. ON A
VOTE OF 39 TO 0, THAT MEASURE
PASSES. NEXT UP, FILE ITEM 219.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ALLEN. AYE.
ASHBY AYE. BLAKE. SPEER. AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE. DURAZO. AYE.
LAIRD AYE. MCGUIRE. MIN A MIN.
AYE. NILO. AYE. ROTH AYE. STERN
AYE. AYE. UMBERG AYE. WAHAB AYE.
WILK. AYE. ON A VOTE OF 39 TO 0,
THE MEASURE PASSES. WE'RE GOING
TO MOVE TO FILE ITEM 233.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ALLEN. AYE.
ASHBY AYE. CABALLERO AYE. DURAZO
AYE. LAIRD AYE. NILO AYE. ROTH.
AYE. STERN. AYE. UMBERG. AYE.
WAHAB. AYE. WILK. AYE ON A VOTE
OF 40 TO 0, THE MEASURE PASSES.
WE'LL MOVE NEXT TO FILE ITEM
243. SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ALLEN AYE. ASHBY
AYE. CABALLERO. AYE. DURAZO.
AYE. LAIRD AYE. MCGUIRE. NIELSEN
I. ROTH. AYE. STERN. AYE.
UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB AYE. WILK.
AYE. ON A VOTE OF 39 TO 0, THE
MEASURE PASSES. NEXT UP, FILE
ITEM 244. SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. ALLEN. AYE.
ALVARADO GILL. NO. ASHBY. AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE. DURAZO. AYE.
LAIRD AYE. MCGUIRE. NILO OCHOA.
ROTH AYE. STERN. AYE. UMBERG
AYE. WILK. NÓ OCHOA. NO. ON A
VOTE OF 30 TO 8, THE MEASURE
PASSES. WE'LL MOVE NEXT TO FILE
ITEM 252. SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. ALLEN AYE.
DURAZO AYE. MCGUIRE. ROTH AYE.
UMBERG. AYE. WILK AYE. ON A VOTE
OF 39 TO 0, THE MEASURE PASSES.
I MOVE NEXT TO FILE ITEM 276.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. BECKER AYE.
MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR. AYE ON A VOTE
OF 39 TO 0, THE MEASURE PASSES.
NEXT UP, FILE ITEM 227.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
OPPOSITE MEMBERS. ALLEN AYE.
BECKER AYE. BRADFORD. AYE.
EGGMAN AYE. MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR
AYE. RUBIO. AYE. ON A VOTE OF 39
TO 0, THE MEASURE PASSES. NEXT
UP, FILE ITEM 230. SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALLEN. AYE. BECKER. AYE.
MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR. AYE. RUBIO.
AYE. ON A VOTE OF 39 TO 0, THE
MEASURE PASSES BY. ITEM 241.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ALLEN AYE.
BECKER AYE. HURTADO AYE.
MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR. AYE. RUBIO
AYE. ON A VOTE OF 39 TO 0, THE
MEASURE PASSES. WE'LL MOVE NEXT
TO FILE ITEM 277. SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALLEN. AYE. BECKER. AYE.
HURTADO. AYE. MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR
AYE. RUBIO AYE. IT'S A 39 TO 0
ON THE URGENCY. 39 TO 0 ON THE
MEASURE. THE MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING NEXT TO FILE ITEM 279.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ALLEN AYE. ASHBY
AYE. BECKER. AYE HURTADO. AYE.
MCGUIRE MENGIBAR. AYE. RUBIO
AYE. STERN. AYE ON A VOTE OF 39
TO 0, THE MEASURE PASSES. NEXT
UP, FILE ITEM 281. SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALLEN A BECKER. AYE. HURTADO.
AYE. LIMON. AYE. MCGUIRE.
MENGIBAR. AYE. RUBIO. AYE. IT'S
39 TO 0. ON THE URGENCY. 39 TO
0. THE MEASURE PASSES. NEXT UP,
FILE ITEM 283. SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. ALLEN
AYE. BECKER AYE. HURTADO AYE.
MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR. AYE. RUBIO
AYE. WILK KNOW, ON A VOTE OF 30
TO 9, THE MEASURE PASSES. WILL
MOVE TO FILE ITEM 290.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ALLEN AYE.
BECKER. AYE. GROVE HURTADO. AYE.
MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR. AYE. RUBIO
AYE. GROVE. AYE ON A VOTE OF 39
TO 0, THE MEASURE PASSES. WILL
MOVE TO FILE ITEM 293.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ALLEN AYE.
BECKER AYE. GROVE NO. HURTADO
AYE. LIMÓN MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR.
AYE. NGUYEN NILO. OCHOA. BOGH
RUBIO. AYE JUST A MOMENT.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS, PLEASE.
EVERYBODY, GET YOUR. PLEASE HAVE
YOUR ATTENTION NOW. CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ONE MORE TIME.
LIMÓN AYE. MCGUIRE NGUYEN. NILO
OCHOA. ALBERTO. GILARDINO. ON A
VOTE OF 31 TO 5, THE MEASURE
PASSES. MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM
294. SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ALLEN Ã ASHBY.
AYE. BECKER AYE. DALLEY DURAZZO.
AYE. HURTADO AYE. JONES MCGUIRE.
MENGIBAR. AYE. NGUYEN RUBIO.
AYE. SEYARTO WIENER. AYE ON A
VOTE OF 35 TO 0, THE MEASURE
PASSES. WE'RE GOING TO MOVE NEXT
TO FILE ITEM 297. SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
HOLD ON, HOLD ON. I REALLY NEED
EVERYONE'S ATTENTION HERE. AS WE
COMPLETE OUR MEASURES ON CALL.
OKAY. SO MEMBERS ARE HERE FROM
THE OTHER HOUSE. I'D LIKE TO
JUST ASK YOU TO WAIT JUST FIVE
MINUTES AND WE'LL BE DONE. AND
YOU CAN HAVE ALL THE
CONVERSATION THAT YOU WANT. SO
EVERYONE'S ATTENTION, PLEASE.
WE'RE AT FILE ITEM 297.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ALLEN. AYE.
BECKER. AYE. GROVE AYE. HURTADO.
AYE. MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR AYE.
PADILLA. AYE. RUBIO. AYE. WIENER
AYE. WILK. NÓ. Tê. AYE WILK.
NÓI. ON A VOTE OF 39 TO 0, THE
MEASURE PASSES. WE'LL MOVE NEXT
TO FILE ITEM 304. SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALLEN AYE. BECKER AYE. HURTADO
AYE. MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR. AYE.
OCHOA RUBIO. AYE. WIENER AYE.
WILK. AYE. WILK. AYE YOU'RE
OKAY? ON A VOTE OF 31 TO 7, THE
MEASURE CARRIES. MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM 307. SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. ALLEN
AYE. BECKER AYE. HURTADO AYE.
MCGUIRE MENGIBAR. AYE. RUBIO
AYE. WIENER. AYE. AND A VOTE OF
39 TO 0. THE MEASURE PASSES WILL
MOVE TO FILE ITEM 308.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ALLEN AYE.
BECKER AYE. DALY HURTADO. AYE.
MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR. AYE. WHEN
NILO. OCHOA. BOGH RUBIO. AYE.
WIENER AYE. NILO. AYE. ON A VOTE
OF 32 TO 4, THE MEASURE CARRIES
THE MEASURE PASSES. FILE ITEM
310. SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ALLEN. AYE.
ALVARADO. GILL BECKER. AYE.
HURTADO AYE. MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR.
AYE. RUBIO AYE. WIENER AYE. ON A
VOTE OF 31 TO 7, THE MEASURE
PASSES. FILE ITEM 317. SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALLEN AYE. BECKER AYE. DALY
DODD. AYE. GROVE. HURTADO AYE.
MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR. AYE. RUBIO
AYE. WIENER. AYE ON A VOTE OF 37
TO 0, THE MEASURE PASSES. MOVING
ON TO FILE ITEM 319. SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALLEN Ã ALVARADO GILL NÓ ASHBY.
AYE. BECKER AYE. DALLEY DODD.
AYE. GROVE. HURTADO. AYE.
MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR. AYE. OCHOA.
RUBIO AYE. WIENER AYE. WILK
KNOW, ON A VOTE OF 31 TO 5, THE
MEASURE PASSES. MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM 320. SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. ALLEN
AYE. ASHBY. AYE. BECKER. AYE.
BLAKE. SPEER. AYE. GROVE NO.
HURTADO AYE. MCGUIRE. OCHOA
STERN. AYE. WIENER. AYE. ON A
VOTE OF 31 TO 7, THE MEASURE
PASSES. MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM
321. SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ASHBY. AYE
BLAKE. SPEER. AYE. CABALLERO
AYE. DALLEY HURTADO. AYE.
MCGUIRE. NEWMAN AYE. WHEN OCHOA.
RUBIO AYE. SEYARTO STERN. AYE.
WIENER. AYE. ON A VOTE OF 35 TO
0, THE MEASURE PASSES. MOVING ON
TO FILE ITEM 322. SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ASHBY. AYE. BLAKE. SPEER AYE.
BRADFORD. CABALLERO AYE. HURTADO
AYE. MCGUIRE NEWMAN. AYE
PADILLA. AYE. RUBIO. AYE. STERN
AYE. WIENER AYE. BRADFORD. AYE
ON A VOTE OF 30 TO 9, THE
MEASURE PASSES. MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM 329. SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. ALLEN
AYE. BLAKE. SPEER AYE. HURTADO
AYE. MCGUIRE. NEWMAN. AYE. RUBIO
AYE. STERN Ã. AYE. WIENER AYE.
STERN I DON'T KNOW.
ON A VOTE OF 38 TO 1, THE
MEASURE PASSES. MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM 342. SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. BLAKE
SPEER. AYE. HURTADO AYE.
MCGUIRE. NEWMAN. AYE. SEYARTO.
STERN AYE. I VOTE OF 36 TO 2.
THE MEASURE PASSES. MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM 346. SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALVARADO, GIL. AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER. M. DALLY. DODD
GROVE MCGUIRE. NEWMAN. AYE.
NGUYEN. NILO OCHOA. PADILLA.
AYE. SEYARTO. STERN AYE. WIENER
AYE. WILK.
SECRETARY. CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS ONE LAST TIME. LET'S DO
IT. GO AHEAD. CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. ONE. ONE MORE TIME,
PLEASE. DADDY GROVE. MCGUIRE.
NGUYEN. NILO OCHOA. SEYARTO
WILK. I VOTE OF 31 TO 1. THE
MEASURE PASSES. NEXT UP. FIVE.
ITEM 349. SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. ASHBY. NÓ
BLAKE. SPEER. AYE. GLAZER.
HURTADO MCGUIRE. MIN. NEWMAN
ROTH. RUBIO STERN. AYE UMBERG.
WIENER AYE. ARCHULETA. I DON'T
KNOW. SECRETARY. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. GLAZER HURTADO.
NO. MCGUIRE MIN. NEWMAN ROTH.
ROTH. NO. RUBIO UMBERG. SENATOR.
SKINNER MOVES THE CALL. NEXT UP.
FIVE. ITEM 350. SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ASHBY BECKER. AYE. BLAKE. SPEER
BRAD. CABALLERO GLAZER. MCGUIRE
MIN. NEWMAN. AYE. OCHOA RUBIO.
AYE. STERN AYE. WIENER AYE.
ASHBY. AYE BLAKE. SPEER. AYE ON
A VOTE OF 28 TO 7, THE MEASURE
PASSES. WE'LL MOVE NEXT TO FILE
ITEM 351. SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. ASHBY AYE.
BLAKE. SPEER DALLY. NØ. DODD
DURAZO I. JONES NO. MCGUIRE.
NEWMAN. I NGUYEN. STERN I DODD.
I LIKE SPEER. I ON A VOTE.
ALVARADO. GILL. I DON'T KNOW.
EVERYBODY GOOD ON A VOTE OF 34
TO 4. THE MEASURE PASSES. MOVING
ON TO FILE ITEM 357. SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ASHBY BLAKE. SPEER MCGUIRE.
NEWMAN I NGUYEN. OCHOA. BOGH
CIERTO. STERN I. ASHBY AYE.
BLAKE. SPEER. I DALLY. NÓ. Tê. I
GROVE. NÓ. Tð. I I GUESS FOLKS
DON'T WANT DINNER, ALL RIGHT. ON
A VOTE OF 36 TO 0, THE MEASURE
PASSES. NEXT UP IS FILE ITEM
352. SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. BLAKE SPEER,
DALLY GONZALEZ, MCGUIRE. NEWMAN
I NGUYEN. NILO OCHOA. SKINNER I
STERN I WEINER. I BLAKE. SPEER I
GONZALEZ I. ALL RIGHT. ON A VOTE
OF 34 TO 1, THE MEASURE PASSES.
NEXT UP IS FILE ITEM 363.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ASHBY I. BLAKE.
SPEER I DODD MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR
NEWMAN. MENGIBAR I NEWMAN. I
STERN, I. ON A VOTE OF 29 TO 9,
THE MEASURE PASSES. NEXT UP,
FILE ITEM 370. SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. ASHBY I
BLAKE. SPEER. CABALLERO DAILY.
GROVE JONES. MCGUIRE MENGIBAR I.
NEWMAN I WEN NILO OCHOA. SEYARTO
SKINNER I STERN I WILK.
CABALLERO I BLAKE. SPEER. I ON A
VOTE OF 31 TO 0, THE MEASURE
PASSES. NEXT UP, FILE ITEM 413.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. BECKER I. DADDY
I JONES I MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR I
NEWMAN I SKINNER I. ON A VOTE OF
39 TO 0, THE MEASURE PASSES.
NEXT STEP, FILE ITEM 419.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ALVARADO, GILL.
NØ DADDY. EGGMAN I JONES. NØ
MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR I MIN NEWMAN I
MEAN I NGUYEN NILO OCHOA. CIERTO
SKINNER I WILK DADDY NO. GROVE I
DON'T KNOW. ON A VOTE OF 30 TO
4, THE MEASURE PASSES. MOVING ON
TO FILE ITEM 367. SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ASHBY I BECKER I DADDY NÓ
NEWMAN. I MEAN, I WHEN OCHOA
SKINNER I STERN I ON A VOTE OF
31 TO 6 THE MEASURE PASSES. NEXT
UP IS FILE ITEM 422. SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ASHBY I MCGUIRE, NGUYEN SKINNER
I STERN I. ON A VOTE OF. JANET'S
OKAY. JANET'S OKAY. ON A VOTE OF
38 TO 0, THE MEASURE PASSES.
NEXT UP IS FILE ITEM 421.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ASHBY I MCGUIRE.
SKINNER. I STERN I ON A VOTE OF
39 TO 0. THE MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS. WE'RE GOING TO GO TO
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS. WITHOUT
OBJECTION. PURSUANT TO JOINT
RULE 33.1, JOINT RULE 61 WILL BE
SUSPENDED TO ALLOW ASSEMBLY BILL
2115 AND 3035 TO BE AMENDED
AFTER THE DEADLINE. THE REQUEST
HAS BEEN APPROVED BY THE RULES
COMMITTEE. TAMBIÉN. SALAS.
WITHOUT OBJECTION, PURSUANT TO
JOINT RULE 30 3.1, JOINT RULE 61
AND 62 WILL BE SUSPENDED TO
ALLOW THE SENATE POLICY AND
FISCAL COMMITTEES TO MEET AND
HEAR ASSEMBLY BILL TWO, TWO,
FOUR AND ASSEMBLY BILL 535 AFTER
THE DEADLINE AND WITHOUT
SUFFICIENT NOTICE IN THE DAILY
FILE. THE REQUEST HAS BEEN
APPROVED BY THE RULES COMMITTEE.
SENATOR GONZALEZ, FOR WHAT
PURPOSE DO YOU RISE? THANK YOU,
MR. PRESIDENT. MEMBERS, THERE IS
A RESOLUTION AT THE DESK
REQUESTING PERMISSION TO SUSPEND
JOINT RULE 61 AND 62 FOR THE
PURPOSE OF ALLOWING SENATE
POLICY AND FISCAL COMMITTEE TO
MEET AND HEAR ASSEMBLY BILLS 518
AND 1034. THESE REQUESTS HAVE
BEEN APPROVED BY THE RULES
COMMITTEE. I WILL. SENATOR
SECRETO, FOR WHAT PURPOSE DO YOU
RISE? WE WISH NOT TO WAIVE THE
RULES AND WOULD REQUEST A NO
VOTE. VERY GOOD. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ THE RESOLUTION.
RESOLVE THAT JOINT RULE 61 AND
62 BE DISPENSED WITH. ALL RIGHT.
MEMBERS, SENATOR GONZALEZ IS
ASKING FOR AN AYE VOTE. SENATOR
CIERTO IS ASKING FOR A NO VOTE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN Ã ALVARADO. GILL. NO.
ARCHULETA AYE. ASHBY. AYE
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE CORTEZ. AYE DALLI.
NO DODD. AYE. DURAZZO AYE.
EGGMAN. AYE GLAZER. AYE. I.
GONZALEZ. AYE GROVE. NO. HURTADO
AYE. JONES. NO. LAIRD AYE.
LEHMAN. AYE. MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR
AYE. MIN. AYE. NEWMAN AYE.
NGUYEN NO. NILO. NO OCHOA. NO.
PADILLA AYE. PORTANTINO. AYE
ROTH. AYE. RUBIO ACIERTO. NO.
SKINNER AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS
AYE. STERN AYE. UMBERG AYE.
WAHAB AYE. WIENER AYE. WILK.
ON A VOTE OF 30 TO 8, THE JOINT
RULES ARE SUSPENDED. OKAY. ANY
OTHER MICROPHONES UP FOR MOTIONS
AND RESOLUTIONS? MEMBERS SENATOR
JONES, WHAT PURPOSE DO YOU RISE?
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. UNDER
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS, AT THE
REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR, I WOULD
LIKE TO REMOVE AN ITEM FROM THE
CALENDAR FROM THE SPECIAL
CONSENT CALENDAR. ITEM 506.
ASSEMBLY BILL 1254 BY
ASSEMBLYMAN FLORA AND PLACED ON
THE INACTIVE FILE. THANK YOU
SENATOR. THE DESK WILL NOTE
ANYTHING ELSE MEMBERS, BEFORE
WE'RE GOING TO BREAK. ALL RIGHT,
LISTEN UP. WE'VE HAD A GREAT,
GREAT PROGRESS THIS AFTERNOON.
THANK YOU ALL FOR YOUR
COOPERATION. WE HAVE DEALT WITH
55 BILLS SO FAR TODAY. AS YOU
NOTED AT THE TOP, WE'RE TRYING
TO GET TO 100 BEFORE THE EVENING
IS DONE. WE ARE GOING TO BREAK
FOR DINNER FOR JUST 30 MINUTES.
WE'RE ASKING MEMBERS TO PLEASE
STAY IN THE BUILDING AND THAT WE
ARE CAN MAKE GOOD PROGRESS AFTER
DINNER AND WE CAN HAVE AN
EARLIER EVENING THAN WE MIGHT
HAVE EXPECTED. SO THANK YOU ALL
FOR YOUR COOPERATION. WE'LL SEE
YOU IN 30 MINUTES. THAT'S IT.
WHO HAS THE 554? 554? WE'LL BE
BACK HERE IN THE CHAMBERS.
MEMBERS. WELCOME BACK. WE'RE
GOING TO CALL THE SENATE BACK
FROM RECESS. WE'RE GOING TO
CONTINUE WITH ASSEMBLY THIRD
READING. AND WE'RE GOING TO
BEGIN WITH FILE ITEM 430. THIS
IS ASSEMBLY BILL 2377.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ. I DON'T
HAVE AN ASSEMBLY BILL 2377 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LEWIS RIVAS AND
ACT RELATING TO PUPIL
INSTRUCTION. SENATOR NEWMAN,
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. I RISE
ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
THREE OF US TO PRESENT AB 2377
WHICH WILL PROVIDE FOR
ACCOMMODATIONS FOR K THROUGH 12
STUDENTS WHO ARE PRACTICING
RELIGIOUS FASTING BY EITHER
OFFERING A MODIFIED EXERCISE
OPTION OR BY SUBSTITUTING
ACADEMIC ASSIGNMENTS RELATED TO
PHYSICAL EDUCATION. MANY
RELIGIONS FAST AS PART OF THEIR
WORSHIP PRACTICES IN HOT
WEATHER. THE IMPLICATIONS FOR
STUDENTS OF FASTING DURING LONG,
HOT CALIFORNIA DAYS CAN BE
CHALLENGING, AND SOMETIMES
DANGEROUS. AB 2377 OFFERS
OPTIONS TO KEEP STUDENTS SAFE
WHILE RESPECTING THEIR RELIGIOUS
PRACTICES. THIS BILL HAS
RECEIVED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND
HAS RECEIVED NO NO VOTES SO FAR.
I RESPECTFULLY ASKING FOR YOUR
VOTE THIS EVENING. MEMBERS. IS
THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THIS MEASURE? ANY DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE? SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN ALVARADO GUYER. ARCHULETA.
ASHBY ATKINS. AYE. BECKER BLAKE.
SPEER. BRADFORD AYE. CABALLERO
CORTEZ. AYE. DALLI AYE. DODD.
AYE. DURAZZO EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER
AYE. GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE NO.
HI. GROVE. AYE HURTADO. AYE.
JONES AYE. LAIRD AYE. LEHMAN
MAGUIRE. MENGIBAR. MIN NEWMAN.
AYE NGUYEN. AYE MILO. AYE. OCHOA
AYE. PADILLA AYE. PORTANTINO
RATH. AYE RUBIO. AYE. CIERTO
AYE. SKINNER SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS
STERN. AYE UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB
AYE. WIENER. AYE WILK. AYE
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALLEN. AYE ALVARADO. GILL. AYE.
ARCHULETA AYE. ASHBY. AYE
BECKER. AYE. BLAKE. SPEER AYE.
CABALLERO DURAZZO. AYE LIMON.
AYE MAGUIRE. MENGIBAR MIN. AYE
PORTANTINO. SKINNER SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS.
SENATOR. NEWMAN SENATOR NEWMAN
MOVES A CALL. ALL RIGHT.
MEMBERS, NEXT UP IS FILE ITEM
431. ASSEMBLY BILL, 2016.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
BILL 2016 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MANCINI. AN ACT RELATING TO
ESTATES. SENATOR. LAIRD MEMBERS,
PLEASE GIVE SENATOR LAIRD YOUR
ATTENTION. THANK YOU VERY MUCH,
MR. CHAIR. BEN. BEN, THANK YOU
FOR EVERYBODY'S ATTENTION.
SENATOR LAIRD, OUR APOLOGIES,
AND NOW WE HAVE, I THINK, OUR
ATTENTION DIRECTED TOWARDS YOU.
AND YOU MAY PROCEED. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH, MR. PRESIDENT. THIS
BILL, ADDRESSES THE RAPID
ESCALATION OF HOME VALUES. IT
HAS RESULTED IN ESTATES THAT
INCLUDE MODEST FAMILY HOMES, NO
LONGER QUALIFYING FOR AN
EXPEDITED PROBATE PROCESS. AB
2016 UPDATES THE ESTATE VALUE
LIMIT FOR THE ESTATE. SIMPLIFIED
SMALL ESTATE PROBATE PROCESS TO
ADDRESS THIS CHALLENGE, IT WOULD
PREVENT HEIRS FROM BEING CAUGHT
UP IN CALIFORNIA'S LENGTHY
PROBATE COURT PROCESS,
ESPECIALLY WHEN TRYING TO
ESTABLISH TITLE TO THE FAMILY
HOME AFTER THE PASSING OF A
LOVED ONE. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. MEMBERS. ANY
DISCUSSION ON THIS MEASURE, ANY
DISCUSSION ON THIS MEASURE? ALL
RIGHT. SEEING NONE. SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN.
AYE. ALVARADO. GILL AYE.
ARCHULETA AYE. ASHBY. AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER. AYE. BLAKE
SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD. AYE
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ. AYE
DALY. AYE. DODD. AYE DURAZZO.
AYE. EGGMAN. AYE GLAZER. AYE.
AYE. GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE AYE.
HURTADO. AYE. JONES. AYE. LAIRD.
AYE. LEHMAN. AYE. MCGUIRE
MENGIBAR. MIN AYE. MENGIBAR. AYE
NEWMAN. I NGUYEN. AYE. NILO
OCHOA. BOGH PADILLA. AYE
PORTANTINO. AYE. ROTH. AYE
RUBIO. AYE SEYARTO. AYE.
SKINNER. AYE SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS.
AYE. STERN AYE. UMBERG. AYE
WAHAB. WE HAVE A AYE. WIENER
AYE. WILK. AYE JUST A MOMENT. WE
HAVE A FULL HOUSE NOW, MEMBERS.
SO WE'RE GOING TO GO THROUGH THE
ROLL ONE LAST TIME AND THEN
WE'RE GOING TO CLOSE IT. SO
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. MCGUIRE. NILO
OCHOA. BORG. AYE. ON A VOTE OF
38 TO 0, THE MEASURE PASSES.
NEXT UP IS FILE ITEM 432 AB
2802. SECRETARY, PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL 2802 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MANCINI. AN ACT RELATING
TO FOSTER YOUTH. SENATOR ATKINS,
THE FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK YOU,
MR. PRESIDENT. COLLEAGUES, I
RISE TO PRESENT AB 2802 ON
BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MAIENSCHEIN. THIS BILL SEEKS TO
CREATE A MORE GENDER INCLUSIVE
OPTIONS FOR HOUSING ARRANGEMENTS
WITHIN THE TRANSITIONAL HOUSING
PLACEMENT PROGRAMS, OR CHP. THE
CHP PROGRAM SERVES AS A LIFELINE
FOR CURRENT AND FORMER FOSTER
YOUTH OVER 18 SUFFERING FROM
HOMELESSNESS. HOWEVER, PROVIDERS
OFTEN ENCOUNTER CHALLENGES IN
PLACING YOUTH STEMMING FROM
RIGID, BINARY, GENDER BASED
RULES FOR HOUSING ARRANGEMENTS.
CURRENTLY, THE DESIGNATION OF
HOUSING VACANCIES AS MALE AND
FEMALE CREATES BARRIERS FOR
INDIVIDUALS, SIBLINGS, AND
CO-PARENTING YOUTH WHO WISH TO
LIVE TOGETHER BUT DO NOT SHARE
THE SAME GENDER IDENTITY. AB TWO
802 WOULD ALLOW FOSTER YOUTH IN
TRANSITIONAL HOUSING TO SHARE
ROOMS WITH ROOMMATES, SIBLINGS
OR CO-PARENTS WHO DO NOT SHARE
THE SAME GENDER IDENTITY WITH
THE APPROVAL OF THE PROVIDER,
AND ON A CASE BY CASE BASIS. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE
MEMBERS. ANY DISCUSSION ON THIS
MEASURE, ANY FURTHER DEBATE.
SEEING NONE. SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. HARLOW I
ALVARADO. GILL. AYE ARCHULETA I
ASHBY I ATKINS I BECKER. AYE.
BLAKE SPEER I BRADFORD. AYE
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ I DALY.
DODD AYE. DURAZZO JACKMAN. AYE.
GLAZER I. AYE. GONZALEZ. AYE.
GROVE HURTADO. AYE JONES. LAIRD.
AYE LEHMAN. AYE. MAGUIRE
MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN AYE. NEWMAN.
AYE. NGUYEN NILO. OCHOA PADILLA.
AYE PORTANTINO. AYE. ROTH AYE.
RUBIO. AYE CIERTO. SKINNER. AYE
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. STERN AYE.
UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB AYE. WIENER
AYE. WILK PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. DALLI. DURAZZO AYE.
GROVE JONES. MCGUIRE NGUYEN. NO
NILO. OCHOA. BOG SEGATO.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS WILK.
SMALLWOOD CUEVAS. AYE. ON A VOTE
OF 31 TO 1, THE MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS. HERE'S THE ORDER THAT
WE'RE GOING TO FOLLOW FOR THE
NEXT FIVE BILLS. WE'RE GOING TO
GO FILE ITEM 434 436, 438, 439
AND 440. SO FLOOR MANAGERS,
PLEASE BE PREPARED. NEXT UP IS
FILE ITEM 434. THIS IS ASSEMBLY
BILL 1316. SECRETARY, PLEASE
READ ASSEMBLY BILL 1316 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER IRWIN AND ACT
RELATING TO HEALTH CARE. SENATOR
EGGMAN. SENATOR EGGMAN, THE
FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. I AM PRESENTING AB 1316
TODAY BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER IRWIN.
THAT HELPS FACILITATE PEOPLE OUT
OF THE EMERGENCY ROOM WHEN
THEY'RE IN A MENTAL HEALTH
CRISIS INTO A FACILITY. THE LAST
AMENDMENTS TOOK AWAY ALL
OPPOSITION. I ASKED FOR YOUR I
VOTE.
ANY ANY DISCUSSION ON THIS
MEASURE? MEMBERS. IT IS ELIGIBLE
FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. WITHOUT
OBJECTION. AYES 39. NO ZERO. THE
MEASURE PASSES. NEXT UP IS FILE
ITEM 436. ASSEMBLY BILL 2276.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL 2276 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
WOOD. AN ACT RELATING TO
FORESTRY. SENATOR DODD, THANK
YOU VERY MUCH, MR. PRESIDENT.
MEMBERS, I RISE TO PRESENT 2276
ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WOOD. AS WE KNOW, WILDFIRES HAVE
HAD A CATASTROPHIC EVENT EFFECT
ON OUR STATE'S RESIDENTS AND
LANDSCAPE. IMPORTANT TIMBER
HARVEST PLANS, EXEMPTIONS THAT
FURTHER THE STATE'S POLICY GOAL
OF REDUCING WILDFIRE RISK ARE
SET TO EXPIRE. RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR VOTE ON AB 2276. ANY
DISCUSSION ON THIS MEASURE
MEMBERS IS ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. WITHOUT
OBJECTION. AYES 39. NO ZERO. THE
MEASURE PASSES. NEXT UP IS FIVE.
ITEM 438. ASSEMBLY BILL 2482.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL 2432 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GABRIEL. AN ACT RELATING TO
CRIME AND MAKE AN APPROPRIATION.
THEREFORE, SENATOR RUBIO, THE
FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
OF THE SENATE, TODAY I AM
PLEASED TO PRESENT AB 2432, THE
CALIFORNIA VICTIMS OF CRIMES
ACT, CREATING A PERMANENT SOURCE
OF FUNDING FOR PROGRAMS SERVING
VICTIMS OF VIOLENT CRIMES
MODELED ON THE BIPARTISAN
FEDERAL VICTIMS OF CRIME ACT.
THIS BILL MAKES IT EASIER FOR
PROSECUTORS TO HOLD BAD ACTORS
ACCOUNTABLE AND PROTECT OUR
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES BY
CREATING A STATE EQUIVALENT TO
VOCA. AB 2432 WILL HELP TO
PROVIDE ESSENTIAL FUNDING FOR
PROGRAMS THAT PROVIDE PIVOTAL
AND, IN SOME CASES, LIFE SAVING
SERVICES TO CRIME VICTIMS. IN
CALIFORNIA, INCLUDING HUMAN
TRAFFICKING, DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
AND CHILD ABUSE VICTIMS. AB 2432
IS SUPPORTED BY A BROAD
COALITION OF LAW ENFORCEMENT
VICTIMS SERVICE ORGANIZATIONS
AND CRIMINAL JUSTICE GROUPS.
THIS BILL ALSO ENJOYS OVER 20
BIPARTISAN COAUTHORS, HAS NO
OPPOSITION, AND HAS RECEIVED NO
NO VOTES. WITH THAT, I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
THANK YOU, SENATOR RUBIO. ANY
DISCUSSION ON THIS MEASURE, ANY
DISCUSSION ON THIS MEASURE,
SEEING NONE. THIS IS A 27 VOTE
BILL. SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN ALVARADO. GILL. AYE.
ARCHULETA I ASHBY. AYE. ATKINS I
BECKER. AYE. BLAKE SPEER I
BRADFORD. AYE. CABALLERO AYE.
CORTEZ. AYE. DALLI DODD. AYE.
DURAZZO AYE. EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER
AYE. GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE
HURTADO. AYE. JONES AYE. LAIRD.
AYE. LEMON AYE. MAGUIRE.
MENGIBAR AYE. MIN. AYE. NEWMAN
AYE. NGUYEN. AYE. NILO AYE.
OCHOA. BOGUE. AYE PADILLA AYE.
PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH. AYE RUBIO.
AYE. SEYARTO AYE. SKINNER AYE.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS AYE. STERN.
AYE UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB AYE.
WIENER AYE. WILK. AYE PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. DALLI
AYE. GROVE AYE. MCGUIRE A VOTE
OF 39 TO 0. THE MEASURE PASSES.
NEXT UP IS FILE ITEM 439.
ASSEMBLY BILL 2860. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY BILL 2860
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER GARCIA. AN
ACT RELATING TO HEALING ARTS.
SENATOR HURTADO, THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. I'M PROUD TO PRESENT
AB 2860 DOCTORS AND DENTISTS
FROM MEXICO PROGRAM AB 2860
REMOVES THE PILOT STATUS OF THIS
PROJECT FOR DOCTORS. ALLOWS THE
MEDICAL BOARD, BEGINNING IN
2025, TO INCREASE THE NUMBER OF
DOCTORS SERVING IN THIS PROGRAM,
AND INCLUDES 30 PSYCHIATRISTS.
THIS PROGRAM HAS PROVEN ITS
MEDICAL QUALITY AND CREATED
ACCESS FOR COMMUNITIES LACKING
MEDICAL CARE DUE TO LANGUAGE AND
CULTURAL BARRIERS. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
ON THIS MEASURE. MEMBERS ANY
DISCUSSION ON THIS MEASURE? ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION? SEEING NONE,
IT IS ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL. WITHOUT OBJECTION.
AYES 30 900. THE MEASURE PASSES.
NEXT UP IS FILED. ITEM 440. THIS
IS ASSEMBLY BILL 3162.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL 3162 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BENNETT. AN ACT RELATING TO FISH
AND WILDLIFE. SENATOR MARTIN.
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
PERMISSION TO USE A PROP? I
PERMISSION DENIED THIS. THIS IS
AN OCTOPUS. HE'S ANGRY BECAUSE
HE'S VERY INTELLIGENT AND
UNFORTUNATELY, IS SUBJECTED TO
UNNECESSARY CRUELTY AS OCTOPUSES
GAINED POPULARITY. HOLD ON A
SECOND. YOU NEED TO PUT THE PROP
DOWN ON YOUR DESK. THANK YOU.
OKAY, NOW YOU CAN PROCEED. I
CAN'T USE THE PROP. OKAY OKAY.
MY APOLOGIES. AS OCTOPUS HAS
GAINED POPULARITY ACROSS THE
GLOBE, THE SEAFOOD INDUSTRY HAS
EXPRESSED INTEREST IN OCTOPUS
AQUACULTURE OR OCTOPUS FARMING.
HOWEVER, RESEARCH TELLS US THAT
OCTOPUSES ARE NOT SUITABLE FOR
FARMING. HERE I JUST WANT TO
NOTE THAT OCTOPUS IS A WORD WITH
GREEK ORIGIN, SO WE OFTEN REFER
TO THE PLURAL AS OCTOPI
INCORRECTLY. IN THE GREEK IT
WOULD BE OCTOPODES. BUT IN THE
UNITED STATES, IN ENGLISH,
OCTOPUSES IS THE PREFERRED OR
APPROPRIATE PLURAL, SO AB 3162
OPPOSED CRUELTY TO OCTOPUSES OR
THE OCTOPUS. OCTO ACT
PREEMPTIVELY BANS OCTOPUS
FARMING AND THE SALE OF FARMED
OCTOPUS ACROSS THE STATE. RECENT
AMENDMENTS REFLECT TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE FROM DEPARTMENT OF
FISH AND WILDLIFE. NO OPPOSITION
TO THIS VOTE. TO THIS BILL, I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE. OKAY, SENATOR. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR SPIRITED PRESENTATION.
MEMBERS IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THIS MEASURE, ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE? ALL RIGHT.
SEEING NONE. SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN ALVARADO
GILL. AYE. ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE BRADFORD. CABALLERO
AYE. CORTEZ. AYE. TALLEY AYE.
DODD DURAZZO. AYE. EGGMAN AYE.
GLAZER GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE AYE.
HURTADO. AYE. JONES AYE. LAIRD.
AYE LEHMAN. AYE. MAGUIRE
MENGIBAR. MIN AYE. NEWMAN NGUYEN.
NILO HÌ. PADILLA AYE. PORTANTINO
AYE. ROTH. AYE RUBIO. AYE.
SEYARTO AYE. SKINNER AYE.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS AYE. STERN
AYE. UMBERG. AYE WAHAB. AYE.
WIENER AYE. WILK AYE. OKAY. YOU
CAN CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALLEN. AYE ASHBY. AYE. BRADFORD
AYE. DODD AYE. AYE GLAZER. AYE
AYE. MAGUIRE MENGIBAR. AYE
NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN NILO. OCHOA.
BOGH. ALL RIGHT. ON A VOTE OF 36
TO 0, THE MEASURE PASSES.
CONGRATULATIONS, SENATOR MIN,
IT'S A GOOD INSTRUCTION FOR
OTHER FOLKS ON THE FLOOR. IF YOU
WANT TO USE A PROP, PLEASE CLEAR
IT WITH THE PRESIDING OFFICER.
ALL RIGHT. WE'RE GOING TO WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE ON TO THE NEXT
FIVE ITEMS OR FILE ITEM
443445446447 AND 451.
ALL RIGHT. NEXT UP IS FILE ITEM
443. THIS IS ASSEMBLY BILL 2013.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
BILL 2013 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
IRWIN AND ACT RELATING TO
ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE. SENATOR
PADILLA, THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. I'M PLEASED TO
PRESENT AB 2013 WHICH REQUIRES
DEVELOPERS OF GENERATIVE
ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE SYSTEMS
AND SERVICES TO DISCLOSE HIGH
LEVEL SUMMARY INFORMATION ABOUT
THEIR TRAINING DATA. GENERATIVE
AI HAS BECOME NEARLY UNAVOIDABLE
IN CALIFORNIA'S DAILY LIVES, BUT
CONSUMER CONFIDENCE IN
GENERATIVE AI HAS NOT GROWN AT
THE SAME RATE OR PACE THAT THE
INDUSTRY HAS ADOPTED, AND
DEVELOPED IT. MANY CONSUMERS
HAVE VALID QUESTIONS ABOUT HOW
THESE GENERATIVE AI SYSTEMS AND
SERVICES ARE CREATED, AND IF
THEY ARE SAFE AND ETHICAL TO
USE. TO BUILD CONSUMER
CONFIDENCE, WE NEED TO START
WITH THE BUILDING BLOCKS OF
GENERATIVE AI MODELS, AND THAT
IS THE SELECTION OF TRAINING
DATA. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE MEMBERS DISCUSSION ON
THIS MEASURE. ANY DISCUSSION ON
THE MEASURE? SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN. AYE. ALVARADO GILL. AYE.
ARCHULETA. AYE ASHBY. AYE.
ATKINS. AYE BECKER. BLAKE. SPEAR
AYE. BRADFORD. AYE. CABALLERO
AYE. CORTEZ. AYE. DALI. AYE
DODD. AYE. DURAZZO. AYE EGGMAN.
GLAZER. AYE. AYE GONZALEZ. AYE.
GROVE AYE. HURTADO AYE. JONES.
AYE. LAIRD AYE. LEHMAN. AYE.
MAGUIRE MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN
NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN AYE. NILO.
AYE. OCHOA BORG. AYE. PADILLA.
AYE PORTANTINO. AYE. ROTH AYE.
RUBIO. AYE. SEYARTO AYE. SKINNER
AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE
STERN. AYE. UMBERG. AYE WAHAB.
AYE. WIENER AYE. WILK AYE.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
BECKER AYE. EGGMAN AYE. MAGUIRE
MIN. ON A VOTE OF 38 TO 0, THE
MEASURE PASSES. MOVING NEXT TO
FILE ITEM 445, ASSEMBLY BILL
2859. SECRETARY, PLEASE READ
ASSEMBLY BILL 2859 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER JIM PATTERSON. AN ACT
RELATING TO EMERGENCY MEDICAL
SERVICES. SENATOR ALVARADO GILL.
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. I RISE
AS A PROUD COAUTHOR OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER JIM PATTERSON'S ASSEMBLY
BILL. AND YES, HE DID SELECT ME
TO PRESENT AND FLOOR JOCKEY HIS
BILL. THIS WOULD ENACT A PEER TO
PEER SUPPORT GROUP FOR EMERGENCY
MEDICAL TECHNICIANS AND
AMBULANCE EMPLOYEES. IT AIMS TO
ENHANCE THE OVERALL WELL-BEING
AND RESILIENCE OF THE EMTS AND
OUR AMBULANCE STAFFERS. BY
FOSTERING A NEW SUPPORTIVE
NETWORK WITHIN THEIR OWN
PROFESSIONAL COMMUNITY. THE MOST
RECENT AMENDMENTS ARE CLARIFYING
IN NATURE, AND THIS BILL HAS
RECEIVED NO NO VOTES. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I
VOTE. MEMBERS ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS MEASURE, ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. ALL RIGHT.
WE'VE LOST OUR FULL HOUSE HERE.
SO WE'RE GOING TO GO THROUGH THE
ROLL ONCE AND PUT BILLS ON CALL.
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN ALVARADO GIL ARCHULETA.
AYE. ASHBY AYE. ATKINS. AYE.
BECKER AYE. BLAKE. SPEER. AYE.
BRADFORD AYE. CABALLERO. AYE.
CORTEZ AYE. DALI. AYE. DODD AYE.
DURAZO. EGGMAN AYE. GLAZER. AYE.
AYE. GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE. AYE.
HURTADO AYE. JONES. AYE. LAIRD
AYE. LEHMAN. AYE. MAGUIRE
MENGIBAR. I'M IN. AYE. NEWMAN
AYE. NGUYEN. AYE NILO. AYE.
OCHOA. BOG. AYE PADILLA. AYE.
PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH. AYE. RUBIO
AYE. SEYARTO AYE. SKINNER AYE.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE STERNE.
AYE. UMBERG AYE. WAHAB. AYE.
WIENER AYE. WILK. AYE SENATOR
ALVARADO GILL MOVES A CALL
MEMBERS WE PASSED EARLIER ON
FILE ITEM 296. WE'RE GOING TO
COME BACK TO IT NOW. THIS IS
FILED ITEM 296. IT'S ASSEMBLY
BILL 2061. SECRETARY, PLEASE
READ ASSEMBLY BILL 2061 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WILSON, AN ACT
TO TAXATION TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY. TAX LEVY. SENATOR
BECKER, THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. THIS BILL WILL
ESTABLISH A NEW EXEMPTION FOR
THE STATE PORTION OF SALES AND
USE TAX FOR THE PURCHASE OF ZERO
EMISSION FERRIES BY PUBLIC
TRANSIT AGENCIES SUCH AS LONG
BEACH TRANSIT, WTA, AND THE
GOLDEN GATE FERRY THROUGH 2030.
THANK YOU. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU,
SENATOR BECKER. ANY DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THE MEASURE? ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE? SEEING
NONE. SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN AYE. GILL. AYE.
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY. AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER. AYE. BLAKE
SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ. AYE.
DALY AYE. DODD. AYE. DURAZZO
EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER. AYE.
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE. AYE.
HURTADO. AYE. JONES LAIRD. AYE.
LEHMAN AYE. MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR
AYE. MIN. AYE NEWMAN. AYE.
NGUYEN. AYE MILO. AYE. OCHOA
AYE. PADILLA. AYE. PORTANTINO.
AYE. ROTH AYE. RUBIO AYE.
SEYARTO. AYE. SKINNER. AYE.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE. STERN.
AYE. UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB AYE.
WIENER. AYE WILK. AYE SEN.
BECKER. BECKER. MOVES A CALL.
ALL RIGHT. NEXT UP, WE'RE GOING
TO GO BACK TO 446, FOLLOWED BY
447, 451 AND 454. 446 IS AB
1841. SECRETARY, PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL 1841 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WEBER. AN ACT RELATING TO
PUBLIC POST-SECONDARY EDUCATION.
SENATOR HURTADO. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. I RISE TODAY ON
BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER DOCTOR
WEBER TO PRESENT AB 1841, WHICH
WOULD REQUIRE THE CSU AND
COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND REQUEST
THE èC TO REQUIRE THAT
RESIDENTIAL ADVISORS BE TRAINED
AND HAVE EASY ACCESS TO
NALOXONE. WE'RE ALL AWARE OF THE
RISING OPIOID RELATED DEATHS IN
CALIFORNIA AND THE BENEFICIAL
ROLE NALOXONE CAN PLAY IN
REDUCING THAT HARM. THIS BILL
HAS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT, AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
MEMBERS, ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS MEASURE? SEEING
NO MICROPHONE'S UP. SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN.
AYE. ALVARADO. GILL. AYE.
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER. AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO. CORTEZ. AYE. DALY.
AYE. DODD. AYE. DURAZO. EGGMAN
GLAZER. AYE. AYE. GONZALEZ AYE.
GROVE. AYE. HURTADO. AYE. JONES.
AYE. LAIRD. AYE. LEHMAN. AYE.
MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR AYE. MIN. AYE.
NEWMAN AYE. NGUYEN. AYE. NILO.
AYE. OCHOA. BOGH. AYE. PADILLA.
AYE. PORTANTINO. AYE. ROTH AYE.
RUBIO. AYE. SEYARTO. AYE.
SKINNER AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS.
AYE. STERN. AYE. UMBERG. AYE.
WAHAB. AYE. WIENER. AYE. WILK.
AYE. SENATOR HURTADO MOVES A
CALL. NEXT UP, FILE ITEM 447.
THIS IS ASSEMBLY BILL 2143.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL 2143 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CONNOLLY AND ACT RELATING TO
FARES AND MAKING AN
APPROPRIATION THEREFOR. SENATOR
DODD, AS I RISE TO OFFER YET MY
SIXTH ASSEMBLY BILL TODAY IN
THIS BODY, I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE ON AB 2143.
IT'S A STRAIGHTFORWARD CLEAN UP
BILL. DO YOU WANT TO HEAR MORE?
IT WILL CONSOLIDATE ALL CODE
SECTIONS RELATING TO STATE FAIRS
AND FAIRGROUNDS, AND IT'S ALL
BASED ON TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
FROM CDFA. THANK YOU. SENATOR.
SENATOR DODD, THANK YOU FOR THAT
THOROUGH PRESENTATION. ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
COMPREHENSIVE MEASURE? ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE? OKAY.
THAT'S TOO BAD. NO QUESTIONS FOR
THE AUTHOR. IT'S HIS SIXTH BILL.
I GUESS NOT, SENATOR WILK
QUESTION. WHAT PURPOSE DO YOU
RISE? SENATOR WILK, TO TALK IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL? AB 2143. I
DON'T HAVE A QUESTION FOR HIM. I
SIT ON THE JPA THAT OVERSEES THE
ANNUAL VALLEY FAIR AND ALFALFA
FESTIVAL, AND THESE ARE SIMPLY
TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS. AND I
ENCOURAGE AND I VOTE. ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE?
YOU KNOW WHAT THAT MEANS. YOU
KNOW WHAT THAT MEANS. THAT MEANS
SENATOR DODD GETS TO CLOSE. YES
SENATOR DODD. I'M SORRY THE
MICROPHONE WASN'T WORKING THERE.
LET'S LET'S ASK IF WE COULD HAVE
THE MICROPHONE FOR THE SENATOR.
SENATOR FROM NAPA, CAN WE HEAR
THE SENATOR FROM NAPA AGAIN,
PLEASE, SIR? WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE, SENATOR? I DECLINE. ALL
RIGHT. THE SENATOR IS SHOWING.
HE SAYS, CURB YOUR ENTHUSIASM.
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN AYE. ALVARADO. GILL AYE.
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER. AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ. AYE.
DALY. AYE. DODD. AYE. DURAZO.
EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER. AYE.
GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE. AYE.
HURTADO. AYE. JONES. AYE. LAIRD.
AYE. LEHMAN. AYE. MCGUIRE.
MENGIBAR. I'M IN. AYE. NEWMAN.
AYE. NGUYEN ANEELA. AYE. OCHOA.
AYE. PADILLA. AYE. PORTANTINO.
NÓ. ROTH AYE. RUBIO AYE. SEYARTO
AYE. SKINNER. AYE. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. AYE. STERN. AYE. UMBERG.
AYE. WAHAB. AYE. WIENER. AYE.
WILK AYE. PORTANTINO NODA. AYE
ON BEHALF OF MR. POPULARITY,
SENATOR DODD MOVES A CALL. NEXT
UP, FILE ITEM 451, THIS IS
ASSEMBLY BILL 1505. SECRETARY.
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL 1505
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER RODRIGUEZ AND
AQUILANTE. STATE GOVERNMENT.
SENATOR PORTANTINO, THIS IS YOUR
MEASURE. YOU WANT TO PASS ON
FILE? I'M READY. ALL RIGHT,
SENATOR PORTANTINO, THE FLOOR IS
YOURS. THANK YOU, MISTER
PRESIDENT. AND MEMBERS AB 1505
WOULD ESTABLISH A NARROW
EXPANSION OF A CLOSED SESSION
AUTHORITY FOR BAGLEY-KEENE OPEN
MEETING ACT FOR THE GOVERNING
BOARD OF THE CALIFORNIA
EARTHQUAKE AUTHORITY. AS I SAID,
IT'S NARROW. IT WILL, THEY'LL
STILL BE RESPONSIBLE FOR
RETAINING MANAGING EARTHQUAKE
INSURANCE POLICIES FOR ITS
PARTICIPATING HOMEOWNER
INSURANCE. IF THE GOVERNING
BOARD DISCUSSES NEGOTIATE
STRATEGIES IN PUBLIC, THEY RISK
JEOPARDIZING THEIR ABILITY TO
SECURE FAIR, LOW RATES. SO THIS
WILL ENCOURAGE THEM TO DO GOOD
GOVERNMENT BY GIVING THEM THIS
NARROW EXEMPTION SO THEY CAN
NEGOTIATE IN CLOSED SESSION. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. SENATOR
PORTANTINO, ANY DISCUSSION ON
THIS MEASURE? MEMBERS, ANY
DISCUSSION? SEEING. NO.
MICROPHONE'S UP. SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN AYE.
ALVARADO. GILL. AYE. ARCHULETA.
AYE. ASHBY AYE. ATKINS. AYE.
BECKER. AYE. BREAKSPEARE. AYE.
BRADFORD. AYE. CABALLERO. AYE.
CORTEZ. AYE. DALY. AYE. DODD.
AYE. DURAZO EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER.
AYE. AYE. GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE.
AYE. HURTADO. AYE. JONES. AYE
LAIRD. AYE. LEHMAN. AYE.
MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR. I'M IN. AYE.
NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN AYE. NILO
AYE. OCHOA AYE. PADILLA. AYE.
PORTANTINO. AYE. ROTH AYE. RUBIO
AYE. SEYARTO. AYE. SKINNER.
ASMALLWORLD. CUEVAS. AYE. STERN.
AYE. UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB AYE.
WIENER. AYE WILK. AYE SEN.
PORTANTINO MOVES TO CALL. WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE NEXT TO FILE ITEM
457, FOLLOWED BY 459, 461 AND
463. FILE ITEM 457 IS ASSEMBLY
BILL 2897 SECRETARY. PLEASE
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL 2897 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CONNOLLY AND
RELATING TO HOUSING. SENATOR
BLAKE SPEER. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT, AND MEMBERS, I RISE
TODAY ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CONNOLLY TO PRESENT AB
2897. THIS BILL WILL UPDATE THE
STATUTORY LANGUAGE USED TO
DEFINE A COMMUNITY LAND TRUST IN
STATE LAW TO REFLECT THE FULL
RANGE OF PURPOSES THAT A
COMMUNITY LAND TRUST SERVES
TODAY. AB 2897 ALSO ADDRESSES A
TECHNICAL CROSS-REFERENCING
CORRECTION IN EXISTING LAW THAT
ALLOWS COMMUNITY LAND TRUSTS TO
MAINTAIN THE PROPERTY TAX
WELFARE EXEMPTION UNDER THE SAME
CIRCUMSTANCES AS LOW INCOME
HOUSING TAX CREDIT PROJECTS.
THIS BILL HAS NO REGISTERED
OPPOSITION AND BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT, AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. MEMBERS, ANY
DISCUSSION ON THIS MEASURE? ANY
DISCUSSION. SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON I. ALVARADO. GILL. AYE.
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY. AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER. AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER BRADFORD. AYE. CABALLERO.
AYE. CORTEZ. AYE. DALY. AYE.
DODD. AYE. DURAZO. EGGMAN. AYE.
GLAZER. AYE. AYE. GONZALEZ. AYE.
GROVE AYE. HURTADO. AYE. JONES.
AYE. LAIRD. AYE. LEHMAN. AYE.
MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN AYE.
NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN AYE. NILO.
AYE. OCHOA. AYE. PADILLA. AYE.
PORTANTINO. AYE. ROTH. AYE.
RUBIO. AYE. CIERTO AYE. SKINNER.
AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE.
STERN. AYE. UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB
AYE. WIENER AYE. WILK. AYE SEN.
BLAKE. SPEAR MOVES A CALL. MOVE
NEXT TO FILE ITEM 459. THIS IS
ASSEMBLY BILL 1913. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL 1913
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER ARDIS. AN ACT
RELATING TO PUPIL SAFETY.
SENATOR BLAKE SPEER. THANK YOU,
MR. PRESIDENT AND COLLEAGUES, I
RISE TODAY TO PRESENT AB 1913
THE CHILD ABUSE PREVENTION ACT.
THIS LEGISLATION REQUIRES
MANDATED REPORTER TRAININGS IN
THE K THROUGH 12 EDUCATION SPACE
TO INCLUDE INFORMATION ON THE
PREVENTION OF CHILD ABUSE, IN
ADDITION TO THE EXISTING
TRAINING REQUIREMENTS.
CURRENTLY, THE REQUIRED CONTENT
FOR MANDATED REPORTER TRAININGS
FOCUSES ON REACTIONARY REPORTING
MEASURES. WHILE DISTRICTS ARE
ONLY ENCOURAGED TO PROVIDE
TRAINING ON PREVENTION. WHILE
MANY DISTRICTS HAVE PROACTIVELY
INCLUDED PREVENTATIVE MEASURES
INTO THEIR TRAINING. OTHER
TRAININGS FAIL TO MENTION THIS
ASPECT OF ABUSE ENTIRELY.
COMPREHENSIVE TRAINING OF
MANDATED REPORTERS SHOULD
INCLUDE THE PREVENTION OF CHILD
ABUSE, NOT JUST A REACTIONARY
PROCESS OF REPORTING SUSPECTED
ABUSE. AFTER IT HAPPENS. WHILE
MANY SCHOOL DISTRICTS HAVE
ALREADY INCLUDED IT, AB 1913
WILL CREATE A UNIVERSAL
REQUIREMENT TO PROTECT
CALIFORNIA'S CHILDREN. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE ON AB 1913. THANK YOU.
SENATOR, ANY DISCUSSION ON THIS
MEASURE? SEEING NONE. SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN.
AYE. ALVARADO. GILL. AYE.
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY. AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER. AYE. BLAKE
SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ. AYE.
DALY. AYE. DODD. AYE. DURAZO.
EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER. AYE. AYE.
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE. AYE.
HURTADO. AYE. JONES. AYE. LAIRD.
AYE. LEHMAN. AYE. MCGUIRE.
MENGIBAR. I'M IN. AYE. NEWMAN.
AYE. NGUYEN. AYE. NILO. AYE.
OKUBO. AYE. PADILLA. AYE.
PORTANTINO. AYE. ROTH. AYE.
RUBIO. AYE. SEYARTO. AYE.
SKINNER. AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS.
AYE. STERN. AYE. UMBERG. AYE.
WAHAB AYE. WIENER AYE. WILK.
AYE. SEN. SPEAR MOVES A CALL.
NEXT UP IS FILE ITEM 461. THIS
IS ASSEMBLY BILL 1524.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL 1524 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LOWENTHAL. AN ACT RELATING TO
POST-SECONDARY EDUCATION.
SENATOR MENGIBAR. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. IF AB 1524 WILL
PROVIDE COLLEGE STUDENTS WITH
ACCESS TO FREE DRUG TESTING
DEVICES, SUCH AS TEST STRIPS,
THAT CAN DETECT THE PRESENCE OF
CONTROLLED SUBSTANCES THAT ARE
COMMONLY USED TO SPIKE OR LACE
AN INDIVIDUAL'S DRINK. IT HAS
RECEIVED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND
HAS NO OPPOSITION, RESPECTFULLY
ASKING FOR AN AYE VOTE. MEMBERS.
ANY DISCUSSION ON THIS MEASURE?
ANY DISCUSSION. SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN AYE.
AYE. ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY. AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ. AYE.
DALY. AYE. DODD. AYE. DURAZO
EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER. AYE.
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE AYE.
HURTADO. AYE. JONES. AYE. LAIRD.
AYE. LEHMAN. AYE. MCGUIRE.
MENGIBAR. I'M IN. AYE. NEWMAN.
AYE. NGUYEN. AYE. NILO AYE.
OCHOA. AYE. PADILLA AYE.
PORTANTINO. AYE. ROTH. AYE.
RUBIO. AYE. SEYARTO. AYE.
SKINNER AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS.
AYE. STERN. AYE. UMBERG. AYE.
WAHAB. AYE. WIENER. AYE. WILK.
AYE. SENATOR. MENGIBAR MOVES THE
CALL. NEXT UP IS FILE ITEM 463.
THIS IS ASSEMBLY BILL 1820.
SECRETARY. PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL 1820 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
SCHIAVO. AN ACT RELATING TO
HOUSING. SENATOR BLAKE. I
BELIEVE THIS IS YOUR SIXTH BILL
THAT YOU'RE PRESENTING HERE
TODAY. IN FACT, IT'S MY SEVENTH.
AND SO I'M SURPASSING THE GOOD
SENATOR FROM SONOMA RIGHT NOW. I
THOUGHT THERE WAS SOMETHING
NOTEWORTHY ABOUT THIS
PRESENTATION OR NAPA OR BOTH.
SENATOR BLAKE, THE FLOOR IS
DEFINITELY YOURS. OKAY I'LL DO
IT VERY BRIEFLY. AB 1820 ALLOWS
HOUSING DEVELOPERS TO NØ
DEVELOPMENT FEES PRIOR TO
COMMITTING SHOVELS TO THE
GROUND. I ASK FOR AN AYE.
SECRETARY. NO. LET'S JUST SEE IF
THERE'S ANY DISCUSSION ON THIS
MEASURE. ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION?
SEEING NONE. SENATOR DODD
DOESN'T WANT TO SAY ANYTHING.
JUST CONGRATULATIONS, THEN LET'S
CALL THE ROLL. SECRETARY, CALL
THE ROLL ON THE SEVENTH BILL OF
SENATOR BLAKE SPEARS TODAY.
ALLEN AYE. ALVARADO. GILL. AYE.
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY. AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER. AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ. AYE.
DALI. AYE. DODD. AYE. DURAZO
EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER AYE.
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE AYE.
HURTADO. AYE. JONES. AYE. LAIRD.
AYE. LEHMAN. AYE. MCGUIRE.
MENGIBAR. I'M IN. AYE. NEWMAN.
AYE. NGUYEN. AYE. NILO. AYE.
OCHOA. BOGH AYE. PADILLA. AYE.
PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH. I. RUBIO.
AYE. CIERTO. AYE. SKINNER. AYE.
SMALLWOOD CUEVAS. AYE. STERN
AYE. UMBER AYE. WAHAB AYE.
WIENER AYE. WILK. AYE SENATOR
BLAKESPEAR MOVES A CALL.
WE'RE JUST TAKING A BRIEF PAUSE,
BUT I DO HAVE PRICE WATERHOUSE
BACK HERE IN THE BACK ROOM. HAVE
INDICATED THAT. SENATOR LAIRD,
YOU HAVE CARRIED SEVEN BILLS
TODAY THAT WOULD MOVE SENATOR
DODD TO THIRD PLACE ON THE LIST
OF MOST POPULARITY. OKAY. WE
JUST WANT TO KEEP THE RECORD
STRAIGHT. CONGRATULATIONS,
SENATOR LAIRD.
I KNOW THAT SENATOR MENJIVAR IS
PAYING ATTENTION. SHE'S THE
SPIRIT LEADER, AND I KNOW SHE'S
PAYING ATTENTION TO THIS, THIS
COUNTING POPULARITY ISSUE. WE
HAVE GONE SO FAST TODAY, FOLKS,
THAT THE MACHINES CAN'T EVEN
KEEP UP WITH US. JUST SO YOU
KNOW.
SO, MEMBERS, WHEN WE GET BACK ON
LINE HERE, WE'RE GOING TO START
WITH A FILE ITEM 469, FOLLOWED
BY 472, 473, 476 AND 477. AND
WE'RE ROUNDING THE BEND SO WE
CAN SEE THE, THE BARN DOORS ARE
OPEN. SO WE'RE MAKING GOOD
PROGRESS. ALL RIGHT, MEMBERS,
WE'RE GOING TO NOW BEGIN AGAIN
AT FOUR A FILE ITEM. 469, THIS
IS ASSEMBLY BILL 1284.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
BILL 1284 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RAMOS. AN ACT RELATING TO NATIVE
AMERICAN TRIBES AND SENATOR
LAIRD, THIS WOULD BE YOUR
SEVENTH, IS THAT CORRECT? THANK
YOU VERY MUCH, MR. PRESIDENT.
YOU YOU STOLE MY THUNDER BECAUSE
I WAS GOING TO SAY I WAS SO
EXCITED AT THE SEVENTH THAT
PASSING THE SENATOR FROM NAPA, I
HAD NO IDEA I WAS TYING THE
SENATOR FROM ENCINITAS. SO, THIS
BILL, AB 1284, WOULD ALLOW
FEDERALLY RECOGNIZED TRIBES IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA TO ENTER
INTO CO-GOVERNANCE AND
CO-MANAGEMENT AGREEMENTS WITH
THE CALIFORNIA NATURAL RESOURCES
AGENCY, AN AGENCY WHICH IS
FONDLY REMEMBERED BY THE SENATOR
FROM BAKERSFIELD. AT EVERY
OPPORTUNITY. AND THIS ACTUALLY
PUTS INTO PLACE A STRUCTURE THAT
WAS LONG ENVISIONED THEIR
SUPPORT ON BOTH SIDES. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. ANY DISCUSSION ON THIS
MEASURE? OKAY. IT IS ELIGIBLE
FOR UNANIMOUS, BUT WE HAVE A NOT
EVERYBODY ON THE FLOOR. SO WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE THE SECRETARY CALL
THE ROLL. ALLEN AYE. ALVARADO.
GILL. AYE. ARCHULETA. AYE.
ASHBY. AYE. ATKINS AYE. BECKER.
AYE. BLAKE. SPEER AYE. BRADFORD.
AYE. CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ.
AYE. DALLY. AYE. DODD. AYE.
DURAZO EGGMAN. GLAZER. AYE. AYE
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE. AYE.
HURTADO. AYE. JONES AYE. LAIRD.
AYE LIMON. AYE. MCGUIRE
MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN AYE. NEWMAN.
AYE. NGUYEN. AYE. NILO AYE.
OKUBO. AYE PADILLA. AYE.
PORTANTINO. AYE. ROTH. AYE.
RUBIO. AYE. CIERTO. AYE. SKINNER
AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYES.
TURN. AYE. UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB.
AYE. WIENER AYE. WILK. AYE SEN.
LAIRD MOVES THE CALL. NEXT UP IS
FILED. ITEM 472. THIS IS
ASSEMBLY BILL 2606. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL 2606
BY SENATE MEMBER AGUIAR-CURRY
AND NH P RELATING TO FOOD AND
AGRICULTURE AND MAKING AN
APPROPRIATION. THEREFORE SENATOR
PADILLA. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. I RISE TO PRESENT AB
2606 WHICH WOULD ESTABLISH
CALIFORNIA'S FIRST AGAVE
COMMISSION, WILL HELP FARMERS BE
MORE COMPETITIVE DOMESTIC AND
INTERNATIONAL MARKETS BY
CREATING THE FIRST EVER AGAVE
COMMISSION IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. THE BILL HAS
RECEIVED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND
ZERO NO VOTES. RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. MEMBERS. ANY
DISCUSSION ON THIS MEASURE? ANY
DEBATE ON THIS MEASURE? SEEING.
NONE. SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN. AYE. ALVARADO.
GILL. AYE. ARCHULETA. AYE.
ASHBY. AYE. ATKINS. AYE. BECKER.
AYE. BLAKE. SPEER. AYE BRADFORD.
AYE. CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ.
AYE. DALLI AYE. DODD. AYE.
DURAZO. EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER.
AYE. AYE. GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE
AYE. HURTADO. AYE. JONES AYE.
LAIRD. AYE. LIMON AYE. MCGUIRE.
MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN. AYE. NEWMAN.
AYE. NGUYEN. AYE. NILO. AYE.
OCHOA. AYE. PADILLA. AYE.
PORTANTINO. AYE. ROTH. AYE.
RUBIO. AYE. SEYARTO AYE.
SKINNER. AYE. SMALLWOOD CUEVAS.
AYE. STERN. AYE. UMBERG AYE.
WAHAB AYE. WIENER AYE. WILK.
AYE. SENATOR PADILLA MOVES A
CALL. ALL RIGHT. NEXT UP IS FILE
ITEM 473. THIS IS ASSEMBLY BILL
2830. SECRETARY, PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL 2830 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ROBERT RIVAS. AN ACT TO
FOSTER CARE. SENATOR MENGIBAR.
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. AB
2830 BY THE AUTHORED BY THE
SPEAKER WILL REQUIRE THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES TO ESTABLISH RELATIVE
OR KING SPECIFIC LICENSING OR
APPROVAL STANDARDS BY JANUARY
1ST, 2027, RESPECTFULLY ASKING
FOR AN AYE VOTE. ANY DISCUSSION
ON THIS MEASURE? MEMBERS. ANY
DISCUSSION. SEEING NO
MICROPHONES UP. SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN AYE.
ALVARADO. GILL. AYE. ARCHULETA
AYE. ASHBY. AYE. ATKINS AYE.
BECKER. AYE. BLAKE. SPEER AYE.
BRADFORD. AYE. CABALLERO. AYE.
CORTEZ. AYE. DALLI. AYE. DODD.
AYE. DURAZO. EGGMAN. AYE.
GLAZER. AYE. GONZALEZ. AYE.
GROVE. AYE. HURTADO. AYE. JONES.
AYE. LAIRD. AYE. LEHMAN. AYE.
MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR. I'M IN.
NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN. AYE. NILO
AYE. OCHOA. BOGH. AYE. PADILLA
AYE. PORTANTINO. AYE. ROTH. AYE.
RUBIO. AYE. CIERTO. AYE. SKINNER
AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. EYES
TURN. AYE. UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB.
AYE. WIENER. AYE WILK. AYE.
SENATOR MENGIBAR MOVES THE CALL.
NEXT UP IS FILE ITEM 4.76. THIS
IS ASSEMBLY BILL 3284.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL 3084 BY THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON ELECTIONS. AN ACT
RELATING TO ELECTIONS. SENATOR
BLAKE SPEER. THANK YOU. MR.
THANK YOU. MR. PRESIDENT. THIS
BILL IS AN ASSEMBLY ELECTIONS
OMNIBUS BILL WITH VARIOUS MINOR
AND TECHNICAL CHANGES TO THE
ELECTIONS CODE. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. MEMBERS,
ANY DISCUSSION ON THIS BILL? WE
HAVE A FULL HOUSE. THIS IS
ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL. WITHOUT OBJECTION. AYES 30
900. THE MEASURE PASSES.
CONGRATULATIONS, SENATOR BLAKE
SPEER. ALL RIGHT, MOVING ON.
THIS IS FOR ITEM 477. THIS IS
ASSEMBLY BILL 2773. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL 2773
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA. AN ACT
RELATING TO ELDERS AND DEPENDENT
ADULTS. SENATOR EGGMAN. THE
FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH, MR. PRESIDENT. THIS BILL
DEALS WITH A VERY IMPORTANT
ISSUE PROTECTING OUR SENIORS.
SOMETIMES WHEN PEOPLE ARE IN A
FACILITY, HARM OCCURS TO THEM.
SOMETIMES EVEN DEATH. THIS
CHANGES THE PREPONDERANCE OF A
GUILT PLEA. IF THE IF THE
ADMISSION OF SPOLIATION, MEANING
THE FACILITY PURPOSEFULLY
DAMAGED THE INFORMATION THAT
WENT TO FIND THAT SOMEBODY HAD
BEEN HURT, I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. MEMBERS ANY
DISCUSSION ON THIS MEASURE? ANY
DISCUSSION? SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN ALVARADO. NO. ARCHULETA.
AYE. ASHBY. ATKINS AYE. BECKER
AYE. BLAKE. SPEER BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ AYE.
DALLEY NO. DODD DURAZO. AYE.
EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER. AYE. AYE.
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE. NO
HURTADO. JONES. NO LAIRD. AYE.
LEHMAN AYE. MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR.
AYE. MIN. AYE. NEWMAN. WHEN NO.
NILO. NO. OCHOA. NO. PADILLA.
AYE. PORTANTINO. AYE. ROTH RUBIO.
AYE. CIERTO. NO. SKINNER. AYE.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE. STERN.
AYE. UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB AYE.
WIENER WILK. NO. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ALAN AYE. ASHBY
AYE. BLAKE SPEER. AYE. DODD.
AYE. HURTADO. AYE. MCGUIRE
NEWMAN. ROTH. AYE. WIENER. AYE.
ALL RIGHT. WE HAVE A FULL HOUSE
ON A VOTE OF 29 TO 9. THE
MEASURE PASSES. WE'RE MOVING ON
TO FILE ITEM 480. THIS IS
ASSEMBLY BILL 1815. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL 1815
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER WEBER. AN ACT
RELATING TO DISCRIMINATION.
SENATOR SMALLWOOD CUEVAS, THANK
YOU, MR. PRESIDENT AND
COLLEAGUES, I'M PROUD TO PRESENT
ON BEHALF OF MY COLLEAGUE,
ASSEMBLY MEMBER, DOCTOR WEBER AB
1815, AN EXPANSION OF SB 188,
OUR CROWN ACT, WHICH WAS THE
FIRST LAW IN THE NATION TO
PROHIBIT DISCRIMINATION ON THE
BASIS OF TRAITS ASSOCIATED WITH
RACE, INCLUDING HAIRSTYLES. AB
1815, WHICH COMES FROM THE
RECOMMENDATIONS OF THE
CALIFORNIA REPARATIONS TASK
FORCE, WILL EXPAND THE SCOPE TO
THE CROWN ACT, TO THE UNRUH
CIVIL RIGHTS ACT, ENSURING ALL
CALIFORNIANS RECEIVE THESE
PROTECTIONS. SENATE FLOOR
AMENDMENTS MAKE NON-SUBSTANTIAL
AND TECHNICAL CHANGES AND
INCLUDE DOUBLE JOINTING
LANGUAGE. THIS BILL IS A BLACK
CAUCUS PRIORITY AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. SENATOR, ANY
DISCUSSION ON THIS MEASURE? ANY
DEBATE ON THIS MEASURE? SEEING
NONE. SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN AYE. ALVARADO. AYE.
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY. AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER. AYE. BLAKE
SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO AYE. CORTEZ. AYE.
DALI. AYE. DODD. AYE. DURAZO.
AYE. EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER. AYE
AYE. GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE. AYE.
HURTADO. AYE. JONES. AYE. LAIRD.
AYE. LEHMAN. AYE. MCGUIRE.
MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN. AYE. NEWMAN.
AYE. NGUYEN. AYE. NILO. AYE.
OCHOA AYE. PADILLA. AYE.
PORTANTINO. AYE. ROTH. AYE.
RUBIO ACIERTO. AYE. SKINNER.
AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE.
STERN. AYE. UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB.
AYE. WIENER. AYE. WILK AYE. ON A
VOTE OF 39 TO 0, THE MEASURE
PASSES. NEXT UP IS FILE ITEM
485. THIS IS ASSEMBLY BILL 3279.
SECRETARY. PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL 3079 BY THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY. AN ACT
RELATING TO ATTORNEYS. SENATOR
UMBERG. THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT
AND COLLEAGUES. AB 3279 IS THE
ANNUAL BAR AUTHORIZATION BILL,
AS SOME OF YOU KNOW, THE
CALIFORNIA SUPREME COURT HAS
PRIMARY RESPONSIBILITY FOR THE
SUPERVISION OF THE STATE BAR. WE
SHARE SOME OF THAT
RESPONSIBILITY IN TERMS OF
OVERSIGHT. THE TOM GIRARDI
DEBACLE HAS REVEALED AND IS
CONTINUING TO REVEAL A NUMBER OF
DIFFERENT CHALLENGES THAT THE
STATE BAR HAS FACED
HISTORICALLY. THEY'VE MADE SOME
IMPROVEMENTS IN TERMS OF
ACCOUNTABILITY, IN TERMS OF
REFORMATION OF THE DISCIPLINARY
PROCESS, BUT THERE'S STILL A WAY
TO GO. STATE BAR HAS ASKED FOR A
SUBSTANTIAL FEE INCREASE FOR
ATTORNEYS TO BE ABLE TO FUND
SOME OF THESE IMPROVEMENTS, THE
ASSEMBLY BILL DOES NOT PROVIDE
FOR THE AMOUNT THAT THE BAR HAD
ACTUALLY REQUESTED, BUT DOES
INCREASE FEES BY $88 PER YEAR TO
COVER THE STATE BAR'S
COMMITMENTS, WE HAVE A
RESPONSIBILITY TO CONTINUE TO
PROVIDE OVERSIGHT OF THE BAR AND
PROVIDE THEM ADEQUATE RESOURCES
TO FUNCTION, BUT WITH
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY,
I URGE, AND I VOTE. THANK YOU.
SENATOR UMBERG. ANY DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THIS MEASURE, ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEEING
NONE. SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN ALVARADO, GIL.
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO CORTEZ. AYE. DALLY. NÓ
DODD. AYE. HUESO AYE. EGGMAN.
AYE GLAZER. AYE AYE. GONZALEZ.
AYE GROVE. NO. HURTADO AYE.
JONES. NO. LAIRD AYE. LEHMAN.
AYE MAGUIRE. MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN
AYE. NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN NO.
NILO AYE. OCHOA. BOGH PADILLA.
AYE. PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH. AYE
RUBIO. AYE. CIERTO NO. SKINNER
AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS AYE.
STERN. AYE UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB.
AYE WIENER. AYE. WILK AYE.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALLEN AYE. ALVARADO. GILL NO.
CABALLERO AYE. MCGUIRE AYE.
OCHOA BORG. ON A VOTE OF 33 TO
6, THE MEASURE PASSES. MEMBERS.
HERE'S THE NEXT SIX BILLS WE'RE
GOING TO TAKE UP IN ORDER. FILE
ITEM 488 FOUR, 9491, 494, FOUR,
98 AND 501. NEXT UP IS FILE ITEM
488. ASSEMBLY BILL 2353.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
BILL 2353 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WARD AND ACT RELATING TO
TAXATION. SENATOR PADILLA. THANK
YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. I RISE TO
PRESENT AB 2353 WHICH WOULD
ENSURE AFFORDABLE RENTAL HOUSING
DEVELOPERS CAN ACCESS THE
EXISTING WELL WELFARE PROPERTY
TAX EXEMPTION WITHOUT FLOATING
UNNECESSARY TAX PAYMENTS WHILE
THEIR APPLICATION IS UNDER
REVIEW. CURRENTLY, AFFORDABLE
RENTAL HOUSING DEVELOPERS MUST
PAY PROPERTY TAXES UP FRONT AND
SEEK REIMBURSEMENT AFTER BOTH
THE BOARD OF EQUALIZATION AND
THE COUNTY ASSESSOR HAVE
APPROVED THE DEVELOPER'S
EXEMPTION AS A RESULT, HOUSING
DEVELOPERS FLOAT HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS IN
UNNECESSARY TAX PAYMENTS FOR AS
LONG AS THREE YEARS, ONLY TO BE
REIMBURSED ONCE THEIR
APPLICATION IS APPROVED. THIS
BILL WOULD REDUCE THE COST OF
DEVELOPING DEVELOPMENT OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING BY ALLOWING
NONPROFIT, AFFORDABLE HOUSING
DEVELOPERS TO WITHHOLD RELEVANT
TAX PAYMENTS, WHILE THEIR
WELFARE EXEMPTION APPLICATIONS
ARE UNDER REVIEW. THIS BILL HAS
HAD BROAD BIPARTISAN SUPPORT,
HAS RECEIVED NO NO VOTES, AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. SENATOR
PADILLA, ANY DISCUSSION ON THIS
BILL? MEMBERS. ANY DISCUSSION?
SEEING NONE. SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE. CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN.
AYE. ALVARADO. GIL. NO.
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER. AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE CORTEZ. AYE. DALY
AYE. DODD AYE. DURAZO EGGMAN.
AYE GLAZER. AYE. AYE. GONZALEZ.
AYE GROVE. HURTADO AYE. JONES.
AYE LAIRD. LEHMAN. AYE. MCGUIRE.
AYE MENGIBAR. I'M IN. AYE
NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN. AYE. NILO.
AYE. OCHOA BORG. AYE. PADILLA.
AYE. PORTANTINO. AYE. ROTH AYE.
RUBIO SEYARTO. AYE. SKINNER.
AYE. SMALLWOOD CUEVAS. AYE.
STERN. AYE UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB
AYE. WIENER. AYE WILK. AYE.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
DURAZO. AYE GROVE. AYE LAIRD.
AYE. RUBIO AYE. ALVARADO. NÓ.
TÚI IT'S A VOTE OF 40 TO 0. THE
MEASURE PASSES. MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM 490. THIS IS ASSEMBLY
BILL 32 8082. SECRETARY, PLEASE
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL 3282 BY THE
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY.
AN ACT RELATING TO COURTS AND
DECLARING THE URGENCY THEREOF TO
TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY. SENATOR
UMBERG. THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
COLLEAGUES, I RISE TO JOIN THE
ELITE, THE REVERED SEVEN TIME
CLUB WITH AB 3282, A BILL ON
BEHALF OF THE ASSEMBLY JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE, WHICH AUTHORIZES
JUDICIAL COUNCIL OF CALIFORNIA
TO SELL THREE COURTHOUSES IN SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY. ALSO DIRECTS THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL TO REPORT TO
THE LEGISLATURE REGARDING THE
COURT'S EFFORTS TO MAKE COURT
RECORDS AVAILABLE, AND FINALLY
AUTHORIZE THE COURTS TO WORK
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF GENERAL
SERVICES TO HELP FINANCE CLIMATE
FRIENDLY RETROFITS AND COURT
FACILITIES. I URGE, AND I VOTE.
ANY DISCUSSION ON THIS MEASURE,
ANY DISCUSSION ON THIS MEASURE?
IT IS ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL THAT OBJECTIONS. EYES
39. NOES ZERO. EXCUSE ME. AYES
40. EYES HOLD ON A MOMENT.
THAT'S AYES 4040 TO 0. ON THE
URGENCY, 40 TO 0. THE MEASURE
PASSES. CONGRATULATIONS, SENATOR
UMBERG, I WOULD PUT DODD INTO
FOURTH PLACE. I THINK IF WE WERE
COUNTING CORRECTLY. OKAY WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE ON TO ITEM 491.
THIS IS ASSEMBLY BILL 2910.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL 2910 BY SENATE MEMBER
SANTIAGO. AN ACT RELATING TO
HOUSING. SENATOR SMALLWOOD
CUEVAS THANK YOU AND COLLEAGUES.
I ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SANTIAGO, PROUD TO PRESENT AB
2910, WHICH ENABLES THE CITY OF
LOS ANGELES TO ADOPT ALTERNATIVE
BUILDING REGULATIONS TO
FACILITATE THE CONVERSION OF
NONRESIDENTIAL BUILDINGS INTO
HOUSING. THERE HAVE BEEN
AMENDMENTS. THEY ARE CLARIFYING
AND TECHNICAL IN NATURE. THIS
BILL HAS RECEIVED UNANIMOUS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT, AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. MEMBERS, ANY DISCUSSION ON
THIS MEASURE? ANY DISCUSSION.
THIS IS ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL. WITHOUT OBJECTION.
AYES 40. NÓ ZERO. THE MEASURE
PASSES. NEXT UP. FILE ITEM 494
AB 1962. SECRETARY, PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL 1962 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BERMAN. AN ACT RELATING
TO CRIMES. SENATOR RUBIO. THANK
YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN OF THE SENATE, TODAY I
RISE TO PRESENT AB 1962 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERMAN AB 1962
WOULD CLOSE A LOOPHOLE IN
CURRENT LAW THAT MAY ALLOW
INDIVIDUALS TO DISTRIBUTE
PRIVATE SEXUAL IMAGES OF ANOTHER
PERSON WITHOUT THEIR CONSENT.
THIS BILL WOULD PROVIDE A NARROW
FIX IN THE STATUTE TO ENSURE
THAT SURVIVORS OF REVENGE ARE
ADEQUATELY PROTECTED IN
CALIFORNIA. WITH THAT, I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. MEMBERS.
DISCUSSION ON THIS MEASURE.
DISCUSSION. SEEING NONE,
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
JUST A MOMENT, PLEASE. LET ME
JUST CHECK. THIS IS ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. WITHOUT
OBJECTION. AYES 40. NØ ZERO. THE
MEASURE PASSES. NEXT UP, FILE
ITEM 498 AB 1919. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL 1919
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER WEBER. AN ACT
RELATING TO PUPIL DISCIPLINE.
SENATOR BRADFORD. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. 1919 WOULD ALLOW
LOCAL AGENCIES TO ADOPT AT LEAST
ONE EVIDENCE BASED BEST
PRACTICES FOR RESTORATIVE
JUSTICE ON A SCHOOL CAMPUS. FOR
A LIST OF NEW RECOMMENDATIONS
FROM THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF EDUCATION, DATA SHOWS THAT
PUNITIVE AND ZERO TOLERANCE
SCHOOL DISCIPLINE POLICIES THAT
RELY ON EXCLUSIONARY PUNISHMENT
ARE INEFFECTIVE AND
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACT BLACK
STUDENTS, PARTICULARLY BLACK
MALES AND STUDENTS WITH
DISABILITIES. BLACK STUDENTS ARE
FOUR TIMES MORE LIKELY TO BE
SUSPENDED THAN THEIR WHITE
COUNTERPARTS, WITHOUT INDICATION
TO SHOW THEY MISBEHAVE ANY MORE
THAN OTHER STUDENTS. POSITIVE
ALTERNATIVES TO SUSPENSION AND
EXPULSION, SUCH AS SCHOOLWIDE
POSITIVE BEHAVIOR INTERVENTION
AND SUPPORT, RESTORATIVE
PRACTICES AND TRAUMA INFORMED
PRACTICE. SCHOOLS ARE
DEMONSTRATED TO SUPPORT STUDENTS
AND ADDRESS HARSH AND
DISPROPORTIONATE SCHOOL
DISCIPLINE. RESTORATIVE JUSTICE
PRACTICES ENGAGE IN A
COLLABORATIVE PROBLEM SOLVING,
EMPOWERS CHANGE AND GROWTH, AND
FOCUSES ON BUILDING SYSTEMS THAT
ADDRESS DISORDERLY CONDUCT IN A
WAY THAT STRENGTHENS THE
RELATIONSHIP. THIS BILL IS BUILT
UPON AB 2598 FROM LAST SESSION
AND WOULD HELP ADDRESS REMAINING
INEQUALITIES WITHIN THE SCHOOL
AND HELP REDUCE FEELINGS OF
ISOLATION, BULLYING AND
CLASSROOM DISRUPTION, TRUANCY,
ANTI-SOCIAL BEHAVIOR AND
DISPUTES AMONG STUDENTS AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU. SENATOR BRADFORD, ANY
DISCUSSION ON THIS MEASURE?
MEMBERS. ANY DISCUSSION? SEEING
NONE. SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN AYE. ALVARADO. GILL
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ. AYE.
DALLY. NØ. DODD. AYE. DURAZO.
AYE. EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER. AYE.
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE HURTADO.
AYE. JONES. NO. LAIRD. AYE.
LEHMAN. AYE. MCGUIRE MENGIBAR.
AYE. MIN AYE. NEWMAN. AYE.
NGUYEN NILO. OCHOA. NO PADILLA.
AYE. PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH. AYE.
RUBIO. AYE. CIERTO. NO. SKINNER
AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE.
STERN. AYE. UMBERG AYE. WAHAB.
AYE. WIENER. AYE. WILK PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALVARADO. GILL NØ. GROVE
MCGUIRE. NGUYEN. NO. NILO NO.
WILK ON A VOTE OF 30 TO 7, THE
MEASURE PASSES. MEMBERS.
ACCORDING TO MY SECRET
INTELLIGENCE, HERE AT THE
PODIUM, WE HAVE LESS THAN TEN
BILLS LEFT THIS EVENING. SO
THANK YOU FOR ALL YOUR DILIGENT
CONSIDERATION. ALL RIGHT. WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE NEXT TO FILE ITEM
5.01. THIS IS ASSEMBLY BILL
3168. SECRETARY, PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL 3068 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GIBSON. AN ACT RELATING
TO THE DEPARTMENT OF MOTOR
VEHICLES. SENATOR RUBIO. THANK
YOU, LADIES AND GENTLEMEN OF THE
SENATE, I RISE TO PRESENT
ASSEMBLY BILL 3168 ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GIBSON. THIS
BILL AUTHORIZES A DMV TO REMOVE
CONFIDENTIALITY PROTECTIONS
FOLLOWING TERMINATION OF AN
OFFICE OR EMPLOYMENT. IF NO
APPEAL TO THE TERMINATION HAS
BEEN FILED, IT IS IMPORTANT THAT
WE HOLD PEOPLE ACCOUNTABLE FOR
THEIR ACTIONS. IF ACTIONS ARE
INAPPROPRIATE OR LAWS ARE
BROKEN, GIVING PRIVACY
PRIVILEGES IS SOMETHING ONLY
GIVEN TO THOSE THAT WORK. IN
PARTICULAR INDUSTRIES. ONCE
AGAIN, ONCE THE JOB IS
TERMINATED, THEY SHOULD NOT BE
HELD IN CONFIDENTIALITY. THIS
BILL HAS NO OPPOSITION AND
ENJOYS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT. WITH
THAT, I ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU, SENATOR
RUBIO. ANY DISCUSSION ON THIS
MEASURE? ANY DISCUSSION? SEEING
NONE. SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN AYE. ALVARADO. GILL.
AYE. ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER. AYE. BLAKE.
SPEAR. AYE. BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ. I. DALY.
AYE. DODD. AYE. DURAZO. AYE.
EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER. AYE. AYE.
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE AYE.
HURTADO. AYE. JONES LAIRD. AYE.
LEHMAN. AYE. MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR.
I'M IN. AYE. NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN
AYE. NILO. AYE. OCHOA AYE.
PADILLA. AYE. PORTANTINO. AYE.
ROTH. AYE. RUBIO. AYE. CIERTO.
AYE. SKINNER. AYE. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. AYE. STERN. AYE. UMBERG.
AYE WAHAB. AYE. WIENER AYE.
WILK. AYE. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBER. JONES. MCGUIRE ON
A VOTE OF 38 TO 0, THE MEASURE
PASSES. MEMBERS. WE HAVE FOUR
MORE BILLS ON ASSEMBLY. THIRD
READING. THEY ARE. FILE ITEM
258, 452, 465 AND 496. YOU'RE
KEEPING TRACK AT HOME. WE'LL
BEGIN WITH FILE ITEM 258. THIS
IS ASSEMBLY BILL 2765.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL 2765 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PELLERIN. AN ACT RELATING TO
TELECOMMUNICATIONS. SENATOR
ASHBY. THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
I RISE TO PRESENT AB 2765 ON
BEHALF OF ASSEMBLYMEMBER
PELLERIN, WHICH REQUIRES THE
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION'S
ANNUAL REPORT TO THE LEGISLATURE
TO INCLUDE AGGREGATE INFORMATION
ABOUT BACKUP POWER, RULE
VIOLATIONS AND ACTIONS TAKEN TO
ADDRESS THOSE VIOLATIONS. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. MEMBERS, ANY DISCUSSION ON
THIS MEASURE, ANY DISCUSSION IT
IS ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL. WITHOUT OBJECTION. AYES
39. ON A VOTE OF 38 TO 0, THE
MEASURE PASSES. NEXT UP. ITEM
452. THIS IS ASSEMBLY BILL 2037.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL 2037 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
PAPINEAU AN ACT RELATING TO
WEIGHTS AND MEASURES. SENATOR
BECKER. GOOD EVENING, LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN OF THE SENATE. I RISE
TO PRESENT AB 2037. THIS WILL
GIVE COUNTY SELLERS AUTHORITY TO
TEST AND VERIFY MUNICIPALLY
OWNED EV CHARGERS. THEY ARE
TASKED WITH TESTING, TESTING AND
VERIFYING COMMERCIAL MEASUREMENT
DEVICES SUCH AS GROCERY SCALES
AND GAS PUMPS. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR I VOTE. MEMBERS ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
MEASURE? ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. SEEING NONE. SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN.
AYE. ALVARADO. GILL. AYE.
ARCHULETA ASHBY. AYE. ATKINS.
AYE. BECKER. AYE. BLAKE SPEER.
AYE. BRADFORD. AYE. CABALLERO.
AYE. CORTEZ. AYE. DALY. AYE.
DODD AYE. DURAZO. AYE. EGGMAN
AYE. GLAZER. GONZALEZ. AYE.
GROVE AYE. HURTADO. AYE. JONES.
LAIRD. AYE. LEHMAN. AYE.
MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN.
AYE. NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN AYE.
NILO AYE. OKUBO. AYE. PADILLA.
AYE. PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH RUBIO.
SEYARTO AYE. SKINNER AYE.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS AYE. STERN
AYE. UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB. AYE.
WIENER. AYE. WILK. AYE PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ARCHULETA GLAZER. JONES. MCGUIRE
ROTH. AYE. RUBIO. AYE ON A VOTE
OF 36 TO 0, THE MEASURE PASSES.
NEXT UP IS FILE ITEM 465. THIS
IS ASSEMBLY BILL 3258.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL 3258 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BRYANT. AN ACT RELATING TO
SAFETY AND EMPLOYMENT. SENATOR
DURAZO. THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
I AM HERE TO PRESENT AB 3258 ON
BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BRYANT. THROUGHOUT THE HISTORY,
REFINERY WORKERS HAVE FOUGHT
TIRELESS BATTLES TO SECURE THEIR
RIGHTS AND PROTECTIONS. THEY
FACE HAZARDOUS WORKING
CONDITIONS. AB 3258 WOULD MAKE A
SIMPLE BUT IMPACTFUL CORRECTION
TO OUR PROCESS SAFETY MANAGEMENT
REGULATIONS TO PROTECT THOSE
WORKERS. THIS BILL HAS BEEN
BIPARTISAN AND ON CONSENT
THROUGHOUT THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AYE VOTE. ANY DISCUSSION ON THIS
MEASURE. IT IS ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. WITHOUT
OBJECTION. AYES 38. NO ZERO. THE
MEASURE PASSES. OUR FINAL ITEM
ON ASSEMBLY THIRD READING IS
FILED. ITEM 496. THIS IS
ASSEMBLY BILL 2875. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL 2875 BY SENATE
MEMBER FRIEDMAN AND AQUILINA.
WETLANDS. SENATOR CABALLERO.
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. I RISE
TO PRESENT AB 2875 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FRIEDMAN. THIS BILL
DECLARES IT A STATE POLICY TO
ENSURE NO NET LOSS IN THE
QUANTITY, QUALITY AND PERMANENCE
OF WETLANDS, ACREAGE, WETLANDS
PROVIDE CRITICAL HABITAT FOR
ENDANGERED SPECIES AND STATEWIDE
DEVELOPMENT PROJECTS HAVE
REDUCED WETLANDS TO A MERE 10%
OF THEIR ORIGINAL SIZE. THE LOSS
OF COASTAL WETLAND WETLANDS IS
EVEN MORE ALARMING. 95% OF
FORMERLY ABUNDANT LAGOONS AND
MARSHES ALONG CALIFORNIA'S
COASTLINE HAVE BEEN DESTROYED.
MY DISTRICT IS HOME TO THE
LARGEST REMAINING CONTIGUOUS
BLOCK OF FRESHWATER WETLANDS IN
THE STATE. IN FACT, THE
GRASSLANDS ECOLOGICAL AREA HAS
BEEN DESIGNATED AS A WETLAND OF
INTERNATIONAL IMPORTANCE. IN
1993, GOVERNOR PETE WILSON
ISSUED EXECUTIVE ORDER W 5993,
ESTABLISHING A STATE POLICY TO
HAVE NO NET LOSS OF THE LONG
TERM GAIN OF WETLANDS SINCE
THEN. HOWEVER CALIFORNIA HAS
CONTINUED TO LOSE MORE WETLAND
ACRES THAN IT REPLACES. AB 2875
DOES NOT CREATE ANY NEW
PROTECTIONS OR PROGRAMS, NOR
DOES IT PROVIDE THE STATE WITH
MORE ENFORCEMENT AUTHORITY. IT
ISN'T MEANT TO STOP NEW HOUSING
OR DEVELOPMENT. THE BILL MERELY
PUTS INTO STATUTE THAT IT IS THE
POLICY OF THE STATE TO PROTECT,
CONSERVE AND RESTORE WETLANDS.
IT HAS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT,
RECEIVED NO NO VOTES AND NO
OPPOSITION. RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU.
SENATOR CAVALLERO. ARE THERE
SOME QUESTIONS OR DEBATE ON THE
FLOOR? IT SEEMS LIKE THERE'S
SOME QUESTION OR DEBATE. SENATOR
CARILLO, DID YOU MISS SOMETHING
IN YOUR SCRIPT? IS THERE MORE
YOU NEEDED TO SAY? NO. YOU GOT
IT ALL COVERED. ALL RIGHT. ANY
QUESTIONS FOR THIS? TO THE
AUTHOR. LARA MANAGER. ALL RIGHT,
SO. I GUESS YOU DON'T GET TO
CLOSE. SENATOR. SENATOR. WE'RE
GOING TO GIVE YOU A BONUS.
CLOSE. WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE?
NO. ALL RIGHT. SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALAN AYE. GILL.
AYE. ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY. AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER AYE.
BREAKSPEARE. AYE. BRADFORD AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ. AYE.
DALY. DODD AYE. DURAZZO. AYE.
EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER. AYE.
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE HURTADO.
JONES LAIRD. AYE. LEHMAN. AYE.
MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR. AYE MIN. AYE.
NEWMAN AYE. NGUYEN. AYE. NILO
AYE. OKUBO. AYE. PADILLA AYE.
PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH. AYE.
RUBIO. ACIERTO SKINNER. AYE.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE. STERN.
AYE UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB. AYE.
WIENER. AYE WILK. AYE PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. DALY.
GROVE GROVE. AYE. HURTADO.
JONES. MCGUIRE SEYARTO. ALL
RIGHT. ON A VOTE OF 35 TO 0, THE
MEASURE PASSES. MEMBERS. WE HAVE
FIVE BILLS ON UNFINISHED
BUSINESS. THESE ARE. SENATE
BILLS HAVE COME BACK FROM THE
ASSEMBLY. CONGRATULATIONS TO
THESE AUTHORS. AND THEN WE HAVE
OUR ITEMS ON, ON, ON CALL AND
THEN WE'LL BE AND WE'LL GO BACK
TO MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS. AND
I THINK WE COULD BE DONE FOR THE
NIGHT. SO THE FIVE BILLS THAT
ARE COMING BACK ON UNFINISHED
BUSINESS ARE FILED ITEMS 198,
200, 202, 205 AND 206. WE'LL
BEGIN WITH FILE ITEM 198 SB
1022. SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL 1022 BY SENATOR
SKINNER. AN ACT RELATING TO
CIVIL RIGHTS. ALL RIGHT.
SPEAKING TO ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS,
SENATOR SKINNER. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. MEMBERS SB 1022 IS
BACK FOR CONCURRENCE FROM THE
ASSEMBLY. IT ONLY HAD CHAPTERING
AMENDMENTS, NOTHING ELSE, NO
OTHER TECHNICAL OR SUBSTANTIVE
AMENDMENTS. AND I ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. SENATOR
SKINNER, ANY DISCUSSION ON THE
AMENDMENTS? NO DISCUSSION ON THE
AMENDMENTS. OKAY. SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN.
AYE. ALVARADO. NO. ARCHULETA.
AYE. ASHBY. AYE. ATKINS. AYE.
BECKER. AYE. BLAKE. SPEER. AYE.
BRADFORD. AYE. CABALLERO. AYE.
CORTEZ. AYE. DALY. NO. DODD.
AYE. DURAZO. AYE. EGGMAN. AYE.
GLAZER. AYE. GONZALEZ. AYE.
GROVE. NO. HURTADO AYE. JONES.
LAIRD AYE. LEMON. AYE. MCGUIRE.
MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN AYE. NEWMAN.
AYE. NGUYEN NO. NILO. NO. OCHOA.
NO. PADILLA AYE. PORTANTINO.
AYE. ROTH. AYE. RUBIO ACIERTO.
NO SKINNER. AYE. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. AYE. STERN. AYE. UMBERG.
AYE. WAHAB AYE. WIENER. AYE
WILK. NO PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. JONES. MCGUIRE ON A
VOTE OF 30 TO 8, THE ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
WE'LL MOVE NEXT TO FILE ITEM
200. THIS IS SENATE BILL 1210.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL 1210 BY SENATOR SKINNER. AN
ACT TWO UTILITY SERVICE. SENATOR
SKINNER. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. MEMBERS Ã SB 1210 IS
BACK FOR CONCURRENCE. THIS IS A
BILL THAT CREATES SOME
TRANSPARENCY ABOUT THE FEES THAT
OUR UTILITIES CHARGE FOR
HOOKUPS. IT THE ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS ADDED AN ESTIMATED TO
THE FEE SCHEDULES RATHER THAN
SPECIFIC EXEMPTED UTILITIES WITH
FEWER THAN 4000 SERVICE
CONNECTIONS AND ADDED DETAILS
FOR WHAT UTILITIES MUST SHOW FOR
A HARDSHIP EXEMPTION. AND WITH
THAT, I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
MEMBERS, ANY DISCUSSION ON THE
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS? ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION ON THE ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS? SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN. AYE ALVARADO. GILL. NO.
ARCHULETA AYE. ASHBY. AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER. AYE. BLAKE
SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ. AYE.
DALLY. NÓ. DODD. AYE. DURAZZO.
AYE. EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER. AYE.
AYE. GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE NO.
HURTADO AYE. JONES. NO. LAIRD
AYE. LIMON. AYE. MCGUIRE.
MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN NEWMAN. AYE
NGUYEN. NO. NILO AYE. OCHOA.
AYE. PADILLA. AYE. PORTANTINO
AYE. ROTH. AYE. RUBIO. AYE.
CIERTO. NO SKINNER. AYE.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE. STERN.
AYE. UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB. AYE.
WIENER. AYE. WILK. AYE. PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
MCGUIRE. MIN. AYE ON A VOTE OF
33 TO 6, THE MEASURE PASSES. THE
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. NEXT UP IS FILE
ITEM 202. THIS IS SB 1357.
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL 1357 BY SENATOR WAHAB. AN
ACT TO HOUSING. SENATOR WAHAB.
THANK YOU. I RISE TO PRESENT SB
1357 BACK ON CONCURRENCE. SB
1357 IS A BILL RELATIVE TO THE
HOUSING AUTHORITY OF ALAMEDA
COUNTY, AND IT'S ABOUT DATA
TRANSPARENCY, ACCESSIBILITY AND
GOOD GOVERNANCE. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. ANY
DISCUSSION ON THIS MEASURE, ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION. IT IS
ELIGIBLE FOR A UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL. SEEING NO OBJECTIONS.
AYE'S 39. NÓ ZERO. THE ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
NEXT UP IS FILE ITEM 205. THIS
IS SB 1046. SECRETARY, PLEASE
READ. SENATE BILL 1046 BY
SENATOR LAIRD. AN ACT RELATING
TO SOLID WASTE. SENATOR LAIRD,
WOULD THIS BE YOUR EIGHTH BILL?
YES. IF YOU COUNT CONCURRENCES.
CONGRATULATIONS ON THAT. YES.
THE FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK YOU,
MR. PRESIDENT. THIS BILL CREATES
A PROGRAMMATIC ENVIRONMENTAL
IMPACT REPORT FOR ORGANIC WASTE
FACILITIES. THE ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS WERE TECHNICAL AND
CLARIFYING IN NATURE THEIR
SUPPORT ON BOTH SIDES. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. MEMBERS, ANY DISCUSSION ON
THIS MEASURE? ANY DISCUSSION.
THIS IS ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL. SEEING NO OBJECTIONS.
AYES 39. NØ ZERO. THE ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN. AND
FINALLY WE'LL GO TO FILE ITEM
206. THIS IS SB 1209. SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL 1209.
SENATOR CORTEZ, AN ACT RELATING
TO LOCAL GOVERNMENT. SENATOR
CORTEZ. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. AND SENATORS, I RISE
TODAY TO PRESENT SB 1209, WHICH
IS BACK ON CONCURRENCE. THE
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS LIMIT THE
BILL TO APPLICATIONS OF LOCAL
AGENCY FORMATION COMMISSION.
ACTUALLY APPROVES. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I
VOTE. ANY DISCUSSION ON THE
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS? ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION? THIS IS ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. SEEING NO
OBJECTIONS. AYES 39. NÓ ZERO.
THE ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. ALL RIGHT,
MEMBERS, WE ARE GOING TO GO TO
BILLS ON CALL. SO WE'RE GOING TO
PAUSE FOR JUST A MOMENT. COULD
ASK ALL THE SENATORS TO COME TO
THEIR DESKS SO WE CAN GIVE ALL
OF OUR ATTENTION TO THAT. THAT
WORK. MEMBERS, WHILE WE ARE
COMPILING THE ON CALL LIST FOR
EVERYONE TO PARTICIPATE IN, I'M
GOING TO MOVE BACK TO MOTIONS
AND RESOLUTIONS PURSUANT TO
SENATE RULE 29.1 D, THE
FOLLOWING BILLS ARE REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON RULES SB SEVEN,
SB 278, SB 285, SB 295, SB 393,
SB 532, SB 536, SB 551, SB 632,
AND SB 639.
OKAY, MEMBERS, I JUST WANTED TO
ASK AS WE GO TO BILLS ON CALL,
IF I COULD HAVE ALL THE MEMBERS
WHO HAVE BILLS ON CALL THAT THEY
NEED TO PARTICIPATE IN TO PLEASE
COME BACK TO THEIR DESKS SO THE
CLERK CAN HEAR YOUR VOTE CLEARLY.
WE HAVE ALL THE MEMBERS COME
BACK TO THEIR DESKS. PLEASE ALL
RIGHT. THANKS FOR GIVING THE
CLERK YOUR ATTENTION. WE'RE
GOING TO BEGIN WITH FILE ITEM
349. SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. GLAZER I
MCGUIRE. I MIN NEWMAN. RUBIO
UMBERG. ON A VOTE OF 22 TO 14,
THE MEASURE PASSES. NEXT UP IS
FILE ITEM 430. SECRETARY, PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLL. CABALLERO MCGUIRE.
I MENGIBAR I PORTANTINO I
SKINNER. AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS
I CABALLERO. AYE ON A VOTE OF 40
TO 0, THE MEASURE PASSES. NEXT
UP IS FILE ITEM 445. SECRETARY
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL. ALVARADO,
GIL, I DURAZO I MCGUIRE. I ON A
VOTE OF 40 TO 0. THAT MEASURE
PASSES. NEXT UP IS FILE ITEM
296. SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. DURAZO I JONES,
MCGUIRE. I JONES I ON A VOTE OF
40 TO 0. THE MEASURE PASSES.
NEXT UP IS FILE ITEM 446.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. CABALLERO
DURAZO. I EGGMAN MCGUIRE I
EGGMAN I CABALLERO I. VERY
DELICIOUS. I DIDN'T GET THAT
VOTE. ON A VOTE OF 40 TO 0, THAT
MEASURE PASSES. NEXT UP IS FILE
ITEM 447. SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. DURAZO I
MCGUIRE. I ON A VOTE OF 40 TO 0.
THAT MEASURE PASSES. SOMEONE
MENTIONED TO ME THAT THERE ARE
SOME REFRESHMENTS IN THE BACK
ROOM THAT ARE AVAILABLE TO
MEMBERS, AND IT'S SUGGESTED THAT
THEY'RE PRETTY GOOD. I WAS
CHOOSING MY WORDS CAREFULLY ON
THAT SO YOU CAN INTERPRET IT AS
YOU SEE FIT. NEXT UP IS NOT
HERE. WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO
FILE ITEM 451. MEMBERS PLEASE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. DURAZO I MCGUIRE
I ON A VOTE OF 40 TO 0 THAT
MEASURE PASSES. NEXT UP IS FILE
ITEM 457. SECRETARY, PLEASE OPEN
THE ROLL FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
BLAKE, SPEER, Ã DURAZO I
MCGUIRE I ON A VOTE OF 40 TO 0.
THAT MEASURE PASSES. NEXT UP,
FILE ITEM 459, PLEASE OPEN THE
ROLL FOR ABSENT MEMBERS. DURAZO
MCGUIRE I DURAZO I ON A VOTE OF
40 TO 0. THAT MEASURE PASSES.
WE'LL MOVE TO FILE ITEM 463.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. DURAZO I MCGUIRE.
I ON A VOTE OF 40 TO 0. THAT
MEASURE PASSES NEXT UP, FILE
ITEM 461. PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. DURAZO I MCGUIRE I ON A
VOTE OF 40 TO 0. THAT MEASURE
PASSES. WILL MOVE TO FILE ITEM
469. SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. DURAZO I EGGMAN
I MCGUIRE I ON A VOTE OF 40 TO
0, THAT MEASURE PASSES. NEXT UP
IS FILE ITEM 472. SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
DURAZO I MCGUIRE. I ON A VOTE OF
40 TO 0. THAT MEASURE PASSES OUR
FINAL ITEM ON CALL IS FILE ITEM
473. SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. DURAZO I
MCGUIRE. I MIN I ON A VOTE OF 40
TO 0. THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS, I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
A GOOD SESSION. THIS AFTERNOON
AND THIS EVENING. I APPRECIATE
ALL YOUR COOPERATION. IF THERE'S
NO OTHER BUSINESS, SENATOR
MCGUIRE, THE DESK IS CLEAR, MR.
PRESIDENT. MEMBERS BEFORE 8:00,
NEARLY 100 BILLS COMING OUT OF
THE SENATE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
TO THE MEMBERS ACROSS THE AISLES
FOR ALL OF YOUR WORK. I WANT TO
SAY THANK YOU TO OUR PRESIDING
OFFICER, MR. PRESIDENT. THANK
YOU SO MUCH TO THE DESK TEAM.
AND FOR BOTH THE REPUBLICAN AND
DEMOCRATIC STAFFS, FOR ALL THEIR
HARD WORK, WE ARE GOING TO BE
GOING LATE TOMORROW. REMEMBER,
WE ARE IN AT 10 A.M. TOMORROW
AND BRING YOUR SLEEPING BAGS,
BECAUSE WE'RE GOING TO BE HERE
LATE TOMORROW NIGHT. WE WILL
ALSO BE HERE LATE TOMORROW NIGHT
ON WEDNESDAY. OUR GOAL FOR
TOMORROW 100 TO 150 BILLS. THE
GOAL FOR WEDNESDAY 150 TO 200
BILLS. SO WE GOT SOME LONG DAYS
AND NIGHTS AHEAD. MR. PRESIDENT,
UNTIL NEXT TIME. OUR NEXT FLOOR
SESSION IS SCHEDULED FOR
TUESDAY, AUGUST 27TH AT 10 A.M.
THANK YOU, MR. PRO TEM. THE
SENATE IS ADJOURNED. WE WILL
RECONVENE TUESDAY AT 10 A.M.